hey everyone welcome to simply launch
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning the complete software
testing
but before we begin i would like to take
a quick confirmation from the viewers if
i'm clearly audible and the screen is
visible if yes kindly type yes in the
chat section and if there are any
problems that we could rectify please do
let us know in the chat section
all right i see a lot of positive
responses from our viewers thank you now
i think it's clear to get started so
before we get started with software
testing i would like to tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you are one of those
tech geeks in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's session
so at first we will get started with
selenium and in selenium section we will
learn the advent of selenium then
followed by that we will understand what
exactly is selenium and the
technicalities of selenium followed by
that we will understand the selenium
tool suite then we will learn how to
install selenium in our local systems
then we will learn the selenium ide
tutorial followed by that we will get
started with selenium webdriver tutorial
so once we are done with the selenium
webdriver tutorial we will get started
with xpath and selenium webdriver
followed by that we will learn selenium
chrome driver tutorial
once we are done with the selenium
chrome driver tutorial we will get
started with test ng annotations then we
will have a head on head comparison with
selenium and qtp followed by that we
will go through selenium jobs and salary
trends in the current id industry
and finally to make things interesting
we carried out a survey on the major
testing software companies and collected
some most frequently asked interview
questions based on selenium now this
will be helpful for your software
testing career so followed by selenium
we have another tool that is j meter so
we will get started with j meter
installation then we will learn
performance testing followed by that we
will learn jmeter load testing and
advancing ahead we will learn about
jmeter api testing and finally in jmeter
part we will learn the jmeter script
recording so once we are done with the
jmeter script recording and jmeter tool
we will get ahead and learn the chain
gains
so in jenkins part we will have a brief
tutorial about what exactly is devops
where we will understand the
fundamentals of devops so that we have a
clear idea what we are dealing with and
why we are using jenkins and software
testing followed by that we will learn
the critical part of ci cd pipeline then
we will get started with what is jenkins
and then we will learn how to install
jenkins in our local systems once we are
done with the installation part we will
go through continuous integrations in
collaboration with jenkins and finally
to make things interesting we are
including some most frequently asked
critical jenkins-based interview
questions
so with that we are done with the agenda
and i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now without further ado let's get
started hey everyone
have you ever thought
what would have helped netflix to evolve
from shipping dvds to streaming videos
over the web
or
what would have helped amazon to predict
how much equipment to buy to meet
traffic demands
how do you think nasa was able to
analyze data from mars rover's curiosity
what would have made it possible for
walmart to become the kink of big box
retailers or what would have helped
facebook to refresh its mobile app so
rapidly
the answer to all these questions is
devops
the devops market generated 3.36 billion
dollars in 2017 and it is expected to
generate
9.40 billion dollars by 2023
devops is helping many organizations to
automate their entire process the
process allows any organization to
create and improve their products at a
faster pace than traditional models
so now let's see what is devops
devops as the name suggests is a
combination of two practices dev refers
to development and ops refers to
operations
devops is not a workflow but a culture
that brings these two teams together the
development team writes codes for new
products security updates and bug fixes
while the operation team looks after the
servers and makes sure that the
deployments happen more reliably and
frequently
the main focus of devops is towards
integrating these two teams to improve
collaboration and increase productivity
by automating the entire process of
software development
devops has several stages and tools to
ensure that all the process is
implemented in the best possible manner
let us look at all these stages with the
tools that play a very significant role
in that phase
beginning with the development phase the
first step is to put down a plan that
includes modules and the algorithms to
be used in the software
once the plan is finalized it is
developed with tools like git
as git helps to store all the codes and
different versions of those codes
this is called the version control
system
this code is now fetched and made
executable in the next stage and that is
called the build phase the phase uses
tools like gradle and maven
after the code is made executable it is
supposed to be tested
the next stage tests the code for any
bugs and the most famous tool used in
this phase is selenium
once the testing is done deployment
comes into consideration this is where
the work of the operations team begins
in the deployment phase the product is
deployed
and this deployed product is
continuously configured to the desired
state
the tools that could be used to automate
these phases are ansible puppet and
docker
the product from here is continuously
monitored for any failures
and the most common tool that makes it
possible is negios
the feedback of all the monitoring is
sent back to the planning phase this
process is repeated in continuous cycles
and this happens until a satisfactory
result is reached
this completes the entire devops cycle
that is the process of automation from
the planning phase to the monitoring
phase
this is what is referred to as the core
of devops lifecycle the integration
phase
jenkins another devops tool is known for
sending the code for build and test and
if this code passes the test it is
further deployed and monitored
let's have a look at some features that
are making industries move towards
devops
increasing customer satisfaction
improved response time fewer chances of
implementation failure
reduction in it cost
better business agility
high employee productivity and
satisfaction
faster delivery
better release control
frequent software releases
better collaboration among teams
automated server configuration
now when you know so much about devops
you must be curious about what would the
future of devops hold it is quite
evident that devops is on the rise and
it is going to have a long way ahead
there are several fields that devops is
going to be explored in in the near
future
every organization has started leaning
towards automation so devops will play a
significant role in new upcoming
organizations when everything moves
towards automation there will be a need
for devops in the security field devops
framework in ai and ml will help the
devops team to focus on innovation and
creativity by enabling them to manage
the amount and speed of data more
efficiently
devops focuses on infrastructure as code
which ensures continuity as all the
processes from building to staging are
configured automatically with no place
for human error
the future of devops will make the
culture more accessible there is no
industry that would not want to shift
towards more reliability in deployment
every organization wishes to deliver its
product in shorter durations and reduce
the gap between its development team and
the operations team
all these scenarios are going to take
devops to the new height very soon
some organizations have already shifted
towards devops and many are planning to
do the same
hence the jobs for devops engineers are
certainly going to rise in the market in
the near future
hey there welcome into the world of
selenium if you are going to embark on a
journey of automation i promise you this
is the right place to start so let me
take you on the first lap of this
journey this is a video tutorial what is
selenium from simply learn what is in it
for you before you start understanding
any automation tool it's good to look
back into what manual testing is all
about what are its challenges and how an
automation tool overcomes these
challenges challenges are always
overcome by inventing something new so
let's see how selenium came into
existence and how did it evolve to
become one of the most popular web
application automation tool selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components and we
will be looking into each of them as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
understanding the advantages and
limitations of selenium and how do we
work around it selenium jobs and salary
very important isn't it you are here to
learn selenium you definitely want to
know what's the market demand on the
skill what what you will be once you are
skilled on this automation tool so what
we will do we'll just discuss some stats
on the job market related to test
automation and selenium in particular
alright so let's get started manual
testing and its challenges what is
manual testing manual testing mainly
involves physical execution of test
cases against various application and to
do what to detect bugs and errors so as
a definition if you can say it is one of
the primitive methods of testing a
software execution of test cases without
using any automation tools it does not
require the knowledge of any automation
tools and can practically test any
application this could be as simple a
definition can be let's do one thing
let's take an example right before we
start understanding why what are the
challenges of manual testing and why we
have to really look into any automation
tools let's take a simple example say we
have a simple use case as a user i want
to log into my web application using
username and password a very common use
case isn't it and this is a common use
case for any kind of web application
under test now let's say for example i
have a web application here say i have
this
community.simplylearn.com for me to
actually enter into this application
what i need to do is first log into this
application so this is a simple login
page which accepts a user id or an email
id a password and you click on the login
now as a tester you would write multiple
test cases to test this use case for
example you will have multiple data test
cases like valid credentials invalid
credentials null value and so on you
will also test multiple links on this
page probably the forget password link
the sign up now so whatever links are
made available you're going to test that
then you will say it as this check box
so you will check the remember me
functionality and when you log in back
again you want to validate if all your
previous data are filled up you will
also check for error messages on an
invalid login you will do accessibility
testing you will also do a performance
on this page like say for example
response time after you click on login
button and so on so while you are doing
a manual testing literally you can do
any kind of test you want so this is
what you do in the first place and then
you start executing this test cases one
by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to rerun all these test cases
again and again until all your bugs are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now this is a very simple use case
now let's look at a little complex use
case now say you have an account
creation form like this so i have this
online pan application form right this
is still a simpler form i would say now
look at the amount of data you need to
fill here each and every field you need
to test and you need to test this with
hundreds of transactions because you're
going to have those kind of data sets
with you and then you're going to repeat
them again and again until you are
satisfied that your application is
working as per it is designed so now if
you go back to our presentation now this
brings us to the first demerit of the
manual testing and what it is this is
very time consuming process and hence
it's going to get very boring for any
manual tester also it is more error
prone the risk of error is pretty high
why because it is done manually and
human mistakes are bound to happen
requires presence of tester all the time
since its manual execution tester's
presence is required all the time one
needs to keep doing manual steps over
and over again and hence he needs to be
sitting in front of his pc manual
creation of logs and repositories
creating manual reports grouping them
formatting them so that they are like a
good looking reports sending those
reports manually to all the stakeholders
say collecting logs from the various
machines after you execute the test
cases consolidating all those results
and logs right creating repositories
maintaining them wow this is a huge long
list of mundane tasks one needs to do
and this you need to do a do again and
again until your testing is completed
right so this is going to be a manual
process and it's going to be very
tedious and as i said it was also error
pro limited scope the scope of manual
testing is very limited for example say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
what you do you will pick up choose your
test cases and then execute that way you
are kind of limiting the scope of
testing also say working with large
amount of data which is manually pretty
impractical what about performance
testing so you want to say collect
certain metrics on various performance
measures as a part of your performance
testing you want to simulate certain
multiple loads on your application which
is under test hence performing this
manually is definitely not feasible and
to top it all the say you're working in
an agile model where your code is being
churned out by developers say every week
testers are building their test and they
are executing them as and when the bills
are made available to them for testing
now this happens iteratively and hence
you will need to run all the test cases
which you have created multiple times
during your development process and
doing this manually is going to become
definitely very tedious and boring and
is this really effective way of doing it
not at all so what do we do we automate
it so this tells us why we want to
automate one one is for the faster
execution two to be less error prone and
the most importantly to help you run
your test cases frequently as many times
as you want so there were many tools
available in the market today for
automation so one such tool is selenium
advent of selenium much before selenium
there were various tools in the market
like rft qtp just to name a few popular
ones selenium was introduced by a
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
manual testing his application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as javascript test runner he
also made this open source which later
was renamed as selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence since
then selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool to test web application so
what is selenium selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tool
for automating your web application it
enables us to test web application on
all kind of browsers like ie chrome
firefox safari edge opera and even the
headless browser selenium is an open
source and it's platform independent the
biggest reason why people are preferring
this tool is because it is free of cost
whereas the qtp and rft which i
mentioned earlier are the chargeable
tools selenium is also a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web application it is not a single
tool it has multiple components in it
which we will be seeing in detail in
some time and all these tools together
they help us test the web application
you can run selenium scripts on any
platform it is platform independent as
and why it is platform independent
because it is developed in javascript
it's very common for manual testers not
to have in-depth programming knowledge
so the selenium has a record and replay
back capability and this tool is called
as selenium ide which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
then you just have to replay the script
so mainly this is used for demo purposes
because selenium itself is such a
powerful tool and it offers so rich
functionality you would want to be in a
position to take the advantage of all
its future however if you have testers
who do not have enough of programming
knowledge to start with there is still
this id which is a record replay tool
which you can use to create your test
scripts it also provides support for
different programming languages like
java python c-sharp ruby and so on so
you can literally write your test
scripts in any language you like or
which you know of so one need not again
know a complete in-depth or an advanced
knowledge of any of these languages
selenium supports different operating
systems and browsers it supports windows
max linux and say if you want to run
your test on ubuntu machines yes that is
also possible it's on any platform of
your choice selenium you can run the
test cases selenium suite of tools so
now let's go little more deeper into the
selenium so as i said it is a suite of
twos and these are the major components
of the selenium selenium ide selenium
remote control which is in short called
as rc selenium web driver and selenium
grid from selenium 3.0 version onwards
you will not find the remote control
anymore because it has been deprecated
but you still have your id webdriver and
grid components now let's take a deeper
look into each of these components and
understand how they function in this
suite of tools selenium integrated
development environment which is called
as selenium ide so it is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it's an integrated development
environment it has a record and playback
functionality and it's very very simple
and easy to use too however it is mainly
used as a prototyping and not used for
creating the actual automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitations since it's just a record
and replay tool so this ide is available
as a firefox plugin and a chrome
extension so either you can use firefox
or the chrome browser to record your
test scripts the commands created in the
scripts where you are going to record
are these commands are called selenius
commands and these are the commands
which interact with your browser you can
also write some of these commands
manually while you're recording your
scripts and we'll see how to do that
when we talk about the id in detail and
it is again a platform independent so
you can deploy id on any platform of
your choice so you can have it on your
windows linux and macros however the
only requirement is you should have
either chrome or firefox browser support
on that particular platform earlier
selenium ide was only a firefox
extension it died with the firefox
version 54 or i55 i guess so ide was not
supported from the 55 version onwards
and this was sometime during 2017.
however very recently all new brand
selenium ide has been launched by apply
tools and they have made it cross
browser that is it is available both on
chrome and firefox now so you can
install this extension as a chrome
extension or as an add-on on your
firefox browser it's a completely
revamped version which was done by apply
tools they literally rewrote the
complete code and now they have made it
available on the github under the apache
2.0 license and it also comes with many
new features now like reusability of
test cases it has a better debugging
technology now and most importantly it
supports parallel test execution it has
introduced an utility called selenium
side runner that allows your test cases
to run on any browser so you can create
your automation using your ide on chrome
or firefox however through the side
runner from your command prompt you can
execute any of your test cases on any
browser of your choice and thus by
achieving your cross browser testing you
can also run parallel testing using grid
without writing any specific code to do
this again this can be done using the
selenium site runner and having the grid
installation done so let's look at how
ide looks like and what are its
components are and how do we work with
ide let's go to the firefox browser now
and launch the ide and see how the id
looks so let me go to my firefox now on
this browser if you can see here there
is an icon here which says selenium id
and this appears after you go ahead and
install the selenium id plugin so now
i'll just go click on this and then i
already have a project created so this
is the id window which gets open for me
i have a pre-recorded script here and
what the script does is i just open
amazon dot in website and i am searching
for the product iphone also i have an
assertion statement here which asserts
for the web page title and then i'm
closing the browser so let's first
execute the script and see how it works
and then we will get into the details of
what are the different components
available on this id so for me to
execute what i will do is it uh id has a
very beautiful feature here to control
the speed of the execution so what i'll
do is i'll reduce the speed a little bit
so that you should be able to see the
complete execution step by step now to
execute the script i'll just go here and
say run current test so this opens the
firefox window and the amazon dot in
website it should search for iphone
product now then it is going to do the
title assertion and close the process so
if you look here all the statements look
in green now so that means every step
has been executed successfully and there
are no errors so now let's look at the
components of this id so the first
component which you need to understand
is how do you record the test so there
is a start recording button made
available to you clicking on which you
can launch any website of the
application under test and you can start
recording your steps and once you have
recorded you can use this play button
which is nothing but your run current
test button to execute your test so if
you want to execute multiple tests then
you have an option to do so here which
is run alt s this particular window what
you are seeing here right so this is the
window where you have all your commands
which gets recorded when you record your
script and these are pretty simple
commands and they're very
self-explanatory like say for example
open so it says open and the target is
amazon.com that means it is giving
instruction to your browser to open this
particular website setting the window
size clicking on a button so this is the
search button which we have and then
typing what is the product which you are
searching for and then you have multiple
assert statements made available to you
in this id so these are all called as
the selenius command and as simple as a
close browser command and now if you
look here in this window this is log
window so every step which gets executed
here there is a log generated showing
you the status of the execution of that
step so if at all there is a failure you
would see a red failed mark against that
particular step and the test case will
not say completed successfully it will
say the failure occurred okay so it is
very simple and
very user friendly kind of an id so
let's go back to our presentation so we
saw the play button here and we saw how
to record it i also showed you the
commands the command window what we have
so these are the selenium commands and
then we saw the log which indicated the
execution of each of this command now
saving the script so let me go back to
the id again so once you have created
your test scripts you have run it
successfully you need to save your
project so for you to save the project
when you click on the save project every
ide project it is saved with an
extension dot sid which is nothing but
selenium id so you just go ahead and
click on save since i've already saved
this project i'm going to just say
cancel so that's the text file extension
it uses to save your project for more
details on how to use ide you can watch
our video on selenium id on
simplylearn.com selenium rc this is
selenium remote control so this was
developed by paul hammon and he
refactored the code and was also
credited with json as a co-creator of
selenium rc is used to write web
application test in different
programming language the server itself
is written in java language it supports
multiple programming languages like java
c
perl python and php it interacts with
the browser with the help of rc server
it uses a simple http get and post
request for communication this rc server
is also a selenium one daughter version
but it got deprecated in selenium 2.0
and was completely removed in 3.0 and it
got replaced by selenium webdriver we
will see why this happened when we talk
about the selenium webdriver this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
so when jason huggins introduced
selenium the tool was javascript program
and he called it as javascript
testrunner and it is also called as
selenium core so every html has this
javascript statements which are executed
by this web browser there is a
javascript engine which helps in
executing this command now this had a
major issue of something called a same
origin policy now what is the same
origin policy same origin policy
prohibits your javascript from accessing
elements or interacting with the scripts
from the domain different from where it
is launched and this was for the
security measure for example every
webpage inside google.com domain like
say your search email google drive can
be accessible but nothing outside this
domain like say if you want to access
yahoo or an amazon that was not possible
due to security reasons obviously so the
testers had to install the selenium core
and the web server which contained your
web application which you are basically
testing on the same system and this was
not feasible and effective all the time
now to overcome this to overcome the
same origin policy what paul hammond did
was he created something called as this
remote server which is selenium remote
control server and it acted like a proxy
to trick the browser in believing that
your core which is your selenium core
and your web application under test are
on the same domain this thus by
eliminating your same origin policy and
this was called as your selenium remote
control which was a version one of
selenium now if you look at the simple
architecture of this what are the things
it has so one is your script right first
you need to write your scripts using any
supported language like say php java
python and ruby as i mentioned now
before we start the testing what is the
requirement of the selenium one version
is you need to install the rc server now
this rc server is a separate application
so once you install this this selenium
server is responsible for receiving the
salinis commands now these are the
selenius commands which you have written
in your scripts it interprets them and
it executes it on your browser and the
results are sent back to your test
scripts and this browser interaction
happens only through this rc server
again as i said using a simple http get
and post request to communicate now upon
receiving these instructions right from
the selenium core the response is sent
back to this rc server from your browser
and back to your test scripts so the
cycle starts from your test scripts the
selenius commands are interpreted by
your rc server those are sent to the
browser and it's a simple javascripts
which executed on your browser and the
results after the execution are sent
back to your test scripts through your
rc server this is a simple cycle now
this cycle is repeated for every command
written in your test script until your
complete test case is executed okay so
this is how the rc worked now this rc
had few shortcomings and what are those
one is the architecture of this rc
itself was complicated why because of
this intermediate rc server which we
have between the browser and your test
script and this rc server had to be
installed before running any test
scripts so that means this became an
additional setup and it acts as a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser also the execution of
commands takes a very long time it is
pretty slow why because every command it
needs to make a full trip from your test
script to your rc server to the core and
to the browser execute the script and
then again back in the same line which
makes your overall test execution very
slow and now because of this short falls
web driver was introduced so selenium
webdriver selenium web drivers were
introduced by a gentleman called styman
stewart and it was developed in the year
2006. it is the first cross platform
testing framework it is a programming
interface to create and run test cases
it makes provision to act on web
elements so basically there are multiple
locating techniques which selenium
webdriver provides us for finding those
elements and to perform operations on
those web elements webdriver does not
require a core engine like rc and it
interacts natively with the browser
application so there is a direct
interaction with your browser
application and it eliminates the need
of having that intermediate rc server
and that makes the architecture pretty
simple this web driver again it supports
multiple languages which we already
talked about and also it has integration
with multiple frameworks so once you
understand how the web driver works what
are its functionalities and what are it
drawbacks you will appreciate the fact
that so how the selenium webdriver
overcomes this even in web driver we
have test scripts we also have a web
browser here and then we have a web
driver however what we do not have this
additional server which rc required and
this makes the architecture of the web
driver simpler the browser is controlled
directly from the operating system level
now due to this direct communication the
speed of test execution is much faster
than rc now how does this web driver
work so we have something called as
client libraries or the language
bindings so we know now that selenium
supports multiple languages and you're
free to use any supported language to
create your automation script and where
are these libraries available so if you
go to
seleniumhq.org so let me go to the
browser and show you that so in the
selenium hq dot r if you go to the
downloads so here you will see something
called as selenium client and web driver
language binding and depending on the
language which you want to work with or
which you want to create test scripts
with you can download this client
libraries so if you're working with java
download the client library for java so
if you're working with python you have a
corresponding link which you through
which you can download your client
libraries and then selenium provides lot
of apis for us to interact with the
browser and these are called as the rest
apis so then we have the browser drivers
through which we interact with the
browser now what are these browser
drivers so there are drivers specific to
each browser so let me show you that on
our
seleniumhq.org so here if you just
scroll down you have something called as
third party drivers bindings and plugins
for every supported
browser of selenium you have a
corresponding driver file available now
say for example if you want to work with
firefox mozilla gecko driver is what you
need to download and these driver files
so if you go and click here you will get
an executable driver file for any of the
platforms which you're working so if
you're working on windows mac os or
linux you can just download the
corresponding driver files here so these
drivers see these driver files are the
ones which interact with the actual
browser and how does this happen this
driver establishes the connection with
the real browser without revealing the
internal logic of the browser
functionality now what does that mean
say we want to execute a test script and
how does this test script gets executed
first is it it sends an http request
which is generated and sent to this
browser driver which we just saw for
each of the command in your scripts and
then this driver receives the request
through your http server and this hp
http server does all the execution
directly on the browser and then the
execution status the complete status is
sent back to your test script so let me
show you a simple use case how it works
with the web driver so for that let's go
to my eclipse here so i already have a
test script written here in webdriver
and what this basically does is it
launches amazon.com amazon.in website it
uses the firefox browser and then i'm
also fetching the page title and
printing it on the console and then i'm
closing the browser this is a simple
functionality which i am doing here so
if you look here so the eclipse is the
id which i am using i have already
installed selenium here and i have
written a simple java class and this
java class we have multiple methods one
is to launch browser one is to fetch the
title of the page and one is to close
the browser now while launching the
browser i said every browser has its own
driver files so somewhere in this java
class i need to tell selenium as which
browser to use and how is that done that
is done by this first two statements
here where i am doing a system.set
property and where i am indicating that
this is my driver file which is
geckodriver to be used and using this i
want the selenium to launch the firefox
browser and after this all the
operations any operations which you want
to perform on your web application under
test you can do it here now let's go
ahead and execute this and see how it
works so simply what i need to do is
i'll just say execute this as a java
program so the firefox browser is
getting launched so you can see amazon
dot in being launched here and since we
are not doing any operations here what i
am simply doing is printing the title of
the page and closing the browser that is
it so if you see here you can see the
page title is online shopping site so
and so and this is what i'm printing
through this method which is fetch page
title a very simple way of writing a
automation script using webdriver so now
you saw how we write a small test script
using the webdriver function now say if
i want to run the script on multiple
browsers and on multiple operating
system and i do not have just one test
case i say say i've got hundreds of test
cases now with this approach what you
can achieve your best is you can
sequentially execute on every browser
available and all your 100 or 200 test
cases whatever you have now this is
going to take quite a long time to
execute and hence to reduce the time
taken for the execution selenium has
something called as grid selenium grid
the main objective of the grid is to
minimize your test execution type this
grid is designed to distribute commands
to different machines simultaneously in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment for example a
web application for which say you have
automated thousands of test cases and
you want to run them as a regression
suite across multiple browsers and os
what you need to do is you need to run
them parallelly and not really
sequentially so grid allows this
parallel execution of tests on different
browsers and operating system you also
want an integration with reporting tools
so that you can get a consolidated
report after the tests have been
executed on multiple machines so grid
can be integrated with such many other
tools how does the grid work so grid has
this hub and node concept which helps in
achieving the parallel execution let's
take an example say again your
application supports all browsers and it
also supports different os like the one
which you're seeing here like windows
mac and linux and your requirement is to
run tests on all the supported browsers
and operating system like this one so
what you do here is you configure a
master machine that is this which is
also called as hub by running something
called a selenium standalone server and
this selenium standalone server can be
download downloaded from your selenium
hq website so let me show you that let's
go to my browser and in the downloads
here if you see selenium standalone
server version 3.1.4.5
and this is what you need to download so
using the server you create a hub
configuration like this once you do this
you also need to create nodes specific
to your requirement like a windows 10
like a mac machine with firefox with the
windows 8 with a chrome and mac say with
safari browser and the node
configuration is also done using the
same server which is the selenium
standalone server so you create a node
configuration on this node machines so
once you have the setup created through
your master that is your hub you can
control on which nodes you want to
execute which test say for example here
say you want to run some test on your
mac machine with safari browser so you
have a kind of smoke test which you need
to run now through the master you can
control this complete execution so what
master does it it selects this
particular node depending on the
configuration which you have set on the
master machine also you could have
multiple possible combinations like say
i want to just run smoke test on all my
nodes i want to run specific component
test on say only windows 10 with an edge
browser or i can say i want to just run
my complete regression suite but only on
mac machine and so on and all this is
controlled through your master so what
happens on the node once it gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs the specified test on the
browser so you can check out our
detailed video on selenium grid for you
to understand how the grid works and how
do we do this configuration and execute
the test to summarize the selenium
versions selenium version 1 comprised of
an id rc and grid as we discussed
earlier rc was on its path of
deprecation and web driver was taking
birth so selenium 2 had an earlier
version of webdriver and also rc existed
from 3.0 onwards rc was completely
removed and webdriver took its place
also there's a four dot version around
the corner it has more features and
enhancement so some of the features
which is expected are like w3c webdriver
standardization they have an improved
idea and also i believe there are some
improvements done to the grid advantages
of selenium speed and accuracy since
there is no manual execution your test
can run faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution so you can actually
execute large volume of test cases
within a short frame for example let's
say before your release of product
during your last lap of testing you find
a bug and it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and what you
want to do is you want to run all the
test cases pertaining to that area can
you imagine the amount of time which
will be required if you have to do this
manually but by automation you can
achieve this in a short duration of time
and you can also enable releasing your
product in time and with less or no
human error the second advantage is it's
an open source so it's available free of
cost and anyone can download and start
using it supports a wide spectrum of
programming languages it is not
restricted to any particular programming
language whatever language you are
comfortable with you have an option to
use that and to write your selenium
scripts selenium has support for almost
all browsers and operating system
including a headless browser so this
helps you to create test cases once and
run them across all browsers and
operating system and thus saving your
time for manual execution it also helps
in achieving a broad test coverage it's
a pretty easy to use tool you can check
out all our videos and you can just
master the skill of writing automation
scripts reusability and add-ons of
course like any programming languages it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy limitations so
like any other tool selenium also has
certain limitations so let's look at
what they are and see if there are any
workarounds also since selenium is an
open source you do not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
materials forums available which you can
refer to this tool is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
application or desktop application
automation however what selenium
provides is a support for integrating
tools like apm tool for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing since especially it is designed
for web application automation but then
we again have many other tools which can
be integrated with selenium like auto it
and securely selenium again has a
limited reporting capability it can help
create basic reports but we definitely
need more so it provides supports for
tools like test ng report ng extent
reports which you can integrate and
generate beautiful reports powerful
isn't it of course it does not have a
test management capability a tool need
not have all these capabilities but
again you can integrate with the test
management tool used in your
organization since selenium supports
multiple programming language the
developer of the automation script need
to have some basic knowledge of any
programming language to write effective
automation scripts of course a deep
advanced knowledge is not required a
basic knowledge is more than sufficient
so if you look at all this selenium
still provides a complete solution for
your automation need and that's the
beauty of selenium and that is what
makes it the most popular today most
popular tool today for automation in
this video we will look at how to
install selenium on windows system
selenium installation is a three-step
process so it has certain prereqs the
first prerequisite you need to have java
in your system so we will be installing
java first and then we will be working
with eclipse id so we will be installing
eclipse and then we will install
selenium for java we will install the
version java 8 and for eclipse we have a
version 4.10 this was the last stable
version which was released in december
last year so i'll be using that version
and selling game we will download the
latest 3.14 version okay so let's get
started with our first step which is the
java installation so to install java
let's go to the browser and simply just
search for java 8 download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to log in
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdks and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the oracle login to that
account and then you can just download
the java it so since i already have an
account and i have already downloaded
the package but i'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this java development kit 8211 so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as i said i've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what i've done is
i've just created a directory called
installers and i'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here i have
a folder called java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can
change the directory to the choice of
whatever drive and the folder structure
you want to i would like to leave it as
default here and we'll just go and click
on next and then the java installation
is in progress so let's wait until this
is completed it really shouldn't take
too much time maybe just a few more
minutes here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we leave the destination folder
as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what i'll do is i'll go to my
command prompt and i'll send just say
java minus version so it says java
version 1.8 and this tells us that the
java is installed successfully now after
this installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
you we are also going to set a java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the java got
installed was in program files java i
have there are certain previous versions
which had installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here let's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what i have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so what i
will do is i will just copy this path
and then
go to your control panel here go to your
where is my system yeah so click on the
system go to advanced system setting and
here in the environment variables find
the path variable okay and then say edit
now what are we doing here in the path
variable is we are going to add the java
bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you are editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say control v
paste the path which you have just
copied from the explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the java now
what i'll do for that is i just say new
i just type java home here
and what is the value of this we need to
set we need to set the same path but
without the bin directory so we just
need to set the path till your java
directory that is this so we'll just
copy the path again and paste it here
that is all just say okay click on ok
click on ok here and we are done so
again let's go to our command prompt and
just say java minus version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was 20 90 006. so
especially with eclipse since it's an
open source i prefer to work with the
last stable version and so does most of
the developers do and hence that is the
reason why i have picked up the version
which is like last year's version which
is uh 4.10 which was released in last
december so you can always choose to go
with the latest version but then if
there are any issues and if you're like
first time working with the eclipse
you're going to get confused as where
these issues are coming from right so i
would still recommend that you use the
last stable version which is available
with your eclipse so now to get the last
table version what you need to do is go
and click on this download packages and
here if you scroll down this page you
can see here more downloads so there is
a list of all the previous releases of
eclipse which is available and this is
what we need to download so just click
on that 4.10 version and then click on
the os on which you want to install
eclipse for us it is windows so i'll
just click here on the 64-bit windows
and then click on the download and you
will be downloading the complete package
so once you download this is what it
will look like so let's go back to our
directory of installers so this is the
installer for the eclipse which i got
now what's the next step i need to do
just launch this installer and install
eclipse so i'll just say double click on
this i'll say run
so here you'll see multiple options here
for eclipse installation so depending on
your requirement you can go ahead and
install any of these packages so for us
we just need an eclipse id for java
developer so i'll select this and i'll
say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so i have chosen d drive here
this is the default directory name it
takes which is ok we can leave it as it
is and then also you have an option to
create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
this is select all you can close this
window this is select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what opens
when you launch the eclipse you need to
specify a workspace directory now what
is this workspace directory so this is a
directory or a folder wherein all the
java files or any programs or any
artifacts which you are going to create
through eclipse will be stored in this
particular folder so this could be any
location on your system so this is you
can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is i'll go to the d drive and
i already have a directory so here i'll
create i'll just clear select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace i'll say my workspace and then
i'll say launch so every time i open the
eclipse right so this is going to take
as my default workspace and all my
programs all my javascripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so i'll
say file new and since i'm going to be
using java with selenium i'll say create
java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the jre which
you want to use so we just installed
this jdk 1.8 okay so i'm going to click
on use default jre otherwise you also
have an option to use a project specific
gr for example i could have two
different projects where one project i'm
going to be working with gre 1.8 and
there is another project which i want to
work with the latest java maybe java 12
and i can have more than one java
installed on the machine so this give me
an option to select whichever java i
want to work with so if you have another
java installed here it will show up in
this list so and you can just go ahead
and select that now since we have only
one java installed on our machine which
is java 1.8 i will say use default gre
which is 1.8 and i will click on finish
now if you observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install selling
so let me go to my browser and here i
will be going to the seleniumhq.org
so if you are working with selenium this
particular website the seleniumhq.org is
going to be a bible everything and
anything related to selenium is
available in this website whether you
want to download the files whether you
want to refer to the documentation
anything regarding to selenium is
available here so what we want now is
the installables for selenium so here go
to the download tab now for you to
install selenium and start working with
selenium there are three things which
are required for you to download one is
a standalone selenium server so this is
not required immediately when you get
started with selenium however when you
start working with remote selenium
webdriver you would be requiring this
when you have a grid setup you will be
requiring the standalone server so for
that what you can do is you can just
download the latest version available
here so when you click on that it will
download the file into your download
folder so this is one particular file
which you need to keep next selenium
client and web driver language bindings
now in today's demo we will be looking
at selenium with java so that means my
client package of java is what i need to
download so whatever programming
language selenium supports we have
respective downloadables available with
that say if you're working with python
then you need to download your client
library for python and since we are
working with java you need to download
this package so simply what you need to
do click on this link and it will
download the java package for you which
are basically the jar files so we have
client libraries now and then there is
another component what we need now with
selenium you are going to be automating
your web browser applications correct
and you also want your applications to
run on multiple browsers so that means
your scripts the automation scripts
which you create should be able to run
on any browser selenium works with
multiple browsers like edge safari
chrome firefox and other browsers even
it has a support for headless browser
now every browser which it supports
comes with its own driver files now say
for example we want to say work with
firefox driver so that means for us to
start working with firefox browser we
need to download something called as a
gecko driver here and if you want to
work with chrome browser you need to
install the chrome driver so depending
on what browsers you'll be testing with
go ahead click on each of this link and
download the latest driver files now
since we are going to be working with
firefox in this demo what i need to do
is i just need to click here on the
latest link so when i click on the
latest link it is going to take me to
this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for linux for mac and for
windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file i need because
we are working on windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
selenium hq dot r for us to install
selling so let me show you the folder
where i've already downloaded all this
so if you see here selenium java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client library which we saw here let's
go back to the main page here that is
this so once i download this this is a
zip file after i unzip the file this is
the folder structure i see and let's see
what is there at this folder structure
so there are two jar files here and then
in the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selenium and then we also downloaded the
driver files so what i did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser i created a directory here
called drivers and i've kept all my
browser drivers here so i have a driver
file downloaded for chrome i want to
work with firefox so i have a gecko
driver here and then for internet
explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this jre libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium jars to
the slide bridge and how do we add that
on your right you can see this add
external jars click on add external jars
go to your folder where you have
downloaded your selenium which is this
select all the jar files which is
available so i have two jar files here
i'll just say click open again i will
click on add external jar now from the
libs folder i will select all this file
so select all the five jars and click on
open so you should see all the seven jar
files here so once you have this just
say apply and close now if you look into
your project directory here you will see
some a folder called referenced library
and this is where you will see all the
selenium charts here this is a very
simple installation in eclipse when you
want to install selenium you just need
to export all the jars of the selenium
into eclipse and now your system is
ready to start working with selenium
scripts all right so now let's just test
our installation by writing a small
selenium test script so for that what i
will do is i'll go to the source folder
right click new and i'll say java class
so let's name this as say first selenium
test and i will select this public
static void main and i will click on
finish all right so now let's
create a use case say we want to launch
a firefox browser and then we want to
launch the amazon site so this will be
just two simple things which we will be
doing in this test script so for me to
do that what i usually do is i create a
method for any functionality which i
want to create here so now i want to do
a launch browser so i'll create a method
here called launch browser now whenever
you start writing your selenium scripts
the first line what you need to do is
you need to declare an object of
webdriver class so here i'll say
webdriver driver so now if you hover
over this error what it is showing it
says import webdriver from or dot open
qa dot selling it so if you remember
when we installed the selenium we
imported all these jars right so that
means so what whenever we want to use a
web driver we need to import this class
from these packages so just go ahead and
click on this import state done now next
step now for us to launch a firefox
browser it is a two steps process which
is involved here one is you need to set
the system property and then you need to
launch the driver so let's do that i'll
say system dot set property so use this
method set property so this takes two
arguments the key and the value now what
is the key i'm going to mention here i'm
going to be mentioning the gecko driver
and the path for the gecko driver okay
because since i'm working with the
firefox so in double quotes i'll say
webdriver.geco.driver this is my key and
the value is going to be sorry the fully
qualified path for your driver files and
you know where we have kept our driver
first let's go to that driver files in d
colon i have selenium tutorial in
installers i have driver folder okay so
i'm just going to copy the complete path
from here ctrl c and
i paste it here control v along with
this i need to provide the file name for
the gecko driver which is
geckodriver.exe and let's complete this
step next so once i've set the property
i need to provide a command for
launching my firefox driver and how do i
do that i simply use this driver object
which i have created driver equal to
new firefox driver again similarly the
way we imported packages for the web
driver we also need to import the
package for firefox driver so just hover
over the mouse over that and select
import firefox track with these two
statements we will be able to launch the
firefox browser and as i said in our use
case what is the next thing we want to
do we want to launch say amazon dot in
website for that there is a command in
selenium which says
driver.get and you pass the url here so
for me to write the url what i usually
do is i go to my browser i open the
website which i want to work with in our
case it's amazon dot in and i just
simply copy this fully formed url go to
my eclipse and just paste it here now
this ensures that i don't make any
mistakes in typing out the url let's
complete the statement and we are done
and now in the main function i'll just
create an object of this and we will
call this method so i'll copy this class
for selenium test say obj equal to new
for selenium test and now i'll say obj
dot this is a function launch processor
so let's save this and execute this
control c right click run as
java application okay so the mozilla
firefox has been launched now it should
launch your amazon.com bingo so there
goes our first test script which runs
successfully in this session we will be
looking at how to install selenium on
your mac machines
selenium installation on mac is a
three-step installation
one we need to install java which is a
prereq and then we need an id to work
with so we will be installing eclipse
and then we will install selenium and
these are the versions of the installers
which we are going to use so we will be
using java 8 eclipse version 4.10 which
was released in 2018 december and then
selenium version 3.14
so let's get started with our first step
which is the java installation so for us
to install java let us go to our browser
and simply what i'll do is i'll just
google for
java 8 download
okay so we would select the oracle site
for downloading the sd
okay so once you go here you can see
that we have something called as java
software development kit 8 u211 so this
is the version we'll be working with so
in order for you to download you need to
have an oracle account so since i
already have one i have directly been
logged into that so if you do not have
an oracle account please go ahead create
an account for yourself so that you can
download any of the java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so i'll be downloading this
package for that i need to click on
accept license agreement and then since
we are going to be working on mac this
is the package which i'm going to
download so let's go ahead and click on
that
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since i have
already downloaded the package and i
have kept it in one of my folders so let
me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what i have
done is i have created a folders called
installers and all the software which we
are going to require today for us to
work with selenium is what i have
downloaded it and kept it here so we
will go step by step so that you
understand what each of these packages
are so as you see here i have the jdk 8
which i've already downloaded so let's
go ahead and install jtk so how do we
install jdk so you have the dmg file
here you just go ahead and double click
on that
okay and then i will double click on
this package
and then we will say continue
and install
so it's going to ask me for my password
i've given my password and i'll say
install the software
probably it will just take a couple of
minutes to install java
okay there you go so now the java has
been installed so i let me close this
window let me close this window too and
then now i'll go to my terminal window
so let's open my terminal and here
let's say java minus version
bingo so there we have java 1.8
installed on our system now there are
couple of other things which you need to
do apart from installation of your jdk
you also need to set some system
variables right so in mac how do you set
the system variables or the environment
variables you do that in your bash
profile so let's see how we do that all
right so what i will do is i'll use an
editor which is my vi
okay and then i'll open my bash profile
so what is bash profile it's a config
file for your bash cell this is mainly
used to export variables in your shell
like in windows we are going to do the
system variable setting from the
advanced setting right so similarly we
are going to do that here so i will say
vi dot
bash underscore
profile so this is the file
where
i will be adding java home path
now i have other parts here already
written because i am working with other
multiple software on this machines and
now i'll go to the end of this file and
i'll say
export
java home
equal
now what is the path we need to give for
java home we need to give the path where
the java has been installed on your
system
okay first let's go and find out that
path so let's go back to our finder
and then i have a folder called library
here so
here there is a java and then there is
something called as java virtual
machines so if you have a single java or
multiple java versions installed so all
those versions you are going to see
under this directory which is java
virtual machines and java one dot is is
what we installed just now so let me go
and open that folder there is something
called as content and then home and in
this you have your jre and bin folder so
that means i need to give my java home
path until here
till this home directory so simply what
i'm going to do is i'll just go here say
get info because i want to just copy the
path and what you can do is you copy
this path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here i'm going to paste this path
plus i want it till the home directory
so i'm just going to type out h ome home
that is it so you have now set your java
home environment variable so simply you
do
save the file escape colon wq and come
out of it and now what you need to do
for this batch profile
to be activated you just exit out of
this terminal
okay close this terminal window and i'll
go ahead and open another terminal
so let me close this
info text so here let me again give java
minus version
okay so everything seems to be working
fine so this completes our java
installation now your system is ready
and you have your java up and running
other thing which you also can do is go
to your system preferences okay here you
will see this java control panel
this is another way of finding out that
your java has been installed
successfully on the machine so you can
just open this java control panel and if
there is any settings which you want to
do here you can do it through your
control panel also
all right
close this
let's minimize this window
and this folder windows
so we have successfully done a step one
so what's our step two we need to go
ahead and install the eclipse
now same thing what i will do i'll go to
my browser
okay and
now i'll open another tab here
and i'll say
eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you're going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here my
recommendation to you is instead of if
you're working first time instead of
working on the latest version available
i would suggest that you work with the
last stable version and that's exactly
what you are going to do today so for me
to go to the previous versions i just
need to go here on this download
packages click on it
okay so once you click on that
on this page if you scroll down you will
see something called as more downloads
right in this you will see all the bills
of eclipse which is available all your
previous versions so since today i'll be
working with 4.10 version i will go
ahead and click on this
this 4.10 was released last year this is
2018 december okay and now when you look
at this installer you have multiple
packages available here so depending on
your need you can choose which package
you want to work with so today for our
demo what i would be using is eclipse id
for java developers
so since we are going to be working on
mac i will go ahead and click on this
downloadable
and then i'll click on this download
which is going to download this
particular file for me i've already
downloaded this file and kept it in my
folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installers okay so
now do you see this eclipse java 2018 12
are
blah blah blah dot dmg so this is the
file which we are going to be using to
install eclipse now as simple as what we
did for jdk i'm going to double click on
this and install the eclipse let's see
how the eclipse gets installed
all right so now
i'll just move this folder into
applications
done
so my eclipse is ready now so simply
let's go ahead and launch so what i'll
do i'll just simply search for that on
my system eclipse there you go and i'll
just double click this
is an application downloaded from the
internet are you sure you want to open
it yes please go ahead and open it
okay it is launching it so did you see
how simple the eclipse installation is
it's just downloading the package and
just installing it on your mac machine
all right when you start the eclipse for
the first time you need to set your
workspace so workspace is place where
you're going to keep all your folders
all your
java code or whatever you're going to do
in eclipse all under that particular
directory
so right now it gives me a default
directory rather what i will do is since
i have created a separate folder for our
demos i will go ahead and select that
folder which is my simply demo
and then in this i will add
a folder called
workspace
okay so that means in this particular
location whatever files i am going to
create whatever code i am going to write
in selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then i'll go ahead and
say launch
so it will take a minute to load your
workbench yeah there it goes so when you
launch your eclipse
right so let me just
make this window bigger the first screen
what you are going to see is the welcome
stream
just go ahead and close the welcome
screen and this is the first view of
your eclipse what you're going to get so
let's close out all the windows which we
are not going to be working today
and i just need this main screen here
now what is the first step you're going
to do once you have the eclipse i would
go ahead and create a project first so
i'll simply say open file new java
project let's give a nice name to this
since this is a first project which is
going to be created so i'll say selenium
first project
now if you observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
eclipse needs a jdk to work with and
what it is done while i create my new
project it has already given me an
option to use the execution jre which
you already have in the system okay
that's why it has already chosen java
one dot it in case you have multiple
javas installed in in that case what you
can do is you can always go here select
this and select the java of your choice
so say if you have got the latest java
which is java 12 installed on your
system it will give you an option here
along with java software 8 it will give
you java 12 here so you can go ahead and
select that for this particular project
that option is also available now since
we have only one jtk installed here i
will go ahead and create this project
so i just click on finish and it's going
to create a projection so there are few
default things which it grades created
one is definitely the gre system
libraries right this is what we told
eclipse when we created project that my
java is 1.8 so what it has done is it
has imported all this jar file which it
requires for our java programs to work
in our eclipse id and then it creates a
src which is your source directory
wherein we will be creating all our java
code or selenium descripts okay good so
far so this is a simple way of
installing your eclipse and getting your
eclipse ready to work with your selling
all right so now let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium right
so what is that we need for selenium
let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
hq
dot
so this is going to be a bible for you
if you're going to be working with
selenium so in this website what i do is
i go to downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with celine
one is the selenium standalone server
so when you're going to be working with
remote selenium webdriver is when you
would require this however i would
suggest that we download whatever is
required for us even though we might not
use it immediately so what i just need
to do is i need to click on this and
it's going to download this server for
me okay so i have already downloaded it
and i'll show you that
and then what we need is the selenium
client and web driver language bindings
okay we need a client so what is the
client which you are going to work in we
are going to working with java client
with the selenium and for that i need to
go ahead and download this if you are
working on say c sharp or ruby or python
then you have the respective packages
which you can go and download now since
we are going to be working with java
here i would go ahead and click on this
and this is going to download the java
client for me now as i said since i've
already downloaded it so let's go ahead
and look at what are those downloadables
what we have so let's close out this
window now if you see here
one is the selenium server standalone
which we just downloaded and then when
you download the client libraries what
it does it it creates a zip file it
downloads a zip file and it unzips it
and what is contained in that particular
folder so if you look here selenium java
3. in this folder you have multiple java
files
with which is what we'll be working with
selenium
so here you have two jar files here and
then under the folder libs you have
other jar files now these are the files
which we will need and now let's see how
do we utilize this file in our eclipse
so for that let's go back to our eclipse
okay so let me maximize this window so
in eclipse first thing what you need to
do is click on your project
okay right click on that
and then you have something called as
build path
go to the build path and say configure
now here in this configured build path
what you need to do is go to your
libraries
okay go to add external jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select all your jar files
from what you have downloaded from the
selenium set so that is present in our
selenium java 3. so what i'll do is
simply select
these two first
okay then again you click on the
external jar files what we have is an
ellipse so select all the jar files in
the list
say open okay you have all the java
files what we need identified here go
ahead and click on apply and close
once you do that how do you know whether
all those jars have been imported
correctly
go to the reference libraries
here you should be able to see all the
selenium jars which we have downloaded
to be listed out here and so it lists
here so that means we have successfully
imported selenium to test our
installation let's go ahead and write a
small test script so for that i'll go to
my source folder
right click new and will create a java
class so let's name it
selenium
first test
and i will also use a public static word
name here and i'll click on
finish
let's remove all this comments here
which we do not need so before when we
write our first line of code first what
we need to do is create an object of
webdriver so i will say webdriver
driver
okay so now if you see this error it
asks us to import this particular web
driver class from a package and that
package is org dot open qa dot selenium
okay so now you can see this import
statement
now let's go ahead and write our
test case now for this test case what we
will do is
we will simply launch a browser say
firefox browser and we will also launch
a website
now i'll create a method for that i'll
say public void
launch browser
so if you have looked at our previous
videos on selenium webdriver basics i
have explained there that every browser
which you want to work with in selenium
comes with its own driver and this
driver is what we need to download from
the website of selenium and i'll show
you how to do that so if we go to that
seleniumhq.org
under the downloads tab if you go down
you will see something called as third
party drivers bindings and plugins so
all the browsers supported by selenium
are listed here and their corresponding
driver files are available so now since
we are going to be working with firefox
in this demo i will go ahead and click
on this latest release of mozilla gecko
driver so gecko driver is the one which
will be using for launching our firefox
so just click on this and this will take
you to the latest version of the gecko
driver available so just scroll down and
depending on the os which you are
working with in our case it is a macros
so just click on this file and download
this file
similarly
say if you are working with the chrome
driver what you need to do is go to this
chrome driver
go to the latest
click on that
and select the release which you want to
work with and just download it
now i've already downloaded this file
and i'll just show you where they are
all right so in this directory which is
my installers directory i have another
directory created called as drivers and
what i do is usually i keep all my
driver files under this folder
okay so i have a chrome driver and gecko
driver already downloaded and kept here
now let us go back to our code and see
what is that we need to do to launch our
browser so there are two steps which we
need to do for launching any browser
which you want to work with
first is you need to set a system
property for that what i do is
system
dot
set property
and this accepts a key and value pair
now key for this is gecko driver is what
i need to provide here and now that is
in the codes because it's a string
argument i say web driver
dot
gecko
dot driver
and the value is
nothing but the path to your gecko
driver which you have just downloaded
okay let's go to my finder so that's
here so what i do is i simply right
click on this file get info
and i copy this complete path
go to my eclipse
paste this path here
and then the file name which is
geckodriver
done so this sets a path to my gecko
driver now next step is actually
launching the web browser and how do i
do that i say driver
equal to new
firefox driver
now we need to do the same thing again
we need to import this class so i say
import firefox driver
all right so now with these two steps
what we do is we simply launch the
firefox browser
and then let's go ahead and also launch
a website say amazon.com so for that i
have a command called
driver.get
which accepts a url
now this url needs to be fully formed
url so for that what i do first is i go
to my any browser i launch the amazon
dot in website okay and then i copy this
complete url
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
that's it we are ready to launch the
browser and launch amazon.com so let's
quickly create a class here or object
here of this class
so selenium first test
obj
equal to new
selenium first test
done
and then i need to call the method
which is
launch browser
okay so now i save this file i do a
right click on this and i say run as
java application now
this should
launch our browser
okay which adjusted and then it should
take us to amazon.com bingo there goes
our first script so we have successfully
executed our first script so that means
your selenium is up and running
successfully
let's talk about automation three months
okay so guys to be precise with you i'll
be talking about the automation
framework when we will start automation
but as that's a part of the automation
basics so i'll just give you a basic
knowledge of it that what automation
framework is and then we'll be seeing
how we will be going to create a
framework
so first of all what is automation
so it's a set of protocols rules such as
coding standards
object repository and data
and beneficial in terms of code reuse
portability maintenance
the framework provides the basis of test
automation simplifies the automation
effort so what happens actually when we
need this automation suppose
you are automating only
one functionality you have written only
one test script of course you don't
require to write an automation framework
for this
because there's only one script if there
is any there is any change comes you can
go ahead and make the change and done
but when this one is this script one one
automation script
becomes hundred
then it becomes very difficult to manage
them suppose in 100 test case 100
scripts there is a user name
there is a password so there is a
username and password in more than 10
test scripts
if that happens then and if there is any
change comes
in the password
or in the username you may have to go to
the 10 tips script separately and make
the change which will be very cumbersome
process and it may be possible that you
make
you made an error okay it may be
possible that you know somewhere you
have written something different
somewhere you'll be something different
or spelling error or space error may
have also if i talk about what you have
done you have created your scripts but
that is keeping in mind for windows but
what if you have to run it on linux and
you'll go back on all your scripts and
make that change what if you have
written your script for firefox browser
and you may have to run it for chrome
browser then it will be difficult to
make multiple changes so it's always
suggested that you create a framework
for that because framework is the one
which will help you out and solve all
these problems instead of writing one
thing again and again we will write it
only at one place and reuse that again
and again it will be very easy for us to
maintain it because that in terms of
framework that's in the framework where
you can make changes very easily
portability so of course you have
written out of windows and you can run
it on any other operating system the
framework provides the basis of this
automation and simplifies the automation
effort it is actually helpful when you
have multiple scripts for multiple test
cases
so framework is very important and
that's the reason if you go and say that
you have done the automation and you
have a knowledge of automation you will
always ask you about the framework
they will know they will not go in the
basics they will always go with the
automation so it's very important
so what are the automation frameworks do
we have we have linear framework we have
structured framework data driven
framework keyword driven hybrid
there are multiple types of frameworks
we have what is the methodology for
automation first of all uh you know
mythology means
how you decide whether you need to
automate or not so first of all you take
a decision whether this project needs to
be automated or not because that is
becoming very complex you have plan of
methodology you have less resources all
those things you have less budget
because of that you thought to automate
that
when you have part of automating it what
tool do you want to use you think on
that so you pick three to four tools it
certainly depends
you pick three to four tools create a
proof of concept
create a proof of concept guys are you
all aware what is proof of concept poc
obey is aware of that anyone who is not
aware of that can just say engineer has
heard of it kushal is aware of that okay
great not created on my own yes that's
perfectly fine of course okay says no
so guys what is proof of concept is
whenever you are suppose you are
shortlisting some tools you have
multiple automation rules in the market
correct so how do you decide whether
which
tool is best for you of course you can
go ahead and you know take a list of
tools
you can see pros and cons of those
tweets but those pros and cons of the
tools
depending on the
blogger depending on the editor who is
writing about that particular tool it
may not be applicable it may not be
possible that those advantages or
disadvantages
are actually correct for your project so
always what we do
we shortlist few tools like three to
four rules
we
develop or create a poc ready poc means
you
actually use those tools to
automate one simple
use
all three tools what you have
shortlisted to automate a simple script
and then figure out
the
pros and cons of that tool
based on your experience and based on
what other people say
and then you create a ppt and show it
to the management and this is the tools
we have taken up this is the poc this is
how it works this is the advantage this
is a disadvantage and then you shortlist
one tool out of it
and that's what we call test tool
acquisition and it does not like uh you
are talking and we are learning selenium
and you will go ahead and face the
reading and that's it they will accept
it no
you have to tell them that this is the
poc and this is the benefits of opting
selenium tool
and then if they are happy with that
then they will
go ahead with that they will say go away
else
they may ask you to come back offer with
more details and all this stuff
okay
and it becomes very difficult to you
know
impress your management
when
there is an existing tool running like
qtp is running
and you wanted to
suggest them selenium tool then it
becomes very difficult because they may
say that all the other projects are
working perfectly fine with the qtp why
should we go ahead with selenium what is
the best part so that's what you need to
highlight and need to say that these are
the things which automate with future
fuel selenium you can do that so that's
where test tool acquisition comes then
you do the test planning uh that what
all test cases should be automated and
start developing your test cases or test
descripts then you execute them and
manage them then you show the result of
all those test cases and send it to all
the stakeholders
then this is the
result
so in this video we will be looking in
detail about how the selenium id works
so what is selenium id selenium ide was
developed way back in 2006. it was
created to facilitate a simple record
and replay of the test automation so
record and replay tools were pretty much
invoked during this time and the main
advantage of using such tool was an
automation engineer was not really
required to know any knowledge of
programming he could just use this
record replay tool and create the
automation and this ide was available as
a firefox extension so for one to use it
you need to just go ahead and install
the extension on firefox and then use
its recording and record the steps of
your test execution it is a very simple
interface which helps in building the
automation scripts and how this works
you just need to start the recording on
id perform your test steps on the
browser and these steps gets recorded in
the script and then what you could do is
you could export the script into say a
web driver or a junit ruby or any
javascripts and then you can use it now
however the record and replay tool is
not a very powerful automation tool and
hence this ide is mainly used for
prototyping or you could say demo
purpose now since selenium webdriver
itself offers such powerful capability
of creating robust test scripts ide more
or less remains as a prototyping tool
only so in short as i said ide is a part
of overall selenium set of tools and
mainly developed to speed up the
creation of test cases and what is the
other advantage of that one need not
really have any programming knowledge to
use this tool and mainly it is used for
writing some quick test for demo
purposes advancements with the new
selenium id back in 2017 selenium id
development was completely stopped the
last supported firefox version where
this ide was available as a plugin was
firefox 54 and from 55 onwards the
complete integration point was remote or
it was completely broken however
recently apply tools help revamp much of
the selenium id code they basically
rewrote the whole ide code and then now
they have released a new version under
the apache 2.0 license and it is
completely managed by the selenium
community now let's look at some of the
features of this now traditionally the
selenium ide was only a firefox plugin
however the new ide supports both the
browsers the chrome and the firefox and
thus making it cross browser so before
even we start looking at the other
features of the selenium id i would like
to show you how do we install this
firefox plugin or the chrome extension
so for that let me go to my chrome
browser so in the chrome browser what
i'll simply do is i'll search for
selenium id for chrome so then let's go
to this chrome.google.com
and here you will see it as an extension
selenium id so go ahead click on add to
chrome so this will add this extension
to your chrome browser so now it says
selenium id has been added to the crew
so how do you make out if it is added so
you can see this particular icon here
which says selenium id so this is the
way you can go ahead and install it on
the chrome now on the firefox i have
already installed it since we want to
use the firefox as a browser for all the
demos in this video so here again you
can see the selenium id so if i click on
this ide it is going to open a window
for me and the first window when it
opens it says either open a new project
or open an existing project or simply
you can start recording a new test case
in which case it creates a default
project for you first so what i will do
is i'll say open an existing project and
i've already got a project created so
let me go to my folder where i have this
project so i have this project created
and i've opened it i also have a simple
test case written now what this test
case does is let me show you here it
simply goes to google.com and then here
what i'm doing is i'm searching for
selenium hq documentation and then i
click on this site which says
seleniumhq.org and docs so which should
take us to this particular website where
the documentation is available so this
is a simple script which i have tried to
write it in this id so let's keep both
this windows open and let's go back to
our presentation to see the first
feature of this selenium id the first
feature what it says is improved locator
functionality what are locators so these
are nothing but the techniques used for
locating your web elements on your
website now for example in our example
here now the type here the type which
says name equal to q so name equal to q
is a locator now this is a locator of
what initially if you saw i went to
google.com and this is the search button
which i used right the search text and
then i said enter so this is nothing but
your web element for which the locator
is name equal to q now what happens in
id is when you record it it has taken
the attribute name and it is recognized
this particular web element using this
attribute however it also has a feature
wherein it also records its multiple
locators available for that particular
web element for example it also has a
css locator it has an expat locator now
how does it help here say for example
tomorrow this particular attribute name
right for the search box if it changes
then what id does is when you execute
this test script it falls back on your
other locators mentioned here in the
structure and then if none of this
locators work only then the test case is
going to go and fail not otherwise so
how does this help this helps to make
the test cases more robust otherwise
having just one locator there is high
possibility the test case might break or
become pretty brittle as and when the
web elements change their attributes so
this is what the locating techniques are
and that is how they have improved the
locator techniques in the uh
functionality in the new id now what's
the next one parallel execution is
possible with this new id so the first
id the traditional one the parallel
execution was not possible however this
is a new feature which has been added so
we will be looking in detail how to work
with this parallel execution later in
this video next is you can add control
statements in your scripts now what are
these control statements like if else
while loops for each loops and even the
switch case the earlier ide also had
this provision but you had to install a
plugin to enable the use of this control
statements and now with this new id it
is available out of box automatically
waits for page to load in any automation
synchronization between your application
under test and your automation scripts
is very important your script should not
run faster than your application
otherwise your scripts are going to
start failing so it is necessary to have
enough load times on the operations
of your web elements and also enough
load times on your page now this low
time ensures that all the elements of
your web pages and the page itself is
loaded completely before even a single
line of script is run this new id takes
care of providing that enough uh wait
time and also you have a global set
speed option which you can uh use to
control your execution of your scripts
so that is something which i will show
you now so if i go back to this so can
you see this clock icon here so it says
test execution speed so what you can do
is right now it is set to the fastest so
i can actually control the execution
speed here so right now i've just kept
it a little slower so let's see how our
test scripts run so you will be able to
see a remarkable difference when i slow
down the complete speed of this so now
do you see how slow it is initially when
i ran it you are unable to see what i
entered in the search field of the
google right so now it's clearly taking
time on each of the steps which we have
mentioned there so now it is executed
successfully so next it supports
embedded code you can run a simple java
script from your test script right and
how do you run that by using a simple
command called as execute now let's see
how do we do that so let's take the same
example here now after clicking this
okay so this is our id so what i will do
is i'll first execute this test case and
then in the end where i will show you
how do we add a simple javascript and do
some functions so
let me get the speed back to a little
normal because we do not want to waste
too much time so i'll just play the
script once so now we are in the
selenium documentation now if you look
at this page this is a pretty long one
so now i'm going to write a simple
javascript wherein i scroll down towards
the end of this page that's all i'm
going to do now for me to do that what i
can do is in my script itself i can just
add another line here okay here i will
say add a new command ah here i'll say
execute script which is my command and
what is the script which i want to
execute it's a java script which i'm
going to write here i'll say window dot
scroll by and i'm just going to mention
some coordinates here start from zero
and i'll say one five zero zero okay
this is all my code is and now i'll
simply run this test again let's see
what happens so it's going to the
documentation now it's clicked on the
link okay let's move down do you see
this initially it was right here on the
top of the page and once the javascript
was executed it brought me somewhere to
the middle of this page that is how you
can insert a snippets of javascript and
it has to be in context with your
currently selected window okay and
that's how you run it all right let's go
back to our ppt okay what's the next
feature so every ide has a debugger
which allows step execution adding of
breakpoints now apart from just having a
breakpoints or adding the step execution
there is another feature which it
provides called i will show you that
which is called as pause and exception
so let's close this window and let's
just keep this id window open here
right so can you if you see here pause
button it says pause on exception so
what it does is if you enable this
button okay and when you're running the
script so if at all there happens to be
an exception in your script it stops the
execution at that particular exception
field and we will see this in detail
when we look at complete debugger for
the id can be integrated in ci since you
can execute scripts from command line
right we also talked about the parallel
execution and you can also export the
scripts to any of the programming
language you want so since you can do
that these scripts can be run from
command line and hence they can also be
integrated with your maven project and
through jenkins you can run it and
that's how you achieve your ci working
principle of selenium id selenium id
works on a very very simple principle
one is the recording it records user
interactions with the browser and which
forms basically your id script and using
this id script which is a recorded
script you execute the script and verify
and monitor for its stability and
success rate and thirdly what you can do
is you can simply save your recorded
script for your future runs or
regression testing and these scripts can
be saved either in the form of an id
project itself or you can also export
these test scripts into the form of a
javascript or your ruby scripts or even
the web driver scripts now let's look at
the components of this id interface
itself the first one is the menu bar so
let's go back to our id window so here
in the menu bar what you can see is is a
project name so either you can edit the
project name here or you can simply
create a new project open an existing
project and save the current project so
these are all the options available and
since we have already created a project
here i will not be showing how to create
a new project so that we can do it
little later now next one is the toolbar
so this is the toolbar what we have here
for the id now there are multiple
components in the toolbar so let's see
one by one so it says run all test now
if you have multiple test cases written
okay so this is an option where all the
tests can be run one after the other
this is to run your current test which
the focus is on so currently our focus
is on search test so if i click on this
button it is going to execute the search
test for you ide has this debugger
option where you can do a step execution
right you can do step by step execution
using this option we'll see how to do
that so for example let's say we start
from here okay and i click on this so
what it does is basically it has just
executed the first step for me so let's
keep this side by side so that we can
observe the complete execution now if i
go and press on this again step over
current command so that is the next
command it is going to execute now it
says type into this all right so now you
can see the selenium hq documentation
okay then again i say step send keys
which it basically it said enter and
then it is going to click on that
documentation which it did and now we
have a script written which scrolls down
on this particular page so let's execute
that and that is what it is so this is
how the step execution happens so let's
close this window and let's come back to
our id window then we have buttons here
where you can say record or you can stop
recording okay then you can pause the
execution and then there are other
options available for disabling
breakpoints so basically you can add
breakpoints any barrier so for example
if i want to add a breakpoint on the
click here so what i have to just do is
i have to just click here so this adds a
breakpoint and if you want to remove all
the spray point you just say disable
those breakpoints so when you run the
script even though you have a breakpoint
available here for that particular run
your breakpoint will be disabled and
your execution will not stop at this
point and let's enable them for now and
what we will do is we'll just run the
script until there so now it has stopped
here at this click now from here either
you can execute the rest of the test
case by just clicking on this run button
or you can stop the execution okay so
for now what we'll do is we'll just stop
the execution so once you stop the
execution you will see that this is in
red which means that this particular
line was not executed or it failed
either of the things because you have
aborted at this particular line and the
rest of the things what you see in green
it shows that all these test steps have
been executed successfully so what is
our next component let's come back here
so we saw the menu bar here we saw the
toolbar we saw start and stop of
recording address bar now what is this
address bar so this address bar is where
you actually write your url from where
you want to start your recording and as
in when you start writing more and more
test cases it keeps a complete history
of all the websites which you are
working on next then we have a test
script editor box which is this so let
me just minimize this little bit okay
this is nothing but your test script
editor box and this is where all your
script steps are all your interactions
are recorded now there are four
attributes in this okay can you see a
command now command is nothing but the
actual operation or the action performed
on your web element so there are
multiple actions you can perform like in
this case we have something called as
open we have got type we have got send
keys and we have got clicks so these are
all the selenium commands which are
available and then we have something
called as target now this target is
nothing but the web element on which you
want to perform the action and now this
target as i said earlier also it is
identified by multiple locating
techniques and if you click on any of
this like we looked at the name here now
similarly the website which we are
clicking on if you look at it there are
multiple locating techniques which are
available here so the one right now
which is being used is the css
identifier you can also have
xpath here which is a relative x bar so
these are all the locating techniques
and this is where it which is applied on
the target value so value is an optional
field so you can send any value to your
web element for example in this case
where we are sending the value which is
our text which is it's selenium hq dot
documentation so this is the value which
i want to send it to as a search text to
my google.com and then comment or the
description so here you can mention any
description about that particular line
which you have recorded for example i
can say here sending search text to the
google search input box and this gets
recorded here against your uh
instruction now let's look at the test
case pane now test case pane that is
here so if you look here now it contains
all the test cases which you have
recorded now there are multiple things
here one is your tests say i can always
go ahead and create another say ah test
case two okay i can add a few more test
case here test case three so all these
test cases are here now i can also have
a test suite now there is already test
suite which i have created which is
called the google suite and now if i
want to add test cases under this what i
can do is i can just say add tests and
now i can add any of this test which i
just created under this test suite so
say i have selected the first three and
i've added it so we have test suite we
have tests here and then executing so
executing is basically it shows that
particular test case which is currently
in the execution mode so whichever test
case we run you will see all the test
cases listed here which have been
executed at that point of time that is
your test case pane and then we have
test log and reference this is a very
important window which you need to be
aware of now here this is a running lock
so as and when you are going to run your
test cases the every instruction the
every test step as and when it runs it
is going to log here whether it is
passed whether it has failed whether the
command was executed properly or not and
this is how it records it it's a running
law also there is something called as
reference tag now for example just go
ahead and ah let's select one of this
command which you have written here so
which is send case now this reference it
will show you the complete description
of the command and how to use that
command so say for click it says
references click locator clicks on the
target element it gives you a complete
detail of what exactly the command does
let's create a test script now for say
amazon.com let's go back to our id what
we will do is we'll create a completely
new project so i'll click on the create
new project are you sure you would like
to without saving it yes proceed further
and let's give the name as amazon
project now in this new project what i
will do is i'll say i'll add a test and
my test name is search iphone now
basically what is the use case which i
am going to automate so i will launch
amazon.com and i will search for iphones
and once i get the iphones let's verify
the title of that particular page now
just the simple steps we'll go ahead and
do that so for that first what i need to
do is i need to enter the url now this
url needs to be a fully formed url so
for that what i will do i'll first
launch amazon.in on any browser i'll
just copy this url and i can close this
browser window and in this url address
space i would say amazon and i'll say
enter and now i would click on this
recording button which says start
recording so once i do this what it does
is it launches the web page with
amazon.com and from there i can start
recording my script so let's do that
i'll say record it so let me just keep
this window side by side so that you can
see what is happening on the id window
here now here what i will do is i'll
click on the search and i'll say iphone
and i will click on the search button
and here i will also click on this
bestseller once i'm in this window i'll
say right click now when your selenium
id is in the recording mode you will get
this option here it says selenium id and
there are a lot of options here which
you can select now for this particular
moment what i want to do is i want to
assert the title so i'll just put an
assertion point here for asset title and
then i will close my browser window now
let's see what are all the commands
which it has recorded let's go one by
one right so it is done it is opening
the amazon dot in it is setting the
window size fine it clicked on the to
search window button and then iphone is
what you are searching and then it said
submit it it's basically clicking on
that button and then we said we also
want to open the bestseller link and
here is our asset title right so it's a
very simple test so let's go ahead and
execute this now since i also have a
close command here this script is going
to execute so fast that you will not be
able to make out all the steps what we
have written so for that what i will do
i will comment out the slide now how do
you comment out any command here just
select the command and can you see here
enable and disable command just click on
it so now your command is disabled also
what i will do is i will reduce the
execution speed so that you should be
able to see exactly what is happening so
let's go ahead and execute this test
first so i'll say run current test okay
i have not stopped the recording so that
is the first thing after closing the
window i also need to click on the stop
recording now your script is ready to be
executed so let's go and run the current
script again i'll just bring this side
by side so that you can see each of
these commands being executed here okay
it has searched for the iphone it's
clicked on the best sellers and it has
done the title assertion now if you look
at the log here as i said see every step
as in when it was executed it has been
logged here can you see here and it puts
an ok and it color coded in green which
says that this particular command was
executed successfully now let's go ahead
now this is what we did by simply
recording all the steps from the browser
now one more thing what we will do is
say i want to continue recording here
right i'm not completed my test case so
what you can still do here is you can
come towards the end of the script and
press on record button again and then
you can continue recording from here now
say for example after the best sellers
what we have got say i want to click on
say hot releases or new releases so i do
that okay it says it has recorded the
click and then i want to stop the
recording just the another step is what
i wanted to add now it has stopped the
recording so can you see this new line
which has got added so that means you
really need not restart recording all
the steps again if you want to add
something in the middle of your script
you can always go towards the end of the
script or anywhere in between and you
can add more commands there or you can
record anywhere in between the script
and that is how this does so let's go
ahead and again execute this then i will
show you another feature of this okay
it's done the title assertion now and it
is also clicked on hot new releases done
now let's say for example i need to add
another command here now instead of
going ahead and using this recording
what i will do is i'll manually add
certain command here say for example
let's go to this amazon website and say
you want to click on this card so let me
add a command manually here so what is
my command my command is click and then
what is that i want to click i need to
identify that web element for that i can
use this here which says select the
target in the page so i click on that
and i simply select this target which is
my cart and that is all i need to do so
my command is written there so i'll just
simply go ahead and execute this again
let's see what happens so let me close
this window here okay let's run this
test cases bring this window to the site
so now you can see one by one the
instructions being executed okay the
iphone has been searched the best seller
has been clicked assert title so it says
your shopping cart is empty so that
means it is successfully able to click
on the cart so now with using id there
are multiple things you can do you can
simply record your script while you are
running your test case you can add a
command all by yourself you can stop
recording anywhere and again restart
from the same point now we have our
complete test script ready now let's go
ahead and save this so how do you save
this simply go here and save your
complete project so all the projects
from the id are saved as dot side file
so let's name this as amazon project and
i will save it so if i show you in my
finder how it looks like this is the
project we created so it always stores
with the file extension dot sid right
that is selenium id now also i said you
can export test cases into multiple
format so search iphone is my test case
so what i can do is i can just say right
click and i can say export now right now
you can see only three options it says
java junit javascripts and python
however the older ide had multiple
options of export which had even the web
driver scripts and also the javascripts
this is still in works and they would be
adding more support for other
programming languages here so but for
now the only options what is available
to us is java junit javascript and the
python so let's go ahead and export this
into java j unit so it's going to simply
save it as dot java file let me go here
in the id test i'll save this file so if
you go back to my finder you can find
our search iphone test dot java you can
open the java file you can you can see
here it's a simple junit test it is
exported into so if you have an eclipse
ide you can use this test and execute it
from your eclipse site selenium commands
selenium commands can be broadly
classified into three action commands
accessors and assertions what are action
commands action commands are the
commands which interact directly with
the web elements on your application so
let's look at what these commands are so
if we go back to our previous example
where we had written a test script for
amazon.n so if you look at all these
things like open set window size click
type so these are all nothing but called
as action commands and if you go here
you can see let me do one thing so let
me just come to a blank line and now
let's look at the list of commands so
you have a whole list of commands here
listed in the alphabetical order like
add selection there are multiple asset
commands which is made available to you
and then there are set of commands where
you say click or click at a particular
location closing the browser using a
debugger command double click drag and
drop echo i'll just explain how to use
an echo command so this is a command
which is not all used on your web
element but something which you want to
say display on your console and then
there are if else statements which are
used as commands here then you have
something called as execute script for
you to execute any say javascript or any
different script which you want to
execute from your test script here and
then you have few mouse commands here
open which is what we use for opening a
new url pause and so on so there are
multiple commands which you can look at
and try to use this commands in your
script so these are all called as the
action commands so let's go ahead and
use this echo command and see what it
does so now in the same script what i
will do is towards the end of the script
i'll just add this command i'll say echo
and say i want to just display a message
saying that this is
the end of the script execution that is
all i want to do now i'll just go ahead
and run this and what we want to observe
here is how this particular message what
we have given here is displayed on the
console in the log so now if you observe
here so go to this last statement what
we have so it says after clicking on the
card it said echo this is the end of the
script so this is what we displayed and
using the command echo okay so this is
how you can use the echo com another
feature here what you can do here is now
say for example i just added a simple
echo statement here now for me to
execute that what i did was i executed
the complete script you really need not
do that always instead of that what i
can do is i can just come to this
particular line i can just say right
click and i can say play from here so
what it does is from this point it is
going to play the script for me and not
right from the beginning of the script
so i'll show you how now with this
command if you look here see it started
running the script here it says running
search iphone and then it executed only
one command which says echo this is the
end of the script so this is also
possible to do with the id accessors
accesses are the selenium commands that
examine the state of an application and
store the results in a variable so these
are those commands which allow the user
to store say certain values into your
user defined variables and these stored
values can be later on used either to
create assertions or you can have some
verification points created so let's see
some of the store commands in action so
i have few store commands here which
i'll be demoing so first one is a store
so simply using a store command you can
store any kind of user defined messages
in a variable and then after that you
can either use it for displaying it on
your console or you can do some
assertions with that similarly store
title so you can to store the title of
any of the web page under test then
store text so store text is basically
used to uh capture the text attribute of
any web element on your web page and
store it in a variable use it as an
assertion point store value so store
value again is uh used to store the
value attribute of any web element like
so you have lot of web elements on the
web page and say one of the attributes
is what you want to do an assertion on
so what you can do is you can use the
store value command here get the value
attribute of your web element and store
it in a variable so let's all see all
these commands in action so let's go
back to the same example so we have this
amazon test script example so what i'll
do is
say instead of using amazon let's do one
thing so let's create another test case
itself so i'll go here i'll say add new
test and i will name this test as
accessor test and we will use the same
amazon site here i'll say click on start
recording keep this window side by side
so first we will look at store title so
simply what i need to do is go to this
amazon site which we have launched right
click on this go to selenium ide and you
have multiple options here so go ahead
and select store title so once i click
on that it is going to ask me the
variable name where i want to store the
title of this page so let's create a
variable here i'll say var title and
i'll say okay done now come back to your
ide all right so i will stop the
execution here now i have this store
title command i created a variable
called var title and i'm storing the
actual title into this variable so let's
also display this on our console so i'll
add a command here echo and in target
how do i use the variable now this is
the way to use it i'll say dollar and in
flower braces i will give the variable
name which i have defined earlier so it
is where i dle title okay so this is all
my scriptures where i'm storing the
title of the webpage and i'm displaying
it in my console or the lock so now
there are some extra commands which gets
added here now because we are doing the
recording on that so whatever the mouse
movements happen it is going to record
we do not need this so i will go ahead
and delete this particular command so
let's close this window and execute this
test first so the script has executed
successfully but let's go and see
whether did we get the title displayed
on the console yes so it did open the
amazon site it has set the window size
it captured the title here in this line
and then after assigning it to the
variable we said echo and that variable
name and it is displayed as the title of
the page so now similarly let's go ahead
and let's see how do we use the store
text command now for store text i need
an use case here say for example what
about this cut let's say we want to
display the text of this particular
element now the text of this element is
cut so now instead of again going and
re-recording all the steps i will simply
manually add this command so now after
displaying the title okay so let's go
ahead here and i will say store text and
in store text i need to pick the text
from this web element cart so what i
will do is i'll use this target select
target and i will select this particular
element which is cut after this i need
to create a variable where it can be
stored so i'll say where car text now
similarly i will also display it using
echo comma echo dollar in the flower
braces i'll say that car text so let's
execute this and then let's look at the
other command so i'll just say i'll
close this window again run this test so
now look at this log lines so our last
statements was storing the title and
displaying the title after that we added
store text okay so here is the command
it said it is executed successfully it
was able to retrieve the text from the
element cart and the text retrieved was
cart and which is what got displayed
with the echo statement on our console
so now let's move to our next store
command which is store value now as i
said store value for us to use that
particular web element should have the
attribute value so first let's examine
which element we can take and display
the value now on the same website i have
the search button so i will right click
on this and i say inspect element now
look at all the attributes of this
element it is of type input it has a
class name it is of type submit and also
it has this value attribute which is
gogo and this is exactly what i want to
retrieve and print so we will be using
the search button now similarly same
thing what i will do here i'll go ahead
add a command here as a stored value
same way i will select the target as i
select target from page i will click on
the search button all right so here it
has taken the target here in the value i
will mention the variable name where i
want to store the value so i'll say
where button and value and similarly i
will say echo and i will print the value
of this variable which is dollar where
btn value let's go ahead and execute
this and say run current test so it has
taken the title it has printed the value
on the line seven so it says store value
on this particular element and the value
was stored in the variable where btn
value so that command was successful and
the value actually which was got stored
and which we retrieved using echo
statement was jio and that's exactly
what we had here if you want to check
again go here to inspect element the one
which is highlighted so as you said the
value is go and that's exactly got
printed on our console now apart from
this i also said there is a simple
command which is just store so let's use
that also now after all this here i will
say store and say we want to just store
a user message i would say a target as
all store commands demo and this message
i will capture it in a variable say var
string this is just a text and then like
i did it in the other
string then i'll say echo and the
variable name so now if we close this
and one way to do it is execute the
complete test so which will execute all
our store commands and also the last
line is this the line number nine in the
log which says the store command which
we use to store the text all store
commands demo and that is also displayed
using the x so all the store commands we
have demo successfully now let's close
this window and go back to our
presentation so this is all about the
accessor command now what do we have
after accessor so we have something
called as assertions now what is an
assert so assertion is nothing but it
verifies the current state of an
application with an expected state so
this is something where you compare your
actual result with the expected result
now assertions are of three different
type one is assert verify and wait for
now what does assert does when the
assert command is executed and if it
fails right the test stops immediately
after this statement so if you are
asserting say
a title of a page and if you find that
the title of page is not as expected as
soon as it finds that failure your rest
of the test case test is not going to
run and it's going to immediately stop
the test and also it is going to flag
the test cases fail what is verify
verify something where the selenium id
it locks that particular assertion as
fail however it would continue with the
rest of the steps in the test case and
then at the end of it the your overall
test case is flagged as fake that is
what verified us so verify is called a
soft assertion whereas assert here is
called as hard assertion why it is
called harder session because as soon as
an assert statement fails the complete
test execution stops at that statement
whereas in soft assert what happens is
after the failure happens the test
continues with the rest of the steps and
continue it completes its execution and
then flags the test cases failure and
when is this usually used in cases like
as the same example say if you are
asserting a title you really do not want
the test case execution to stop even if
there is a failure why because none of
your steps are going to be dependent on
this assertion point and this is where
you will require a soft hazard wait for
wait for something which waits for a
certain condition to be true after that
it proceeds to your further steps so if
the condition goes false here for
whatever say if you are waiting for an
element to appear on the webpage and if
that element does not appear the test
fails however it carries forward and
completes the test by executing the rest
of the steps and then flags the complete
test case as a failure which will be
something similar to a softer cell so
let's see all these things in action
let's go back to our id we will create
another test case here so i'll say
assert test now for this what's the
example we can take so first for assert
title let's do the assert title on
amazon itself and let's change the same
test case to verify and see how this
test case behave now for this i will
launch the recorder with the same amazon
dot in okay my recorder is launched now
simply i will go to this website and
i'll say right click selenium ide and
i'll say assert title then i will stop
the recording now here i will remove
this command which has got added which i
don't need so this is my asset title now
we have already seen a third title
passing in couple of our other examples
now i want to show you a failure on
ourselves so for that what i will do i
will modify this actual type so here in
the last line i'll just remove this
amazon.com so now ideally this test case
is going to fail first because the title
which it is expecting and what it is
comparing against are not the same first
let's execute this um well i also need
to show some statements after this so
what i will do is let's add few more
statements here let me start the
recording here again say after asserting
the title we want to go and click on
this bestseller and then i will close
this now let's execute this stop the
recording and execute this test now do
you see this assert title is in red that
means it has failed the validation here
so you see here in the log it says open
the site done set window size done when
it comes to azure title it says actual
value was something different and it did
not match with what you are trying to
look for assert test ended with one
error now after this assert please
observe that there are no other
statements which got executed this test
stopped right away after this failure
this is called as hard asset now let's
go ahead and change this assert title to
verify title so simply what i will do in
the command itself instead of assert
i'll say verify title and now let's
execute this and see what happens now
let me close this window first and then
i'll say run test running assert test
amazon dot in was open window size was
set verify title failed because the
titles were different because we have
modified that however do you see this
fourth line being executed click on link
test bestseller and click on close now
since i it was a very fast execution and
i closed the browser probably was you
were not able to see the best sellers
clicked here that is fine but in the log
we can see here that the steps 4 and 5
got executed even after the title verify
title step fit and if you compare it
with the previous example where assert
title failed the two lines after that
the line 4 where we are clicking on the
best seller and closing the browser are
not getting executed so this is the main
difference between the verify title and
the asset title so now let's look at
wait for how do we use wait for now for
wait for i want to look at some kind of
website where it would load an element
dynamically after a while so for that i
have a website here let's let's create a
new test again let's go to the tests
pane i will say assertion test and now
uh let's go to a browser we open
a new window and there is a demo site
which i want to use so let me search for
that and then i will use that url so
i'll say internet i'm going to use the
dynamic loading do we have here yes
dynamic loading page element rendered
now see if you look at this website when
i press on the start button right after
the file this hello world text is going
to appear on this webpage so in our use
case what we will do we will launch this
website we will click on the start
button and then we will put an assert on
this text using wait for let's do that
so let's go here let me copy this this
is the one let me say control c and in
my new test i'll say control v and then
i'll say start recording so it's going
to launch this let's close the previous
windows now in this i'm just going to
click on start so that is going to get
recorded done and now while the
recording is still on i will add a
command here for wait for so i'll say
wait for element visible that is exactly
what we are saying right so wait for is
used until for a condition and until
that condition is true so i am saying
here please wait for this particular
element which i am going to give it in
target until it is visible now the
target is i'm just going to select the
target from this web page itself so i'll
say select target and i'm going to
select this particular text come back
here to your id so wait for the element
to be visible what is the element to be
visible is this hello volta hello world
text and then you need to give a value
here now what is this value since we are
using wait for we need to mention a
timeout so we have to tell basically to
id that okay wait for say one second two
seconds or three seconds whatever it is
require and that timeout value is needs
to be mentioned here so and this is in
milliseconds so what i will say is i'll
say so let's fail this test case first
so i'll use a little lesser timer so
i'll say three thousand so that is three
thousand milliseconds which is three
seconds that is it and then we can say
so what we'll do here is we'll add an
assert so i will say assert text now
what is the other text i'm going to do i
need to look for the same element so
i'll simply say select target this one
and what is that i'm going to assert
with i'm going to assert with the same
text so i'll just copy this text and
i'll put it in the value there's another
way of doing that which we have done it
previously so i can just go here do a
right click go to selenium id and i can
say assert text which is basically going
to give me the same command so let me
just go ahead and remove one of them
either of them you can remove okay so
let's stop the recording i will not
close this browser because i want you to
see how the dynamically loaded element
behaves and will go ahead and execute
this so i'll say stop recording and say
execute this test now it's here all
right so it's waiting okay it has failed
now see this so it says wait for element
visible after that the value we have
mentioned is 3000 that is wait for 3
seconds which was not enough because and
it failed with saying that unable to
locate the element within the timer
period now let's go ahead and change it
to a passing value so i will say 10 000
here which is 10 seconds so
let's close this
and let's again execute this
bring this to the side so that we can
see okay it is waiting on that wait for
element now look at the problem here
what we have done is we have closed the
website and after that we have added the
assert text so this is a mistake what we
have done and hence though it is found
that element here for wait for what did
it do it went ahead and closed the
window and after that it's definitely
not going to find the assertive right so
that's the mistake what we have done so
let's go ahead and debug this so what we
will do after this wait for element we
want this assert to be put after that we
don't need this click content because
this was an additional step which got
added delete it and then close okay fine
so now let's go ahead and rerun this
let's say run current test i'll move
this to a side okay it's waiting all
right done so now it is able to do an
assert text on this all right so this is
how you use the wait for key features of
selenium id let's look at the first
feature reusability of test scripts so
many of the test scripts have test steps
that involves signing into an
application or creating an account like
for example a login screen is a very
key example in this case where whenever
you are testing your application first
you need to log in and then perform any
other test so now it's going to be a
redundant or a waste of time to recreate
the login steps again and again for each
and every test case so we do not want to
definitely do that so as we know since a
record and replay tool does not have
enough capability of writing common test
cases or a common functions and calling
those common factions like our regular
selenium webdriver has however what id
is done is it has given us a provision
to run one script from another script so
what basically what we do here is
especially for a login we write one test
case which is going to log into your
application and call this test case in
the other test cases so let's take a a
look at how this works so for that let's
go to our ide so in this id
we'll do one thing let's go ahead and
create a new project so let's say login
project in this project i will create a
new test case we'll call it as login
test let's say add now in this login
test i need to give a url now for this
purpose i will be using again a demo
site so first let me
launch a demo site here file new window
and i will see the demo site go dot uk
okay this is a simple demo site which
has a login functionality right so here
i will go to the login screen now this
also allows me to add few users and
using the same users we can go ahead and
do the login now coming back to our
login page so this is the url which i
need to launch which is going to give us
username and password we will use to
login into this application so give this
url here and say start recording move
this window here for recording and this
here now what is the first step we want
to record we want to come here click on
the username and i'll say user1 okay and
i'll say password pwd1 and i will click
on test login and then what we will do
is we will assert this text so here i'll
say right click selenium id assert text
that's it and then i will close the
browser okay this is all my test is now
come back to your id let's see if there
are any unnecessary commands which it
has taken okay click type all done and
now for the time being i'm going to
comment out this close comment because i
want the browser to be still open so
that we can see the actual test
execution properly till the end of the
script this is the login test case now
simply if i run this let's execute this
let me execute this in show stop the
recording and execute this test case so
it typed user one it typed pwd which is
my password here and then clicked on the
button and then definitely it was the
wrong password so it gave me field
locking so this is fast fantastic
however this is with one value i have
used it but this is a function which i
want to use it every time and also a
probable use case i might have is that i
might need to log in with a different
user id and password and apart from that
even just to test this login test page i
would want to test with multiple user id
and password like valid credentials and
invalid credential now for that purpose
what we will do is we will parameterize
this name that is user id and the
password and how do i parameterize it
simply go here instead of giving a hard
coded value here what you can do is just
say use any variable name here and we'll
define this variable somewhere else so
i'll say username this is the variable
similarly for my password in my value
field instead of a hard coded value i'll
say dollar and i will say password now i
cannot run this program as it is because
there is this variable is not defined in
the login.test what i will do now is i
will create my actual test case so i'll
say here i'll say invalid credential as
my test case and i'll say add now here
is where i will assign values for my
variable now which are these variables i
need to use user name and password so i
need to assign some value here and then
call this function login test so let's
do that in this video previously we also
saw how do we use user variables and how
do we assign value by using the store
command so i'm going to say store and
then my target is going to be the actual
value so
user1 and where is that i'm going to
pass this to my variable username so
let's just check once if the variable
name is username yes all right done now
i have done the username now i need to
pass the password so again i'll say
store the actual password which is pwd1
in my case and what is the variable i
need to use here i have to use password
because that's the variable which we
have used in login test here and then
after that i need to use a command which
is called as run now what this run
command does is run and whatever target
you give which is basically your another
test case it is going to run the test
case now in our case our test is login
test this is all our test case is going
to be okay so what is that we did we do
in this test case we created a variable
username and password and assigned the
actual username and password and then we
are just calling this login test and in
this login test this username and
password will get passed which will be
user1 and pwd1 and then it will execute
this test with the or with the value
which we have passed to this variable so
now which test case we need to run the
invalid credential so let's go ahead
close this window and execute this test
executed so now look at the log of this
invalid credential test see running
login test called by invalid credential
before that it said store this value
store user1 in the value username that
is your variable this is this line and
then the password then it says run login
test so it called the login test
functionality and in the login test we
have all this clicking on the password
field clicking on the username and then
asserting the text and that's exactly
what is done here this is how you use it
so now let's write one more test here
for the same login test so let me add
another test i'll say valid credentials
and let's say add now same thing i will
do here i'll say command store my target
will be now i'll say user3 value will be
username right okay now second command
will be again storing this time it is
for the password my password is pwd3 and
the variable name is password and same
thing i'll just call run and my login
test that's it now similarly let's run
this test and see what happens now this
test is going to fail why let me close
this window i don't need this why did
this test case fail because my assertion
point let's go to the tests i'll show
you my assertion point in login test is
look for failed login however we created
a test case for valid credentials right
because our valid credentials were said
that the login was successful which did
not match with what we were asserting
which is fine right so we just wanted to
see whether we can write a test case
with valid credentials and invalid
credentials and this is how you do that
by passing the variables through your
test case to your actual test case the
next feature is the debugger in the ide
like every other ide offers a debugger
functionality so does selenium id so
let's look at what are the different
functions available for us in the
debugging so there are multiple
functionalities which the selenium ide
offers us so one is called as the step
execution so for us to look at how each
of these debugging techniques works what
i'll do is let's go ahead and create a
new test script so let's go to our id
and i will create a new test case so
i'll say new test case let's use
facebook login this time so i'll say fb
login test or we'll just say fb test so
now for this fb test i would go ahead
and use the facebook login page so i'll
just copy this url paste it here and
then i will minimize this other firefox
window and i will launch the recorder
now so i'll click on start recording now
let's keep this side by side and what is
that we are going to do here is let's do
a simple login functionality so i'll
just use some email id here so i'll say
my user at gmail.com this is just a
dummy user id and password i'll use and
i'll say password as password1 then i'll
click on login button let's stop the
recording here so let's read the script
once whether it has got everything
whatever we need okay it has launched
facebook it clicked on email id there's
a double clicks here because i happen to
click twice on the email id field so
what i'll do i'll remove one we don't
need it and then i'm typing the keys
which is myuser.gmail and then i'm
clicking on the password field typing
the password and clicking on the login
button and then once i do that okay so
i'm going to get this pages the password
you have entered is incorrect so let it
be so we will use the script until here
and check out some of the login options
okay so we have completed writing of the
script let me go ahead and close this
window now first thing what we will do
is we will just simply execute the
script so we have to just say run
current test so it's going to log in
your facebook it'll enter my user at
gmail it'll enter the password it'll log
in and that's about it so now your
script is executed now let's go into the
debug mode as we said there are multiple
options for debugging what is the first
option let's see the first option we
have is something called a step
execution so what the step execution
does is from your script you can execute
all the steps one after the other so you
can basically control the execution of
each step and how you do that what you
have to do is just go and click anywhere
so let's start from the beginning let's
close this window of our previous run
and there is an option here which says
step over current command so when you
click on this what it does is it
basically executes your first line where
your cursor was and it stops immediately
after that so if you look here it has
launched the facebook page which says
open the url facebook and then let's go
ahead and just do the simple step
execution again i will click on that it
is going to execute this command where
it set the window size to certain value
again i will do a step execution now
observe what happens here it clicked on
this email field do you see the cursor
there now let's do the next step again
again i will do step over current
command now the current command was it
entered my user at gmail you can see it
on the left side here now it will be
more visible again i will do a step
execution it is going to click on the
password field now it is going to enter
the password and now the last step is
it's going to click on the login button
and with this all our commands are
executed and this is how you do the step
execution and now where is this useful
say if you've got a very long test case
written and you want at certain point
you want to start doing the step
execution to see where your test cases
fail probably one of your web element
you entered is wrong or probably the
text which you are entered is wrong so
for you to debug such cases you can use
this step over current command
functionality so what's our next command
break points so there are break points
which you can insert in your script okay
so let's close this execution and let's
come back to our script so what i will
do is first let's add a breakpoint how
do you add a breakpoint say for example
we want to add a breakpoint after we
type in our email id so here what i do
is i simply go and click here so once
you click here this is where your
breakpoint is added other way of adding
breakpoint is you can right click on any
command and you can use this toggle
breakpoint so if there is no breakpoint
it adds the breakpoint and for you to
remove it you can simply go and select
the toggle breakpoint again so now i've
added a single breakpoint now what you
need to do is once you execute this once
you say run test what it will do is it
will come till here till your break
point it will execute all the commands
before that and it stops or pauses your
execution at this point okay let's go
ahead and see how it does so what i'll
do is i've added a breakpoint at the
click on password field and i will say
execute this test do you see here it
says paused in the debugger so by adding
breakpoint my test has entered the
debugging mode and where has it stopped
to at the point where i added this
breakpoint so just go back here and see
whether the previous steps have been
executed yes my previous step was adding
this my user at gmail.com into the email
field which it is done and it has paused
here and now from here i can either run
the rest of the tests if i just click on
this run current test what it will do is
it will go ahead and execute all the
steps or even i can do a step execution
from here so say if i want to do a step
execution i'll do this let me minimize
this window a little bit so that you can
see and i'm still again doing that step
execution so it added the password and
after this i'll say just go ahead and
complete the test so it is clicked on
your sign in login button and it is
logged in so this is how you can use the
breakpoint so that is about adding the
breakpoint let's see what's the next
removing the breakpoint so i showed you
so if you want to add a breakpoint you
just click here or you can do a right
click and do toggle breakpoint if you
want to remove the breakpoint just click
again on the same place where it has
added the breakpoint or you can always
do this toggle breakpoint so this is the
way of adding and removing the
breakpoints what is the third option
disabling now say for example my test
case is a pretty long one okay so i
might have a multiple breakpoints so say
let's add one breakpoint here at the
email and then before clicking on login
let's add another breakpoint now when i
execute this it is going to stop here
and then again if i say continue
execution it is going to come and stop
here so let's do that first and then
i'll show you how the disable works so
let's close this window again execute
this bring this window here can you see
this it's paused here okay and here now
you should be able to see it now i'll
say just run after this breakpoint do
you see here it is paused after entering
the password it has not clicked on the
login button it's paused at the click
and now i'll say again complete the test
so your click on the login button is
done and it is logged in so it's a
little bit slow yeah now you got that
logged in page at some point of time
while i'm debugging my test case i would
want to just disable all the breakpoints
and not remove everything for that i
have an option here which says disable
breakpoint so if this button is
highlighted here that means i have
selected disable breakpoint so what this
does is when i execute this test it
ignores all this breakpoints for this
run it ignores this breakpoint until i
have selected this disable breakpoint
button okay so let's see this let me
close this again and i have enabled this
disable breakpoint is what i have
selected i'll just simply go ahead and
run this test case do you see that it
did not stop at this break point it went
ahead and completed the execution why
because i have temporarily disabled it
once i remove the selection and run it
it is again going to stop at the
breakpoints so this is how it works so
we saw adding of breakdowns removing of
breakpoints and disabling of breakpoints
what is the next one enter debugger by
using play to this point option okay now
another way of doing this is so let's
remove all this breakpoint now for
example like the last time we said we
want to add a breakpoint here so now
instead of doing that what i can do also
do is i can just right click on that
particular command and i can say play to
this point only so when i select this
what happens it acts like a break point
and it comes and pauses at this
particular command where i have said
play till this point so let's try to do
that so let me close this window and
then for say type the password so here
okay i'll say right click play to this
point so it is going to execute all the
steps until the password and it will
stop here can you see this paused in the
debugger so it again enter the debug
mode and now it is stopped at this point
so now there are multiple options now
every time last time what we did we did
a step over and also we said continue
with the rest of the test now what we
will do we'll just stop the execution so
this is also an option available say if
you want to change something here you do
not want to continue with your execution
you can simply go ahead and stop the
execution so we saw how do we use the
play to this point option now debugger
command now all these things whatever we
did now adding the breakpoints this was
done in the id there is also a way of
adding a debugger programmatically and
how do we do that let's see now in the
same place say after entering the
password so here i will insert a command
in this command i'll just say debugger
this is all the command is now what
happens when i execute this test cases
at this point wherever it finds this
debugger command this program enters
into a debug mode and it comes and
pauses the script here let's see this in
action so simply i'll just play the
script let's type the email id it's
typed the password okay it is going a
little slower here okay and there there
you go now it is paused in debugger so
this debugger did the same job as what
we did earlier with the breakpoints now
let's go ahead and just stop the
execution because let's not keep logging
into facebook with invalid username and
id okay so this is how you can use the
debugger command so i will stop the
execution here close this window and
then now let's see the next one let's
close this window so we saw the debug
pause on exception okay this is a very
brilliant feature of this id i'll show
you how it works now let's say let me
remove this command now i do not want
the debugger i'll say delete this
command just click let it be there now
if you look at this what we are doing is
we are identifying these elements like
email password and then clicking on the
login button now say for example say
this click so let's run this then i'll
show you what it is and i wanted to and
stop here okay so i will execute this
all right so now it is paused here so
now what i will do is the click right so
this is where i am clicking is this
login button so this login button is
identified by some identifier which is
an id now there is a possibility that
tomorrow this particular id might change
or any of the locator might change on
this particular website and if that
happens the first point of failure what
you will see is when you click on this
button because this script will say that
this element is not found in such cases
if you are using pause on exception that
is here pause an exception what happens
is whenever this script finds an
exception it goes and pauses at that and
enters into a debug mode otherwise what
happens whenever you find an exception
your complete test script will stop
executing because there is an error and
your test case fails instead since we
are in a debugging mode if you choose
this option what happens is if there is
an exception it is going to come get
into the debugger mode and it is going
to pause the execution at that point and
once it pauses what you can do is you
can go and correct it and then continue
your execution so let's see that in
action so now for example the click
button so here the id is u underscore 0
underscore a so say i try to change this
let me add 1 here and then if i execute
this this script should fail for me
basically because it is not going to
find this so can you see us trying to
find this id and since this particular
element with this id does not exist this
whole test case should fail for me now
as i said earlier in this video so if by
any chance if one of the element id is
not found so if that is not found it
always falls back into the other locator
techniques and that is what it did in
this case it tried to locate the login
button using some other id and that's
what it says element found with the
secondary locator okay to use it by
default update the test step and to use
it as a primary locator and that is
where the test case pass so let's try to
see if i can make this test case fail in
any way for that let's remove this and
let's try on the email id so what i will
do is let me try to comment this out
remove the debugger and i will add a
command here i'll say insert new command
and in this i will say click and then i
will use the target as id equal to email
now in this case i do not have a
fallback id because i am not using id to
recognize the element rather i added my
own command and i added my own locator
here so now let's try with this and now
instead of this is the right id so what
i will do is i'll just change this id to
something like underscore one so that
this test case fails for me now let me
close this and let's run this test case
and basically this test case should fail
so if you see here in the log it's
saying trying to find the element with
id email underscore one so this id has a
default timer so it will keep trying to
find the element until the timeout value
is completed now there we go so it had
an implicit timeout of 30 000 so that is
30 seconds 30 000 milliseconds which was
30 seconds now after that this test is
filled so this is the scenario we wanted
what happens here is it simply started
executing the moment it found an
exception it completely stopped so as a
tester what you need to do is you need
to go back look for this red lines where
it has failed correct it and then re-run
the whole test now instead of that what
this pause and exception does is let me
click on that so this is what is
selected now what it does is when i
execute this this is going to come and
stop here let's see that so let me close
this and run this program again so run
current test i'll bring this to the side
now see it's trying to find the id since
the timeout is almost 30 seconds we need
to wait until it pauses at this so now
do you see this now it is not exited
from the test it is just at the same
step where it is unable to find this
email field okay and it's saying okay it
failed with an implicit timeout of 30
seconds but now since i'm in the
debugging mode and how did i get into
the debug mode by selecting this option
pause an exception now what i can do is
i can go ahead and change this back to
the actual one and then from here i can
just simply do this i can say run the
test now so now see what it did the
moment i changed that and i said run it
passed and how did it pass because i
gave the right id here and that's
exactly you can do with this deeper
control flow statements so in the legacy
id uh these control flow statements were
available as plugin so one had to
install the plugin for you to use any of
this control flow statements however in
the new ide these are available out of
box so let's see what these control
statements are so let's go to my notes
so there are two types of control flow
statements one is conditional branching
and the other one is looping so in
conditional branching we have a regular
if else if nested if else and end and
when we talk about looping there are
multiple loops available one is the
while end loop so how does the while end
loop work the code between the while and
the end is executed until the expression
is true and then we have a do repeat so
do repeat where the commands after the
do will get executed first and then the
condition is checked and this is
evaluated in the if statement times end
so you can specify a number of
iterations you would like a piece of
code to be executed using this loop and
then there is another loop which is a
for each loop so this provides the
ability to iterate over collection
objects like say if you have an array
object with you and you want to say or
traverse through the array and perform
certain operations on each of the array
element so that is possible using the
for each loop so let's go and write a
test script and see how this work so
what i will do is i will demonstrate a
use case for the if else and then for
the looping i have a few test scripts
which i have already written which i
will show you and i will walk you
through them it's a simple counter which
we can use where it will be incrementing
the counter using one of these loops so
we will just uh see how the loops are to
be used what is the syntax to be used
and how they execute in the id so let us
go to our id now let let's minimize this
so this was our previous test case so
what i will do is i will close this
project and open another project so i
have another project here which is
called as control flows so as i said i
have few scripts written for some of the
loop however for the demo use case we
will go ahead and write a new script so
i'll say add new test and
we are going to be working with a demo
site called calorie calculator okay so
let me name the test case itself as
calorie calculator test so let's look at
what is our use case now in this use
case this is my use case i am saying go
to this gallery counter website okay so
let's see what that website is i have
this website open here so this is a
calorie calculator website in this
website we are saying if the gender is
male then click on the mail radio button
so you have multiple fields here where
you are accepting the age of a person
the gender of a person the height the
weight and then the activity level of
the person and when when you click on
calculate this is going to give you the
number of calories so for our purpose
for our demo use case what we will do is
we will store the gender to be selected
in a variable say for example i want a
gender female to be selected and then
i'm going to write an if condition here
that if the gender is male right so if
the gender is male then click on the
mail radio button here and then i'm
saying click active from the activity
drop down so there's a drop down called
activity here in this i am going to go
and select active as daily exercise or
intense exercise three to four times a
week this is what i am going to be
selecting and if the gender is female so
if the value passed from the gender is
female then what is that i want to do i
want to click on this radio button
female and select very active intense
exercise from this activity dropped up a
very simple use case so this is what we
are going to write in our test script so
let's minimize this window or we can
just close this window for now we don't
need this and here so how do we start
this test case i need to enter the url
so for me to enter the url let me go to
that copy this url ctrl c minimize this
and ctrl v done so now here i will start
my recording by clicking on the start
recording button so now this url is open
now the first thing what i need to do is
in my test script i need to write a open
command so i'll say open and my target
is what this you are done the next
command is as per our use case i want to
store the gender to be selected in a
variable so we will use the store
command and when we use the store
command we need to specify the target so
let's say the target is f and where is
that i want to store i'll create a var
gender that's my variable so i have
stored this now what is the next thing i
want to do so once i have stored this
first is i need to put an if statement
because my use case is if the gender is
male and if the gender is female now
since by default the male is already
selected here so let's put an if
condition for this condition if the
gender is female okay so that is exactly
what i am going to do so here i will say
if in the command once i say if in the
target you need to specify the condition
now condition is i want to check for
dollar that's my variable where gender i
want to check if this is equal to f and
how is that i can check i need to use 3
equal to here in double quotes i'm going
to mention f now this is what i have
stored in the variable bar gender this
is what i'm going to check so if this is
the condition in the next line now all
the next lines whatever i am going to
mention are the ones which will be
executed if this condition is true now
in the next line what i want is i want
to select this radio button correct so
now what i will do instead of writing
all the commands manually i will now use
a recorder to do that since i'm already
in the recording mode i'll just go to
the url or the website here and i'll go
click on this female so on the right if
you see these steps are getting recorded
and then our use case also said that
from the activity drop down we want to
select very active so now if you look
here all our steps have been recorded so
i clicked on the female radio button and
then we selected the id activity here
which is our activity drop down and then
we clicked on the desired value which is
very active and then you end the if
statement here so but we also want to
add an else statement so instead of
saying end here i will say else so that
means if the gender selected is mail
okay what is that we want to do i want
to go and select in the activity field
as active because the mail is already
selected so i'm not going to select it
again and then i will end the if loop by
end statement that is all so this is all
my script is so let's stop the recording
here there are some mouse move mouse up
which i really do not need so what i
will do is i'll just delete this so this
is the simple statement what i need in
the else where i'm saying select so
select is something a command which is
used to select a web element which is
your drop down so you select the drop
down here and once the drop down is
clicked and then you go ahead and click
on
this particular target is nothing but
your active daily exercises or intense
this value from the drop down is what
i'm selecting and same same thing what
we did in the if statement so let's
remove these also we don't
mouse move at and mouse up at so all
these statements we don't need so same
thing if i am saying the if statement
says if the gender is f that is female
click on the radio button then go to the
select activity select the activity by
clicking on very active and then end the
loop so this is all our scriptures now
let's go ahead and execute this and see
whether it works so let's minimize this
window and i will simply say execute the
current test let's slow down the
execution speed little bit so that you
can observe what exactly is happening
now i'll say run the current test so the
calorie calculator is open so we are
passing the value f for the gender
correct so that means it entered this
loop you can see here in the lock so if
the gender is f which is female yes it
found the condition to be true and then
it clicked on this radio button it went
to the select field which is your
activity drop down it selected the very
active option from here and then it
ended now in the same program what i
will do instead of f let's pass the
value m mail and let's see what happens
and then we will go ahead and execute
this program so let's close this window
again and execute the test script again
so now according to the script we are
not re-selecting the radio button
because this is already selected by
default and in this descript if you see
now all the green colored one if you see
okay the open command ran successfully
store commander and successfully it came
to the if condition it checked if the
gender was f or m it found that this
condition is not true so can you see
here all these other statements in the
if are in black color that means these
were not executed instead it came to the
else part and then it executed all the
commands in the else part so this is how
you use a if condition in your selenium
id so let's close this now as i said
there are other looping statements what
we have like while end loop or do repeat
and time set so i have couple of
examples written here let's walk through
that and see so let's take the while
loop first so what happens in this while
loop let's see in this while loop what
i'm basically doing is i have created a
counter and i am counting it from 1 to 5
and then displaying the value of the
counter and i am using a while loop for
that so here it says first i am setting
a counter value to 1 and then i am
saying while the counter value is less
than 5 this is the loop while and end so
whatever commands are within that those
get executed until the condition is true
so this loop will get executed until the
counter becomes 5 so once it sees that
counter is 5 it is going to exit the
loop and just print the value of the
counter it's as simple as while loop so
just pay attention to the syntax the way
it has been used here so this execute
script is what a simple statement what i
have used this could be anything it
could be any of your web elements you're
performing certain operations say there
is a calculator which you are using say
a calculator under test so if you want
to key in certain numbers until say the
sum of the numbers is 30 or something an
example like that could be a valid use
case for your while loop so you could
use that so let's execute this and see
how the counter works so if i execute
this command so now take a look at the
log here this is running while test so
first statement where it assigned the
counter value and then it got into the
while loop and it executed the volume
until the counter was assigned the value
5 and once the counter became 5 the
while loop got exited and we are
printing the counter value so this is
how a while loop is used now similarly
the same function of using a counter i
have tried to use a do loop here so
let's look at it now in the do loop what
happens is the first the script is
executed because it's the first command
after the do statement so whatever is
between the do and repeat if is executed
and then the condition is checked here
so here what i'm doing is i'm just first
assigning a counter with value 0 and i'm
incrementing the counter every time by
10 and then i have a condition that once
the counter becomes 50 please exit the
loop that's all i'm doing here and
another statement what i have written
here is every time the counter gets
incremented i am printing the value of
the counter so let's execute this can
you see that the way it is executing it
all right now let's see the lock running
do loop test okay the counter has been
initialized to 0 and then it executes
the script and this script is doing what
it is just incrementing the counter by
10. the counter becomes 10 and then 20
30 40 and 50. so as soon as it becomes
50 it's going to exit the loop and print
the value of the counter so one thing to
notice is there is no web element or
website testing which i am doing from
the script however one thing what the id
needs is it needs a starting point so
whenever you create a new test kit it
asks you to at least give it a url from
where it can start though it is not
going to launch that url it is going to
launch your browser definitely before
even it executes a single line of test
so that is something a mandatory in the
id so we saw do loop we saw the while
loop there's also something called as
time slope so which is what i have said
here times and n so this is something
you can specify a number of iterations
you would like to perform a set of
commands so now in this example what am
i doing i'm simply incrementing a
counter by one right and i'm saying just
increment that is this is the only
command which i want to execute but i
wanted to execute two types that's all
so there is no other conditions here it
is simply saying there is a set of
command or a single command which i want
to execute it twice and the number of
times which i want to execute is what i
mentioned here in the target so first
initially i am assigning a counter with
value 100 and then i am saying increment
this counter by one two times and then
print the value of the counter so let's
execute this and then change the number
of times if i say run test here so can
you see this the number of times it got
titrated and now the value is 102 why
because initial value was 100 in the
loop which is the time slope i am saying
the iterations is 2 2 times execute the
command which increments the counter by
one so that is why your counter value
becomes 102. now say i increase this to
say 10 so that we get a feel of how the
loop executes here and same thing i will
execute it now see it you can visually
see the number of times the loop is
getting executed all right and in the
log you can see the values also here
okay can you see here so this loop
executed 10 times and hence the counter
value becomes 110 so these are a simple
ways of using these loops in the id so
you can implement this loops for any
kind of functionality you may want to
perform on your web elements or any
logic which you want to build for your
test cases selenium side runner selenium
side runner is a command line runner
tool which allows the user to run your
selenium id test cases on any browsers
or to run the test cases parallelly and
also it gives you a mechanism to use the
grid setup to run your test cases on a
remote machine okay so for us to work
with this selenium side runner there are
certain uh installations which we need
to do and some of the installation
prereqs are one is you need a node.js
server and what is this node.js server
node.js server is a powerful javascript
based platform and this is the platform
which is intensively used by many
developers across the world for
developing their web applications and
it's an open source and it is available
free of cost to everyone to use it so we
will need to go ahead and install a
node.js server for this so now let's
look at all the installation steps which
are involved in installing the side
runner and running it okay so let's go
to my notes so the
seleniumhq.org has a complete
documentation on how to install this
command line runner how to use it and
what are the different ways we can use
this runner i'll just show you where it
is and you can use this as a reference
for any of the tests which you are
creating and using the side runner to
run it
so let me open a new window here let's
go to this website
so if you see here it has a complete
guide on how to use this command line
runner right including the setups what
is the prereqs installing the browser
drivers and
how do you do the different
configurations which are available with
the side runner so you can configure
various browsers with that you can set
different capabilities for the browser
if you want to use the selenium grid to
run your test cases on remote servers it
also gives you complete details on how
do we do that and also using the
parameters changing your base url so
this is a complete guide which you can
refer to when you're working with the
site runner okay so let's go back to our
installation
so coming back to our installation here
so the first prereq what we need for the
selenium side runner to run is your
node.js okay so if you go to this
website nodejs.org
let me open the same
browser okay
all right so here you will see that the
node.js is available as an installable
for all the platforms like do you have a
windows installer you have mac os
installer you have linux installers also
so if you're working with the windows
machine there are two options for you
either you can go ahead and download the
msi installer or you can just download
the zip and unzip it into any folder on
your system okay and since i'm using mac
machine what i have done is i have
downloaded this version pkg version and
have installed it on my machine okay so
once you download say if you're working
on the windows machine so say 64-bit is
what you require and you click here and
download the zip package i'll show you
how the folder structure looks like so
this is where i have downloaded the
node.js installable now if you look at
the windows one so this is what happens
when you download the zip file and unzip
it this is the folder structure it
creates and this is what we would need
right so npm is something which we would
be using to install all the packages
which are required on this node.js
server and i'll explain to you what
those packages are okay so once you do
this installation you need to go and
check if your installation is gone
properly or not so for that what you do
is go to your terminal window or in your
case if you're using a windows machine
just open a command prompt right and
then you have to just give this command
here you say npm minus v which is
basically saying what is the version of
the node.js which we have installed
which is 6.9 okay now what is this npn
npm is nothing but it's a node.js
package manager and it gets installed
with your node and this is used to
install all your other packages or what
it is called as modules on your system
okay so now with this we know that our
npm has been installed properly so let's
move to the next step of installation so
now we have our node.js installed now
next thing is to install the selenium
side runner now the selenium side runner
is a library which is available to us
and we need to install this library
using the npn so let me go back to my
terminal again so i'll just show you the
command what it is what we use for
installing this package or the library
and since i've already installed on my
machine i will not be doing the
installation here so what you need to do
so if you are a windows user you can
directly give the command as npn install
minus g selenium side
runner okay so this is the command which
you need to get however if you're a mac
user or a unix user since you need to
use a root user here what you need to do
is just say sudo once you press enter
here it will go ahead and install this
complete library on your system now
since i've already installed i'm not
going to do that okay so i'll just exit
from this now once the installation is
done how do you check whether your
installation has gone correctly or not
you have to just simply give a command
like selenium side runner minus version
okay and now this will give you the
version number if the installation has
been successful so right now the version
installed which is the latest version is
3.11 okay so so far we have done the
installation of the node.js server we
have done the installation of the
selenium now while you all also you do
this installation you need to know that
where is the selenium ide side runner
has been installed right as i said it's
a library or what you popularly call as
module in your npm right so for you to
check whether where it has got installed
you simply need to go to the directory
i'll say ls minus user local library so
if you see here you'll see something
called as node modules so whatever
packages you're going to install using
npm would get installed in this
directory the node modules directory so
let's go ahead and see whether i have my
selenium side runner there or not so
i'll just use the same ls slash
node modules okay do you see this
selenium side runner is what has got
installed and previously to that when we
installed the node.js server it also
installed this npm right so that is also
available under the same folder so for
so good so we have our selenium ide
installed now what else is required so
we installed the node.js we installed
the selenium side runner now we need
this browser drivers now what are these
browser drivers now what you did using
your id was let me
in ide was we said right in the id
itself i said run the current test and
since i'm using firefox browser here any
test case using the ide plugin on your
firefox you execute is going to execute
on the firefox browser correct same way
if you are using the selenium ide on
chrome which is an extension on chrome
and you run the test cases there it is
going to use the chrome browser to run
the test case however any test cases or
any automation scripts you're going to
write you want your scripts to run on
all the browsers because you want to do
a cross browser testing right so for
that purpose what we do through command
line is we install this browser drivers
right so say if you want to run your
test cases on edge browser so that means
you first need to install your edge
browse driver on your systems before you
run your test case on edge process if
you want to do it for chrome similarly
you need to download the chrome web
webdriver and install it for firefox the
same and once you install that then you
should be able to run it on any browser
now where are these chrome browsers
available so if you go to the
seleniumhq.org let me show you that
okay in the selenium hq website if you
go to this download tab right and if you
go down here you will see something
called as third party drivers bindings
and plugins and here you have a list of
all the browsers and its corresponding
driver files which are available and
this is what which you need to go and
download for example say i want to run
all my tests on chrome browser right so
what i do is i click here okay in the
download section go to the latest chrome
driver available click on that and then
depending on which os you're working on
if you're working on mac just download
this if you're working on
windows you download this and once you
download the driver what you need to do
is you keep that drivers like for
example
can you see this driver file so this is
my driver file this is my executable
driver file so what i did was i just
downloaded this file for mac and i
copied it to the location where my tests
are present okay now so once i have this
available what i need to do is i need to
install this driver using again the npm
command and to install this driver what
you need to do is you need to be in the
same directory where your driver file is
present in the same directory you just
issue this command you say npm install
minus g and your chrome driver
this is it so once you install this
driver you should be able to work with
your chrome driver got it very simple so
similarly if you're working with
different browsers say if you also want
to run your test cases with edge or
internet explorer or the firefox browser
same way you need to download all the
drivers from this location
so from here like you have edge browser
here opera browser you have a mozilla
firefox browser so any of the browser
which you want to work with you have to
just download your driver from here
place it in this location and install it
using nbn command okay so since i will
not be executing this command again
because i've already installed it so
once your drivers are installed what's
the next step we are ready to execute
our test cases okay so these are all the
installation steps which are required to
get your command line runner which is
called as selenium side runner ready for
you to execute your test from the
command line all right okay now let's go
ahead and see how do we execute the test
cases so let's go back to our previous
example in this video where we wrote
some of the test cases for testing our
control flows okay so these are all the
test cases now if you observe here i
have not created any test suite here we
just had a default suite which was
created when we created the project and
we just went ahead and created all the
tests here for the side runner to run we
need to have a test suite so if i just
try to run the test with let's try to
run this what is the name of this
project control flows so i will show you
what happens if there is no test suite
defined for this so let me clear the
screen and uh which is a project here
this one okay so what i will do is let
me simply go ahead and execute this
project so to execute any test this is
the command which you use you simply
call selenium side runner and the
project name okay and also once you have
installed the selenium side runner you
can also check the version of it so
let's execute this selenium
side runner and the project name project
name is this
done so now if i press enter now see
what happens
okay it's saying running the default
suite
can you see here
it looks for a test suite to start its
execution okay so it picked up the
default suite which is here
okay since it was created when we
created this new project fine however
it's a test suite failed to run why
because your test suite must contain at
least one test and all our tests are
residing outside the test suite we have
none in the default test way correct so
what we will do let's go ahead and
create this test suite instead of
default what i will do is i'll say first
rename this so let's give it a proper
name so we'll say control flow test test
suite okay done so i've renamed it now
let's go ahead and add all those test
cases which we have created to this so
i'll just simply say add test and select
all these tests so we have around four
tests here so i'll just select all them
done so i'll save this project
i'll go to my folder id tests and the
same file name i'll just say replace now
we have a test suite called control flow
test now let's go ahead and run that
again now let's see what happens
okay so there are multiple test cases
here so let's see all these test cases
will be run one after the other
sequential so we have that calorie
counter test case and then we have the
loop test cases all right so it is done
so now let's understand the flow of this
test case okay so this is where we
started running our test suite so it
finished first test case it finished the
second test case it finished the third
test case and then the fourth test case
so all the four test cases it has
completed and it says all the four
passed total four and it also shows you
the total time taken for the complete
test suite to run and for every test
case what is the amount of time required
to execute that so this is all the
information which is available here if
at all there is a failure in any of the
test case that would get reflected here
it would say for past one phase and
total four executed okay so this is the
kind of report what you will get to see
good so far okay so let's go back to our
notes and see whether we have done
everything so the other way of running
is say you have multiple browser drivers
installed and you want to run this on a
particular browser so during that time
what you can do is you can use this
command you can say selenium side runner
minus c minus c is nothing but setting
the capabilities capabilities for what
for the browser and then you give a
browser name here so you can say chrome
or you can say firefox whatever the
browser of your choice and then give
your project name so with this what
happens is if your browser is installed
now we have to install the browser using
this command correct so if your browser
is installed it will execute this
particular test suite on the browser
which you have mentioned here right and
that is how you use the selenium side
runner to run your test cases on
multiple process now simply what you can
do is you can create a shell script or a
batch script you can add this line into
a bad script for the multiple browsers
and you can execute this so that way all
your test cases would execute it on all
the process so that that way you can
achieve your cross browser testing so
other thing if you remember i also said
that command line runner like if you go
back to our presentation it says we can
run it for parallel testing now let's
see how do we achieve this parallel
testing now to achieve this parallel
testing there are certain steps which
you need to do in the id so let's go
back to our test suite so we have this
test suite so if you go here and go to
the settings can you see this run in
parallel so you need to check this check
box to run all these test cases in
parallel so right now what happened when
we executed it all the test cases ran
sequentially one after the other correct
so for every test case there was a
chrome browser launched and the chrome
browser was closed before the next test
was launched now let's try to do this i
am going to check this check box where
it says run in parallel and i will say
submit i'll save this project again now
same thing i'll overwrite this project
save done replace now let's go to our
terminal window and run this test cases
again for that what i will do i'll call
the same command again however now
please observe the number of chrome
browser windows it's going to open okay
i'll show you that so it has started
running the test suite okay can you see
this three chrome browser windows open
at the same time okay and one by one
they're going to get closed out okay so
there was also the fourth one open but
since the test case was so small that it
was too quick for us to see here now
look at the complete execution here so
what it has done is it opened all the
browsers in parallel okay and it ran all
the test cases parallely
you will see a big difference and since
these are very small testers you might
not be able to see a big difference in
the execution time however if you have
got a bigger or bigger test cases which
you are running you will see a
remarkable difference in the time taken
by the suite to run the test cases still
here you can see ok its almost 11
seconds it took whereas in the previous
example it took 13 seconds as i said the
difference is very small because our
test cases are very very minor test
cases right if you have a bigger test
cases where it launches the browser
launches your application under test and
you are doing multiple operations you
will be able to see a remarkable
difference when you run the test
sequentially and when you run it
parallel so this is how you work with
the ide and this is how you achieve the
parallel execution okay so that
completes our selenium side runner now
let's look at some of the limitations of
the selenium id the first limitation is
you cannot export your id scripts to web
driver scripts the support is yet to be
added right so earlier in this video i
showed you there are ways to export the
scripts to junit and python however the
previous ide did have this capability of
exporting your scripts to web driver
scripts and that support is yet to be
added to the new id data driven testing
like using excel files or reading data
from the csv files and passing it to
your scripts so this capability is not
yet available in the id so you cannot do
data driven testing database testing is
also not possible so you cannot actually
connect your database read the test data
from your database or even you cannot
perform any kind of database testing
reporting facility so it does not have a
good reporting we saw when we use the
command line runner or through the ide
when we run the test there is a very
minimal reporting capabilities what we
could see so it does not really have ah
capabilities of reporting like your test
ng or the report engine what exactly is
the selenium web driver and how we can
go ahead with that
so coming back to the selenium web
driver so here a selenium web driver is
one of the most important component of
the selenium test suit
when we talk about the selenium uh tools
suit over here like uh we talk about
okay i want to create a whole together
regression test suit so selenium
webdriver is very important component
for that
and when we talk about the selenium
webdriver it allows the cross browser
compatibility which means like you want
to test your applications you can have a
test suit there one for the chrome
browser one for the firefox one for the
internet explorer you can then say like
okay i want to test and validate my
application across all these three
browsers and in future if safari browser
comes in all you have to do is like you
have to just run the same script with
the web driver of the safari so this web
driver is not only static for one
browser it's actually
approachable for across multiple
browsers there so that enhances the
compatibility there that yes this set
test suit even if you're writing the
test suits in case of selenium it's not
limited to one browser so it's kind of a
cross browser here
so these are small small benefits
although we are talking about the
selenium webdriver here but if you
closely see these all points are
actually defining why exactly the
selenium is best uh when we talk about
the weber automations or the web testing
automation here
right
and then it's actually supporting
various programming languages like uh
programming languages yes it's there
it's even uh supporting with different
browsers and then of course it's
supporting different operating systems
also
because
you can pretty much run these test cases
uh onto linux macs or windows whatever
the platform you feel like you want to
use you can pretty much use it so you
don't have to worry about like where
exactly this web driver is getting
deployed and from where you are trying
to refer it so that kind of
compatibility is also something which is
available here so you don't have to
think about the uh specific different uh
versions or the different operating
systems as such over here and then let's
talk about
further on this one so it also provides
the compatibility across different
programming languages so you can see
like what are the different benefits you
got you got benefits like uh you know
it's it's supporting different
programming languages it's supporting
different browsers and ultimately at
last it's supporting the different uh
particular uh operating systems or the
platforms here so these are small small
things like different uh benefits which
we get with the help of selenium here
and uh it's it's having the support
across different programming languages
so uh it doesn't matter that if you're
working with java or if you're working
with net this is going to work for
across a different different platforms
like different uh
environments you can actually deploy so
these benefits are something which can
definitely help you to see like how the
overall uh benefits can be achieved over
here
and uh
definitely the chrome browsers are the
safari
the firefox the oprah different uh
platforms you will be able to see like
how the execution needs to be done and
how the setup used to be performed here
so that's where the complete uh
implementations uh needs to be performed
here right and
these web driver provides a faster
execution of the test scripts uh because
that's the kind of automation which we
are looking forward that we are not
trying to see like how the systems can
be implemented so when we are trying to
talk about the automation here so these
web drivers basically help us to go for
the faster execution also so it's not
only about uh that we are trying to see
the setup like we are trying to go for
the configurations here it's also like
uh the performance and the efficiency
which we're getting with this one is
quite beneficial so you can get an easy
and a faster execution of the test cases
so it's it's having a lot of benefits if
we talk about in these features only
itself you can see like there are a lot
of benefits which we got over here so
it's fast it's efficient and on top of
that it's
not depending on any kind of environment
it's quite generic like you know it's
it's something which you can use for
windows you can use it for linux you
want to use it for dotnet you want to
use it for java it's kind of uh
chandrick for a lot of technologies
platforms and programming languages
right now why exactly we require the
selenium web driver like what is the
purpose of using this one so let's
explore on that part here so selenium
fib driver provides a user-friendly
interface that could uh you know it can
be easily understood by a particular
person like when we uh when you're using
this uh selenium web driver so this is
something which you can easily
understood like it's pretty easy for you
to understand that and it's not that
much complex for you to understand that
okay you are going to take a lot of time
to
consume you're going to take a lot of
time to
uh you know understand that so that's
not a kind of interface which we are
getting when we talk of the
selenium web driver here
right and uh the web driver is something
which is having much more uh features as
compared to the
uh selenium rc and selenium ide there so
when we talk about the
selenium web driver so this is something
which is having uh much more features as
compared to the other components like
you know these the other components is
also about the selenium only but yes the
when we talk about
selenium web drivers so it's having
much more features as compared to the
selenium rc and the selenium ide here
so you don't have to worry about the
features like all together selenium uh
prep driver is something which is quite
efficient and better as compared to the
other components so that's another
benefit which we get with the selenium
here
so selenium uh
we have got some other components like a
selenium remote control here so uh rc is
something which enables the uh the
creation of
uh you know automated web applications
like uh in in case of programming
languages such as java c sharp uh
node.js different different programming
languages are there so we can pretty
much uh use the remote control uh
selenium remote control over here which
will enable the uh the creation of the
automated web applications there so
that's the purpose of using the
selenium remote control here it's uh
it's not something which is being used
nowadays because most of the
functionalities have nowadays moved on
to the uh
selenium driver here so that's some
migration which has happened over there
and that's the reason why we are not
going to use much of the
selenium remote control over here so
that's not being used as such as
compared to the other components but yes
the selenium webdriver is something
which is quite popular and because of
its features and the efficiency we are
going to use uh the particular uh
browse the uh web driver as compared to
the any other component as such here
right now selenium ide
needs not additional any kind of setup
is required like uh you know apart from
installation of the browser because uh
in that case everything will be
integrated in that like because we are
using we are integrating the complete uh
selenium ide over here so all you need
to do is like you need to do the
installation of chrome browser that's
also because you want to go for the uh
specific
chrome driver which you require for the
execution of the test cases so for that
only you are basically trying to install
the chrome browser but other than that
there is no other component which you
actually require when we talk about the
selenium ide here
so uh the ide makes the life easy
because it helps us to go ahead with the
debugging mode here like a kind of a
debugging environment you will be able
to do that so even if there is any kind
of issue any any kind of problem which
comes up so it will be very easy for you
to debug those things and go ahead with
that part so uh tracking the exceptions
managing the exception so all those
things can be easily handled with the
help of the
selenium ide here so selenium ide is
something which is kind of a bigger
package which is uh further comprising
of different different components like
it's something which is giving us a
variety of things here
right now how exactly the uh selenium
whip driver is at all different from the
selenium rc and ide because those are
also the solution which is available
there from this lane now unlike the
selenium ide selenium webdriver can
actually work with different browsers so
that's something which we have already
focused on that it's having the
compatibility across multiple
browsers there that's the first benefit
which we get over here in this one now
also the web drivers is something which
does not require any user to start the
server or anything like that there so
just in case of a selenium rc you have
to start some server because you're
ultimately connecting to that server and
that's how the communication is
happening but that kind of stuff is not
there in the uh selenium web driver here
also this linear web driver is an api
and it's not a gui based plugin so it's
it's something which can easily handle
like
uh it's having the uh
quite efficient uh connectivity or you
can say like the uh integration is also
good there because we most of the
applications nowadays are working on the
api format which is pretty generic so we
there is no gui based interface which we
have to explore which we need to
integrate here so it's all like the api
is called which we need to do in order
to use uh make use of the selenium web
driver here
now in selenium webdriver the apis are
entirely object oriented in nature as
compared to the selenium rc and selenium
id so which is not a kind of object
oriented in nature but selenium
webdriver is something which is quite
object oriented here also uh web driver
the selenium web driver is actually
supports multiple
listeners right so uh which is available
there as compared to selenium rc and
selenium id here so these are some
couple of features which is available
there also it also supports the testing
of the ios and android which is not
being supported in the rc and ide there
because most of the applications
nowadays also have the counterpart uh
android or the ios applications so if
you don't have the interface or
integration with those platforms then
it's a incomplete way of testing here so
not only the web applications but even
the mobile applications also now getting
integrated with the help of the selenium
web driver here so these kind of
features which is not exactly available
in the rc or the id over here but
definitely it's it's going to be
available there in case of selenium web
driver so what exactly is the overall
need of the web driver like the selenium
web driver here so uh let's talk about
that that uh how exactly we can use it
for the software automation here so
there are a couple of benefits which is
available there so let's focus on that
one by one the very first one is the
open source now it's something which is
available or which is uh available as an
open source over here which means like
uh it's something which you can use
without any license without any cost uh
just like that you can go to the
selenium dot dev website and you can
start downloading the
selenium related uh uh details or
selenium related components
second is multilingual support it's
having the support for different kind of
programming languages not only for the
java based applications it's actually
supporting like different different
programming languages so you just have
to learn one single tool and then can
survives or that can support multiple
programming languages here several
operating system support yes it's not
only related to the windows or linux
platform here so it's actually supported
across
windows linux macos different operating
systems are actually supported here so
different support operating systems is
supported by this uh particular selenium
here uh multiple frameworks are there so
that's a multiple framework support
which is available in this one uh user
friendly it's quite user friendly there
and the developers were more comfortable
with the java programming languages so
they get uh quite uh comfortable and
integrated with the uh selenium because
it's also using the same java syntax
over here in this one
um it's cross device testing uh
definitely both mobile desktops are
different platforms different operating
systems mac os uh ios android different
uh platforms are actually supported by
this uh particular selenium here so
selenium webdriver is something which is
having like cross device testing here
community support is there it's kind of
open source yes but uh it's having a
very good community like a lot of people
are actually there
who can contribute to this selenium you
can get the information from there and
it's kind of a huge efforts like a kind
of a huge community efforts which you
can see over here in this case
also a compatibility testing so it's
having a very good compatibility here so
when you're working with this uh
selenium so it's compatible with pretty
much any programming languages any
platform any operating system so that
kind of
benefits you get with the help of this
selenium web driver here
and uh
unlike uh selenium rc you don't have to
start any kind of server component here
uh which you need to connect so it's
like uh on demand like when you're
running the scripts a kind of a local
chrome browser will be uh initialized
and your test cases will be executed and
uh performed and that that's how the
whole executions will be performed there
so there is no inward like you have to
go somewhere start some server start
somewhere remote server there and then
the communication or the execution of
the test cases will be initialized so
it's not like that kind of communication
here
right so let's talk about the uh web
driver
architecture here now in this one there
are some different uh components which
is available there in this architecture
components the very first one is the
selenium language bindings here now
these are actually available in
different different programming
languages like java ruby python c-sharp
javascript these are the different
programming languages bindings which is
available there then with the help of
json wire protocol these are going to be
connected to the different drivers now
browser drivers is the one where exactly
the request will be sent out so this
selenium web driver is actually going to
connect or send the request to these
drivers
so um depending on the platform also and
depending on the different
systems you can actually go for the
browser drivers here so you want to go
for chrome driver you want to go for
firefox you want to go for opera you
want to go for safari
these are the different browsers which
is available there earlier the uh
internet explorer was also there but now
in the latest version see it uh h
browser or h driver is something which
is available there
and uh these are going to be connected
to the actual uh particular browsers
like the chrome firefox and all so
it will be sending the request over the
http uh http uh that request will be
sent out to the real drivers so the
browser drivers and then the real
drivers will be there so the driver is
going to initialize the chrome browser
and then the whole request will be
processed the
websites will be open the clicking the
access everything will be done after
that on that case so these are the
different uh
steps which is involved when we are
basically going for uh from one step to
another like where the communications or
will be performed over here in this case
right so uh again uh it's not dependent
on any programming languages it's not
dependent on any kind of
browser or any kind of components here
so
right from the uh language bindings it
will go to the json wire protocol from
there it will be sent out to the browser
drivers various browser drivers whatever
the browser drivers you want to use you
can use that and then those drivers are
actually going to connect with the real
drivers or with the real browsers over
here so that the communications or the
exact end result you should be able to
see
so
for instance if you run a particular
chrome browser uh chrome driver there so
you will be able to see like a chrome
browser getting initialized and the
website is getting accessible so all
that activity will be happened or will
be performed over there so these are the
parts of the sequence these are kind of
architecture components like one to
another these will be processed or these
will be executed here right
so uh these programming language these
selenium programming languages again
it's actually a kind of a generic one so
these are the client libraries which is
available there depending on this one
for example for java i can download some
binaries uh i can download some jar
files so that will be referenced or
utilized into my source code for ruby
it's maybe like different uh third-party
libraries or shared libraries which will
be available there for python it will be
available in the form of modules uh c
sharp javascript so each and every
programming languages
is actually having its own uh libraries
now these libraries are actually
required so that we can get the whole
interface of the selenium it's okay like
i am writing some test cases i'm writing
the complete test suite and i'm using it
but unless and until i import my
selenium libraries it will not work for
me i will not be able to work on that
part because i will not be able to get
those features as such in order to get
those features i need to download these
bindings or these kind of
language bindings there corresponding to
my programming language and these are
easily available on the selenium website
so if you go to the selenium website
whatever the programming languages you
want to follow you can download these
findings these windings will be nothing
but the archives where you will be
having some kind of executables
depending on that programming language
right now from there uh we will be using
our libraries like these bindings in
order to interact in order to initialize
the selenium so then we will be going to
the json wire protocol so it's kind of a
connector between the libraries and the
web drivers
now uh programically uh using these with
the help of these uh client libraries
we're going to send the request to the
web drivers it also helps to enable the
transfer of data between a server and
client
because of course you have to
get your end result process right so
that's where you need to go for the
execution so what you're going to do is
like you're going to see like okay i'm
going to run or i'm going to execute
this
json wire protocol over here and it's
going to connect between my client
libraries and the web drivers here so
that's the communications and the
connectivity which we want to establish
or we want to provide here now these are
selenium browser drivers are actually uh
specific browsers now because um the
json wire is going to connect uh to the
specific
browsers uh the drivers here so that the
communication can be happen
now uh these drivers are actually used
uh as in drivers in order to interact
with the exact browser because these are
not the exact browser now if you want to
interact with the chrome then you
definitely have to use the chrome driver
if you want to use for the fireworks
then you have to use the firefox driver
so depending on the programming language
you have to define like which driver you
really need to process or you need to
really go ahead with that part so that's
where the selenium browser drivers
really comes into the picture and then
uh the exact browsers will be there now
once the
executions will be done at last you will
be able to see like all these browsers
getting open if you're going to use the
chrome browser then chrome browser will
be initialized if you're using the
firefox then the firefox browser will be
initialized so whatever the browser or
driver specific driver you will utilize
so according to that you will see a
particular browser being invoked over
here
so that's how the communication happens
and it's kind of a sequence here like
step by step here
so each and every stage is very
important because that's how the uh
communication will happen over here
and you will get the end result or the
desired output if you uh have any kind
of uh failing component over here so
that's where the whole uh connectivity
will be breakdown and you will not be
able to get any kind of values x
expected so this is something which we
really need to consider or we need to go
ahead with that part here
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so what are the different drawbacks
which we got with the help of the
selenium web driver here so when we talk
about the selenium web drivers so what
are the different drawbacks which we are
getting over here so that we can
understand like how exactly we can talk
about that part here
now the drawbacks of a selenium
webdriver is something which we uh you
know use because
this is kind of uh uh main component you
can say like you know using which you
can actually do the complete validation
but the problem is that it's not
something which you can use for the
desktop application so for the desktop
application this does not works so this
web driver is something which is uh
supported for the web applications only
it's not something which we can use for
the desktop applications as such so
that's a kind of a limitation which we
get with the help of the selenium web
driver here so it's only there for the
websites for the web portals
secondly
the it requires the exceptions of the
teams uh you know in order to manage
these scripts because these are the
programming languages of course there
although it's a test suit but uh it
requires a programming language efforts
as such in order to go ahead with that
in order to manage these things
so it requires a kind of expert team
who can actually handle these scripts or
we can work on these requirements
so uh that's a kind of overheat because
if it's not like very easy to manage
these like uh pretty much a person who
is an expert in these things can only
handle these kind of requirements so
it's kind of a limitation where we will
be only depending on an expert to manage
these scripts as such right
now um
it's not having any kind of uh
uh reporting build reporting capability
over here so it's not available in this
one so test reports which is getting
generated here is uh with the help of
the junit and test ng so there is no
default reporting mechanism which is
available over here in this one so we
only have the mechanism of the junit
like we can extend our test scripts in
selenium by integrating with jh unit and
the test ng here
so that we will be able to get a proper
reporting so for the uh reporting
purposes we actually use the components
like this junit and the test ng over
here to go ahead with that
so these are the ways in which we can
actually go for the integration where we
can integrate the selenium and the other
frameworks like junit and the uh test ng
kind of components here
and that's the whole basis because
alone the selenium webdriver is
something which can execute the scripts
process the request but it's not going
to handle any kind of
reporting mechanism so reporting
mechanism is something which you can
only get with the help of the junit or
the test
ng here because these are the additional
packages which you need to integrate so
it's it's a kind of a custom solution
which we need to design uh you know
where we don't have only the web driver
available over here like the core
components but also we have like other
components available over there which
will be of course having the other
components like distance g and the j
unit here so that's also something which
you can integrate all together with this
one right also uh it's very difficult to
manage there is a lot of management or
the maintenance activity which we get
over here
also it's very difficult to scale this
up also depending on the load or
depending on the requirement it's very
difficult to scale it up also if you are
using for some infrastructure some kind
of a load there so having it increased
to a different level is kind of a
difficult task here
also maintenance activity is quite huge
so if you want to have a proper
maintenance or management you have to
get a couple of uh
you know experts in that case so that
they can easily manage those things so
these are the different uh requirements
which is available there where we can
see like how exactly the uh we can you
know manage all these things
now it also uh you know allows the
across
browser uh compatibility testing here so
uh it's something which can easily
handle like different requests across
the browsers
so um image testing is not available so
uh you don't have to uh you know use the
selenium alone like selenium alone is
not compatible for testing the images
here so if you really want to test the
images so you have to
integrate securely in with your selenium
so that you can have a complete package
so again uh selenium in some cases it's
not sufficient for like most or a
variety of things there so in some cases
you have to actually
go for another tool integrations so that
you can have the complete details you
can have the complete component here
so that's where the uh real mechanism
comes in like yes
you don't have the
exact single tool available for taking
care of all these things but yes you can
have all these things integrated uh with
the other tools other components there
and from there you will be able to get a
complete uh values and the complete uh
implementation here
right so these are the uh you know
different uh drawbacks which we get once
we start using the a web driver here so
let's go ahead with the uh particular
demo over here to understand like how
exactly the selenium web driver can be
utilized can be used
so that we will be able to run some test
scripts here so we are going to run or
prepare a test suit here so that we can
get it executed with the help of
selenium so that's what we are trying to
do here so for this one we require some
couple of components to be there like
the jdk eclipse and all so let's talk
about that component so let's go ahead
with the implementation
so let's begin with the uh
configurations of this webdriver here
now the very first thing which we
require is that we require to the
installation of the
java here now let's uh go ahead with
this url so now this one is something
where we have to see like how uh we can
go for the installation of the jdk here
now here we need to go for the jdk
installation that's the version which we
want to install now it a variety of our
versions are available there like which
version you want to install you can go
with that uh jdk 11 8 it is the most
stable version so you can go ahead with
the jdk8 here so you can download here
different platforms it's available like
windows platform uh whatever the
platform is there all you need to do is
like you need to just download this exe
file now once the exe file is downloaded
so what happens like you will be able to
do the installation now i have done the
installation of this jdk here so if i
have to open my uh command prompt here i
would be easily able to see that i'm
using a jdk version of
1.8.0 over here in this one so that's
the version which i'm using but again of
course if you're using some different
version of cdk that will also work here
the only thing is that you need to see
that you need to go for a compatible
browser a compatible uh
java and the compatible eclipse tool
here so that's what you require now what
i'm going to do is like i'm going to
install or download the eclipse browser
also now let's download the eclipse here
now we got an official website of
eclipse here
from where we can download these eclipse
different platform you can do it like
this is the one which is available there
now you can click on download this one
so that will help you to download the
eclipse here so uh here the uh download
will work just like that you can do the
download here even if you want to go for
a different offerings like you want to
go for different platform
uh you feel like you want to decide that
which package actually you need to do
because uh in the eclipse also you got
like different things
um id eclipse ide for the java
developers for uh the c plus c plus plus
so different uh different uh operating
system and different uh packages are
also available there so it's basically
up to you like which exactly environment
you want to follow
so i want to download this uh 64 bit
over here in this one so let's download
this here
now uh let's again download this this is
kind of an exe file which is available
here so let's download it again
now um
it will be working on like uh it's kind
of a download which is getting started
over here so it's close to 102 mb which
is available there this is the
executable which is going to help us to
do the installation of eclipse now this
is the uh latest version our 2020
version is what it is getting installed
over here
and uh it's completely there i have
already got the jdk installed because of
the fact that using this jdk the eclipse
will be open
if you don't have the jdk installed the
java runtime then the eclipse will not
be installed for you so
uh in order to get the eclipse uh
installed and executable perfectly fine
you need uh the jdk installed to be done
here so we got like one more minute here
to complete the download and this is
just 102 mb package or installer which
is available there and once this is
installed we will be able to get ahead
with this installation of the eclipse
here so once the eclipse is installed
all you can do is like you can go ahead
with the
particular configurations you can create
some couple of cro uh projects in case
of eclipse um then we'll also see like
how we can download the
uh programming languages binding so that
also we are going to download so these
are the different components which
you're going to explore while working on
this one so uh let's wait for this uh
download of this executable to be
performed here so that we will be able
to proceed further with this one so
let's wait for that
so it's hardly taking one minute more to
complete it
so selenium and eclipse both are the
open source one you're getting a donate
to a class community page there because
that's a donation which they want but
again you can use it like 100 open
source and free of cost here so you
don't have to pay any cost as such over
here in this case so there is no cost
associated with this one so just 10
seconds more and uh then we can pursue
with the installation of the eclipse
here and here we go so the installer is
almost done here so i can pretty much go
ahead and open the file so this will
help me to do the installation of the
eclipse here so the eclipse installer is
what it's getting started initialized
over here in this one uh now the java
runtime is already available with me we
require the uh specific uh jtx installed
the java command line is working we can
download the eclipse here
and uh
then we can go for the uh specific
executions like we can go and uh
download the uh browser drivers here now
the thing is that if you really want to
go for the chrome browser or firefox or
any kind of those things in case of your
particular system in case of your
windows machine over here uh you don't
have to necessarily go for any kind of
uh a kind of a driver as such here
because of the fact we got a links over
here like uh this mozzarella for the
firefox uh this one is there for the uh
particular selenium this one is there
for the chrome now chrome is something
which we have already got here like we
have already got the chrome browser
installed
but let's see like uh we can download
this driver also like uh depending on
that we can go ahead with that part and
then we can also download the java
client uh libraries over there from the
bindings over there from the uh specific
selenium.dev website over there and we
can download and we can integrate it so
let's do it one by one so first of all
let's see like you know once the
installation of the eclipse is done and
then we'll be able to go ahead with the
third component or the third request
which is the a web driver or a
particular chrome browser a driver over
here so this installer is going to give
us the same thing here so i'm going for
the
uh specific java developer here so let's
go for the uh installation here now this
is going to uh install uh the
java 8 right this runtime over here so
uh if you feel like you want to use the
jdk 11 because that's something which is
available there now if you're using an
existing ones like uh you're already
using uh an existing once over here the
jdk and all so uh that's where the
installation is going on like uh it's
it's going in with that part here but
we already got some system related uh
jdks which is installed but you feel
like you want to go ahead with this one
um like you're not doing the separate
installation of the jdk or jre so there
you can actually use this once here so
let's select this one like i pretty much
want to use like any one of these uh
jvms over here like which i feel like i
can configure or i can utilize so that's
pretty much we can do here
so it's like uh we can use these
variables like we can go for these jvms
or if you feel like you can go for an
external jvm also there so it all
depends on you like how the uh
installation you want to perform here
right and this is the location let's uh
go for the desktop location there
and or you can go for the default
location also over here in this one
so let's go for the installation now
just accept it and uh the installation
will be proceeded over here so uh even
if you have not done a separate jtag
installation so this will basically have
a jdk installed i have selected the java
11 over here uh but you can go for the
15 also in this case in this scenario so
the whole installation of the eclipse is
what it's happening over here
so once the eclipse is installed so then
we can pretty much go ahead with the
next component there which is like uh
dealing with the uh specific selenium
related components and chrome browser
again it's already something which is
installed there but we'll see like how
we can download the chrome driver how we
can configure and we can utilize that so
that's what we're going to follow here
so it's going for the installation and
uh it's something which we are trying to
do like uh it's
this installer is pretty much
downloading some couple of components as
such uh like this j uh
jre is something which is getting
installed or downloaded from the
eclipse website and uh that's where the
uh you know all the components is
getting installed so one by one all the
components will be downloaded
from the eclipse website here and it's a
complete package which means like you
don't have to necessarily go for a
separate installation
there is another installer which is
available for eclipse where you just
have to unzip up for a zip file and you
can pretty much use it but in this case
this is something which is having all
these things integrated all together
inside that so that's an another
component which is being available here
so the installation is still going on
there so uh it depends because all these
things are getting cached up from the
internet so it also depends on like how
much size of file is getting downloaded
here so let's uh you know let's uh wait
for the installations to be complete and
then we'll proceed further so now the
installation is done so we can launch
our eclipse here so that's what we are
trying to launch here now apart from
eclipse what happens like we require
some other components also like uh we
require this lithium web driver also
there so for that we have to download
the uh java related client bindings so
for that uh chrome browser first of all
it's already installed so we don't have
to do any kind of installation there uh
yes i can go ahead with the exe file
like of the chrome browser driver that
i'm going to use it so i'm going to open
the uh specific downloads here now in
this segment what happens like
selenium.dev is the website which is
available there now here we can go for
the downloads now related to your
programming language whatever the
programming language you are trying to
use so you can download the language
binding for that now language binding is
something which is utilized so using
which you will be able to see like how
uh you can establish the connectivity
it's just a kind of a libraries where
you can do the connectivity and you can
see that execution so what i'm going to
do is like i'm going to download this
bindings here so let's download this one
now it's again available as in zip file
which is available there so uh depending
on the version you can go for the beta
download version also and i'm going for
the stable version which we want to
utilize we want to refer it so it's
going to download zip file so this zip
file will have all the jar files and all
the required libraries there
and when i'm going to create a project
into my eclipse at that moment of time i
would be requiring all these components
like all these
various uh libraries i should be added
up into my uh project as such in case of
the eclipse so that's what i need to do
here so let's go to the eclipse here
so here we're going to expand this like
a package
explorer and here are going to go to
file
new and java project so i'm going to
create a java project over here so um
in which we will be getting some couple
of class files in which we will be
having the
selenium related test cases like how we
want to process or how we want to
execute that part so i'm going to
proceed with that part so
let's put the uh project name here so
i'm going to say like selenium
just a project name i want to put
then the jdk now uh if you want to go
for a specific jdk like another version
so you can go with that but right now
i'm using like jdk 1.8 which is pretty
much configured so i can use that
uh you feel like you want to use the
specific jre of
gre which is available as part of jdk
1.8 that also you can use or if you want
to use like a jdk so that also something
which you can utilize over here in this
one so there are different things like
you can configure the gres also so if
you have some custom path which uh where
you have the java available or the jdk
or jre is available there so that also
you can easily refer it so you can
simply say that yes uh this so and so
location i want to refer i want to see
my source code so that's where you can
do the you can go for the execution now
once you're providing these values like
the install gres which you want to
provide which you want to process here
next thing what you need to perform is
like you need to go ahead with that
execution so i'm completely okay with
the jdk whatever the environment i want
to process i can easily do that and i'm
completely okay with that
right so let's go with that part and
then click on next and uh this is the
source directory which is available
there right and if you want to add any
additional libraries so uh here exactly
you can add your a uh selenium related
libraries using which you will be able
to see your source code working fine but
i'm not going to do that activity here
so i'm going to do that later on so that
we can get a complete things in a
sequence
and then here we go like finish so you
will be able to get
the gi related libraries and the source
folder here so right now it's completely
empty project there is nothing available
as such here and what i'm going to do is
like i'm going to create a class file
over here to see with the specific
source code of the selenium to how the
web driver is getting loaded up and
processed so that's stuff we are going
to talk about here so let's see like
what content we need to really put up
over here in this one now if we
downloaded this uh selenium
programming language bindings here so
let me extract it
you can pretty much keep it into the
eclipse folders also or if you wish you
can keep it aside in some specific
folder because it's just going to be
referenced with every project so it's
just kind of a shared release which is
available there so whatever project you
want to onboard you want to use so this
kind of a
package or this kind of uh share library
you can easily utilize and you can
implement it so we're just trying to
extract it now once extraction is done
so you will be able to see like some
couple of files and folders
uh now this is having a particular uh
two executable files like client and
combined this is kind of connecting uh
acting like a selenium client and which
is using to connect and
process all the requirements
and we also have a sources file which is
available there for this one but again
uh it's something which depends on the
requirement so you don't have to put the
sources uh jar file also over here
because that's not required so you can
pretty much uh use this executable jar
file because in this one you will not
have any kind of source then of course
uh your selenium related jar file is
further on depending on some
dependencies like this so these jar
files are also uh something which you
should be putting up into your uh
specific
uh shared library so that your
selenium-related jar files should not
started failing so i will try that
scenario also so that we can get the
complete output and complete in science
here so let's see now uh we'll go to
this uh we'll import this particular
file over there and uh for that we have
to write a class file so let's see like
how we can do that so we have already
got the selenium web driver so
uh the eclipse is what we have followed
so we have created a new uh java project
now we want to create a new class file
the build path configurations we will be
taking care of that later on but right
now we are going to see like how we can
proceed further with that so i i'm going
for this uh specific component here
right so uh whatever the browser or
whatever the driver you want to follow
you can do that so firefox if you want
to use you want to use our chrome
browser it all depends on you like it
all depends on the way that how you want
to configure it so uh let's see let's uh
import this uh particular component here
now if the uh specific uh firefox
browser is installed that's great if
it's not installed so you can just go
back here so here you will be able to
see like this browsers like these
specific components which is available
here
so this is the driver which is available
so for the windows 64-bit you can again
download this one here
so whatever the platform you want uh
like if you want to use for the chrome
browser you can go for that if you want
to go for the firefox edge whatever the
driver you feel like you want to go you
can do go with that part here
so let's uh open this one here and
extract this one also so that we should
be able to refer it over here into our
specific source code so this is the
driver this is the exe file which is
available there now all we need to do is
like we need to just open our eclipse
there so uh in our eclipse uh we should
be using or we should be referring to
this one here so this is a kind of a
path which is available similarly we
will also be giving a path over there so
that uh we can refer to that specific uh
driver that driver over here so let me
open that and uh let's see
so i'm going to create a class file here
you can create a package uh called
calm
and uh in that package you can further
on create a class file
like
selenium test
uh
it's also uh depends like this is just a
custom name so
uh you feel like you want to give some
different name you can uh
go for
uh you know any kind of class name over
here but this is something which is
uh something we are going to see like
how the execution needs to be performed
and needs to be done here
so there are different uh you know names
like uh you want to follow some
different name you can do that also
now if you see closely here let me save
the file here now in this one you are
getting some errors uh related to this
one like you're getting the uh error
codes related to the imports here like
how the uh specific execution should be
done here right now the thing is that uh
this is something which is uh really
causing the problems uh like how the
import or the execution should be done
right
also uh the thing is that uh we require
these imports to be available there
right so uh that's definitely we are
requiring over here and uh that's that's
something which we uh
require uh we want to process as such
also so right now let's uh have an uh
particular declaration of the uh package
also there because it's something which
is there in the comp package so let's
have the package calm also here so it's
there in the com package
uh but again those errors are not
related to that so these are like
related to the configurations which we
are trying to put
and uh during the copy paste there might
be a conversion of the code so that i
have taken care great
so uh let's see now what i have to
really do is like we have to see like
how we can proceed further
on the uh for the most executions and we
need to get this driver like we need to
get this one so i'll right click on my
project here and go to the build path
and click on configure build path
so first i'm going to uh add my binding
jar file there the java binding the jar
file which i downloaded just now this
client combined one here so only this
jar file we are trying to add up over
here
and with that
most of the uh related errors related to
that uh imports will be resolved now i'm
not sure that how it's going to work how
it's going to uh you know function
whether it's going to success or failure
that's a different story but yes all you
have done is like i right clicked on my
project went to the build path went to
the configure build path here and went
for the add external charge so these are
the external jars which you have to do
we have to put up over here
so only the combined client combined jar
file is what i have put up over here in
this one
in the reference libraries you will
immediately be able to know that part of
the jar file here
now this is the directory where you will
be having the exe file available for
that driver for the firefox so let's get
the path for our component also so we
got the path so let me paste it over
here
and here we go so we got the path here
this is the folder where we got our
driver available here and let's try to
resolve it let's try to run it over here
great
so now i'm going to right click here
just say run as and java application
now in this one i got an error saying
that some com google common collect
immutable map some class file is not
available there this is of the fact that
i did not imported those dependent jar
files also which we got downloaded from
the
java binding file here so that zip file
was also having some of the jar files
there in the library folders so in this
one also you will be able to see like
some executions of the jar files is
required over here as an inputs as a
standard imports
so let's import this one and this is the
reason why we got the error at the first
place because we are not importing those
ones those jar files which is being
required by our client combined jar file
also so these are the dependent jar
files which we are trying to import here
so ultimately at last you will be able
to have your referenced libraries
available here with all these jar files
component available here
right now since our driver is configured
everything is configured now the next
thing which we require is the browser
now i have the chrome browser but
unfortunately i don't have the firefox
browser so let's go ahead and download
the firefox browser so for that
let's open the browser so i'm going to
download a
firefox
browser over here into my system
so uh the official website is something
which is quite good so we can go for the
download firefox here now uh why because
i require now i'm using the firefox here
if i am using the chrome browser i will
not be having or facing any kind of
issues as such but since i'm using the
firefox uh driver so i require firefox
browser so uh the uh dependency of the
uh browser is there when we want to go
ahead because uh pretty much my uh core
base is going to connect or this
one is going to connect to the driver
here but driver ultimately internally or
require a browser show that it can
perform these occasions it can do that
execution so these drivers are going to
just uh communicate between the your
source code and the uh actual browser
here so after the driver you also
require the browser to be installed like
the chrome browser to be available here
so that you can pretty much use it and
you can perform the configuration so
let's see uh we are getting the browser
over here in this one and we got the
browser installed perfectly fine over
here so we should be able to see the
browser uh because in this one we are
basically trying to open the browser and
getting our website called
www.google.com here and then we are
having a particularly one and then
ultimately the driver is getting cured
here
so let's see so once the browser is
downloaded and installed so right click
on run as java application
so you will be able to see the browsing
here so okay it's connecting the uh
browser the firefox exe file is getting
executed a browser is getting executed
and it will be maximized automatically
you can see here like it's you know
getting maximized automatically here and
we just have to wait for a couple of
seconds more
and uh here we go we got the a browser
closed automatically also because there
was a slip of a couple of seconds over
here and you got the failure like you
got the complete uh component or it got
the driver closed there driver closed
means that definitely the browser will
also be closed here and you can see here
that the uh specific
output which is being performed or which
is getting executed over here it's
actually showing us like how the
executions and the uh setup needs to be
performed
or needs to be done here
so this is the way that how
the bra the implementations really
performed or really gets executed over
here in this case you got the browser
execution and everything will be work
perfectly fine
so again i'm right clicking over here
just click on run as java application
the same browser will be open again uh
it will be automatically refreshed you
will see that progress like this and
after a couple of seconds uh the thread
will be on sleeve but yes after that it
will be closed automatically over here
so like that you can program how to open
your website how to proceed further from
there you want to click on some buttons
you want to do some processing that's
all up to you like how you program how
you code it over here so this completely
helps you to see like how exactly you
can go ahead with the complete program
and this program will help you to uh
execute a good amount of testing
validations and running or executing
some couple of test cases so this is
what we have in this demo where we saw
like how we can configure the different
drivers the web driver the browser
driver and ultimately the browser and
the selenium web driver here so you're
using the selenium web driver over here
which is going to invoke the browser
driver and this browser driver is going
to invoke the browser as such over here
in this case
so that's it for this demo let's move on
to main content
so that was the demo in which we
executed a very simple program in order
to execute the selenium web driver which
is going to further invoke the uh
browser driver the firefox driver and
then it was invoking the uh specific
implementations there right so this is
what we did and if we summarize this
demo so in this one we downloaded uh the
selenium web driver we installed it we
configured it we integrated the eclipse
with the selenium web driver
and we also executed a specific test
script in order to see like how a
particular browser will be booked and
the previous cases yes the browser was
invoking a
www.google.com website there and we were
getting the response accordingly and
that was the executions mechanism like
that's the whole basis that how the
selenium test cases used to work and
used to be integrated over there so this
is the complete way that how exactly we
did this demo here
first of all you should have java 8 in
your system to run selenium three point
zero three plus i would say so you
should have java eight if you want to
run selenium three plus okay you can
verify whether you have java on uh
version eight plus or not by going to
command prompt and say java hyphen
version and then see if you have the
latest version of java or not if you
don't have download it from the link
provided right here and install that in
your system and configure it second
selenium 3.3.1 is mentioned right here
but now the latest version is 3.5.3
you can simply download the latest
version whatever you get from the
selenium website okay uh here it is
talking about test ng
so we'll be talking about test ng at the
later point when we will be talking
about unit testing framework so as of
now you don't need to download it no
need okay you don't need to download it
just set up selenium and java in your
system and make it ready because from
now onwards we'll be writing the script
of solarium now let's talk about the
project setup steps
so first create a new java project and
give a name
second
create a new source folder and provide
this uh situation
this source folder is automatically
created you don't need to worry about it
right click on test source folder create
a new package and provide a situational
name this is script
so here we will be going create a new
package we have already we already have
a package that is called as selenium
examples
so we will use it
right click on test source folder create
a new folder and name it as resources
right click on the project create a new
folder and limited slip so why they are
calling it as resources and why they are
calling it as lib let me tell you that
so they are asking us to create two new
folders in the project so like
saying new
folder
give it a name resources
in this resources we will be going to
keep all our drivers that is chrome
driver firefox driver all those drivers
it is also good it is also asking me to
create
print okay it is also asking me to
create one more folder
that is called as lib
okay
so in this lab we we'll be going to
store all our selenium libraries
okay
so earlier how we set up so there are
two ways to set up
one is you are going to the project
go to properties
java build path add external jars and
you select the libraries which you want
to add
okay
the second one is you go to lib
you don't go you just create a left
folder you go here copy the libraries
paste it here inside this after pasting
it doing the right click do the right
click and say say
here's that let's see
i completely not
here why i'm not getting that option you
can try it right now if you like
so download the live ids
create a new folder right in this in
your project by creating the folder
you will get here liv and you can
paste all your libraries right into this
folder
and then you can select your library
do the right click and then you will get
an option add to
build path
you can then add your libraries directly
to your build path so how it helps
it actually helps you to manage all your
libraries at one project
and
it will be configured in your project
how to add libraries into the lib folder
just copy the library
come here and paste it and done
so here if i go to left folder copy it
and paste it
and then it will be added or you can do
the right click
go to properties
copy this path the location where this
lib folder is present
you can copy it paste it here and here
you can paste your library this is also
an option
after that you select your libraries do
the right click and there you will get
an option add to build path
okay
and then the libraries will be added to
the build path
we will i would suggest you to try
yourself as well it will be there in
your in your
you eclipse
we won't face any issues like i am
placing
so that's what we do uh it is just that
uh we do create a library here so that
we can maintain all the libraries in one
folder in the same project instead of
you know go and explore like ladies or
search for the libraries
it's completely there is no difference
you can use any way you can use any
approach just that when you do the right
click in the project and go to
properties and uh do add external charts
then it is getting added from some
different location
but here you are creating a folder in
your own project
where you are working so you don't need
to go here and there to search for the
libraries
that's it yes it goes to the reference
libraries regi
uh after you add it to the build path
okay it is you know adding it to the
adding files to the left reference
library it is same
no difference
do the setup okay
today itself so here you can see they
have created a lib folder
on top of that they have created two
more folders that is one is source and
one is test source is what that we
actually get it there is no need to
create test folder if there is a level
comes if you know build tool even comes
then you will see automatically all
these architecture will be created it's
by default comes when you work on living
okay this is how they are saying that
your folder structure will look like
this
then they are asking us to add you know
libraries
so they are asking us to copy the
downloaded prelim jar into the left
folder like i have shown you
this one
they are asking us to add the drivers in
the resources folder so just add the
drivers in the resources folder
asking us to just add the testng library
just ignore for the time being will not
be going to do that
and here you can see that guys
okay great away i hope you must be
getting the build path option and add to
build path
by right clicking on the project
so there are two ways like i mentioned
one is you select all the libraries and
say build path add to build path or
another way is add to external jar files
so
you can choose any way
it's up to you if you don't have chrome
and ie then install those browsers as
well guys it's for you as well if you
don't have ie and chrome just download
them as well no surajit you don't
require any github account to get the
jaco driver you just
what you need to do is
go to
jacob driver version and here you have
windows
zip file click on it and it will
download the zip file for you and that's
it done you don't need to create any
kind of a you know any account and all
that if you have an older version of
firefox and install the latest version
so that we can work on latest version
and guys make sure that you have chrome
ien firefox because these are the main
browser people uses and we'll be working
on all these browsers as well so this is
how they are showing us that you know it
has been added so they have maintained
the resources in a package
but we are maintaining it in a separate
folder and it is always suggested
maintain your drivers in a folder you
can for the time being you can ignore
this the package okay so
let's create this architecture of course
i have the architecture correct so we
have already created that and but in
resources let's copy the jaco driver
chrome driver and i driver as well so
let's go to that uh selenium resources
so here i have stored all my library all
my you know exes and libraries etc so
here i need to add the jaco driver how
to download trekker whatever i'm
repeating it once again just take a look
here for the jaco driver click on this
version clicked on it you will get this
page go down you will get a zip file
here click on it and download it and
unzip it download it and unzip that
that's it second chrome driver click on
the latest version 2.31
let it open
you will you will get
chrome driver
click on the zip file it will get
downloaded and then unzip it and that's
it after that ie driver so for i driver
just move your cursor up move your
cursor up and here you can see there's a
different section completely internet
explorer driver server okay
so click on 64-bit windows
ie
when you click on it it will start
downloading the i driver server and done
so all the three drivers are downloaded
and now
you can unzip them
and after unzipping
you can add them to your resource folder
so jekyll driver copy this paste it in
resource folder go back let's see chrome
drivers this is my chrome driver
let me go inside copy this
again paste it here control v
going back internet explorer driver
server open this copy it paste it and
done all the three drivers has been
placed in the folder you don't need to
add them into the build path okay don't
add them into the build path so you just
need to add the libraries into the build
path not the resources okay okay all the
setup is done no more setup is required
now
in this session we will begin by
learning what expat is what is its
relevance and in the process of learning
about xpath we shall see its syntax and
different types of expat locators
we shall learn the types of xpath
different expat functions and lastly we
will see expat access
while we learn all of these we shall see
the syntax often along the side
but before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and click that bell icon so that you can
never miss an update from simply learn
okay so without further ado let's get
started with what is expert
xpath stands for xml path language it is
a selenium technique that is used to
navigate through the html structure of a
web page it is a syntax or language that
makes finding elements on a web page
possible using xml path expression
there are other locators in selenium
that search for elements using tags or
css class names and they are simple to
use but then they are not always
efficient and effective
there are times when you need to select
all dom elements of an html document
which is when xpath comes to your rescue
the xpath helps in dynamically searching
elements with a webpage giving
sufficient flexibility to the user it
has always been an essential part of an
automation script development to locate
a web element and it has always been a
challenging task to find the correct
useful and accurate locator in an
automation test development process
this is when xpath comes to the picture
and provides its various functions to
help write effective experts
in selenium automation there may be
times when elements can be hard to find
with general locators like id name class
etc and this is when xpath is used to
locate those elements on the web page
we can use xpath and selenium on both
xml and html documents
xpath in selenium has a basic format or
syntax here we can use a syntax that has
many keywords
these double slashes are used to select
nodes in the document from the current
node that match the selenium no matter
where they are
then tag name is used to give the tag
name as an input
this add rate symbol is used to select
the attribute
the keyword attribute indicates the
attribute name of the node and lastly
the value refers to the value of the
node next before we move on to the types
of xpath let's first see the types of
expat locators
as we know by now xpath is used to
locate web elements based on its xml
path here the term locator refers to an
address that identifies a web element
uniquely within the web page these
locators are html properties of a web
element which tells the name about the
web element it needs to act on
the first type of xpath locator is the
id
the best and the most popular method to
identify web elements is by using the id
and obviously each element's id is
unique the second type is the class name
in this case the class name of the
element is used to find the element the
third type is the link text here the
links text is used to find the element
all the hyperlinks on the web page can
be identified just by using the link
text
we can determine the link on the web
page with the help of an anchor tag the
anchor tag is used to create the
hyperlinks on a web page and the text
between the opening and closing anchor
tags constitute the link text then comes
the xpath locator that uses the name of
the element to find that particular
element the other type of xpath locator
is the xpath
this is required by the dynamic element
and to traverse between different
elements of the webpage the last type of
xpath locator is the css path it locates
the elements that have no class name
or id
now let's move further and learn about
the types of xpath
there are basically two types of x path
absolute x path and the second one is
relative x path if we talk about the
absolute x path then it refers to the
direct way of finding an element
the major drawback of an absolute x path
is that if there are any changes in the
elements path then the x path will fail
the x path begins with a single forward
slash
which states that
we can select the root node element
the syntax of the absolute x path looks
something like this you can determine
the absolute x path
of any windows file by right clicking on
the file and then clicking properties
in the file properties first look at the
location which is the path to the file
next add a backslash and then the file
name to the end of the path these
actions will give you the absolute
x-path of that file now next let's see
the relative expert
in the case of relative xpath the path
begins from the middle of the html dom
structure here the structure with a
double slash or double forward slash
that states that the element can be
searched anywhere on the web page
relative xpath enables you to write from
the middle of the html dom structure
without any need to write a long xpath
the syntax of the relative xpath looks
like this
a relative path needs to be combined
with another path to access a file
creating a link to an absolute path is
easy since you are pointing to the
file's internet url if you want to find
a specific files relative xpath certain
things must be kept in mind
the file must exist on the same server
as the html file the path to the file
must be relative to the directory of
html file
this is what sums up the two types of
xpaths for us the next topic in this
session is the xpath functions
now the question arises what does the
term xpath function mean there may be
times when locating a particular web
element using general attributes
xpath in selenium provides xpath
functions to write efficient expats to
discover elements uniquely there are
elements with similar properties like
the same name or the same class name
this is when the simple x path
strategies are not efficient and then we
need the xpath functions
there are three types of xpath functions
the first type is the xpath contains
the xpath contains in selenium is a
function within the xpath expression
used to search for the web elements
containing a particular text it can find
the element with partial text
it is used if the part of the value of
any attribute changes dynamically like
login information etc and here we can
see the syntax of xpath contains
function
the contains method accepts two
parameters the attribute of the tag must
validate to locate the web element the
value of an attribute is a partial value
that the attribute must contain
the second type of xpath function is the
xpath text the xpath text function is a
function used to locate the element on
the web page using the web elements text
it helps to find the exact text element
and it locates the elements within the
set of text nodes
the function proves it worth if the
element contains a text like a label or
etc
so here we can see the syntax of xpath
text on the screen
the text method here returned the text
of web element when identified by the
tag name and compared with the right
site's value now comes the last type of
xpath function that is the xpath starts
with function
the xpath starts with function is used
to find the element in which the
attribute values start with some
specific character or a sequence of
characters
the function plays a major role while
working with the dynamic web pages
we can also use this method to find
element's worst attribute value is
static that is not changing the syntax
for the starts with function can be seen
on the screen
this starts with accepts two parameters
the attribute of the tag must validate
to locate the web element and the
attribute value is the partial value of
the attribute with which the attribute
is expected to start after the xpath
functions let's move on to our next and
final topic that is the xpath access
all the xml dom elements are in a
hierarchical structure and can be either
located using absolute path or relative
paths
for this xpath provides a specific
attribute called xpath access
xpath access and selenium are methods
used to identify those dynamic elements
that are impossible to find by normal
expat methods such as id class name
name etc
access are sony because they tell about
the axis on which elements lie relative
to an element
here an axis shows a relationship to the
current node and helps locate the
relative nodes concerning the tree's
current node so the x-path axis uses
several nodes to find those nodes in the
dom structure
let's have a look on some axes that help
in locating the elements on the web page
the first expat axis is the ancestor the
ancestor axis selects all ancestor
elements grandparent parent etc of the
current node then comes the ancestor or
self
this axis is used to locate the current
node along with its ancestors along that
comes the attribute axis the attribute
axes are used to specify the attributes
of the current node
then comes the child axis as the name
suggests it selects all the children
elements of that current node
the next axis is the descendant axis
it is used to locate the children of the
current node to the leaf node then comes
the descendant or self access that is
used to locate the current node with its
descendants
after that comes the following axis
which locates all the nodes that come
after the current node now comes the
parent axis that is used to locate the
parent of the current node and at the
last we have this self access
the self access are used to locate
current or the present nodes
there are several other nodes other than
these that we have just seen
there is a preceding axis used to select
all nodes that come before the current
node then a following sibling node that
selects the following siblings of the
context node and siblings are at the
same level as the current node there is
one axis called the parent that selects
the parent of the current node let's get
started what exactly is a chrome driver
now when we are working with selenium so
pretty much we
are going to use that tool for the
automatic test cases for the automation
of the test cases is what the main basis
of the selenium tool here so if you got
a website and uh let's suppose you want
to log in you want to put some
credentials you want to do some
transactions so if this kind of flow you
want to test it out
definitely having some back-end test
cases will not help you on that part
because they will not help you to click
on a particular button put some inputs
in that input text so it's it's more on
like a dealing with the more on the gui
perspective so that's where the selenium
chrome driver or the selenium comes into
the picture where it helps you to
drive those test cases where if you are
working on some kind of gui uh related
interface and you want to test out that
application so this kind of
functionality will be helpful for you
and how exactly it goes on let's talk
about the chrome driver here now chrome
driver is a kind of a component which is
available in selenium like you pretty
much use chrome driver only when you
feel like
it's being utilized and at that moment
of time you are working on uh the
specific chrome driver and it gives you
a kind of a content here where you feel
like okay i'm going to use this chrome
driver to see like how the
implementation should be done and how
the automation should be performed over
here so chrome driver specifically helps
you to launches the uh launch the google
chrome browser if you're going to use
firefox if you're going to use internet
explorer then they have their own
specific drivers but this one means like
all your test cases is going to be
executed on the chrome browser so if
your application is compatible with the
chrome browser then this particular
driver makes more sense for you
so it's kind of a driver like uh
definitely this web driver is going to
have all the api calls embedded inside
that which is going to help you to
automate your web applications testing
so
whether you want to go for chrome driver
you want to go for firefox you want to
go for internet explorer it totally
depends on the user and your
application's compatibility if it's
compatible with the chrome you can
pretty much use the chrome driver
without any issues as such here right so
why exactly we need to use a chrome
driver here now when we are using a
chrome driver so it's basically a kind
of main component which is being
utilized by the selenium by the selenium
web driver because selenium requires a
browser plugin or a browser driver so
that it can send the request so it can
send the request to the chrome and it
can process the request uh if the
selenium web driver is saying like i
want to hit onto some input box i want
to hit onto the summit box so those kind
of requests will be processed by the
chrome driver so for that purpose we
require the chrome driver which will
only send the notifications or the
communications which will be sent out to
the chrome browser with the help of the
selenium web driver here now it's being
used to navigate between web pages so uh
if you want to navigate or if you want
to go from one webpage to another web
page so for that also you can use the
chrome browser chrome driver here
so while doing the processing here what
you can do is like you can put the
inputs in the web pages like let's say
like you got a login page so you can put
up a username password you can have the
credentials not only you can provide the
credentials but you can also click on
some buttons certain buttons like okay
let's click on the login button so if
you want to test out how what will
happen that if automatically you're
going to
click on the login button so how your
application is going to behave so if
this kind of a validation and this kind
of verification if you feel like you
want to do then in that case these
chrome browser will be used by the
selenium to interact now the selenium
web driver or selenium
tool can actually send the request and
all these requests will be processed by
the chrome dropper so ultimately it's a
chrome browser where you will see the
end results like the website is getting
navigated the browser is getting closed
automatically the browser is getting
started or initialized automatically
here so all that activity is going to be
done by the chrome driver which will
intake all the specific requests from
the selenium webdriver here now let's
see like how we can set up a chrome
driver for this one you require a chrome
like a chrome browser unique wire
whatever the platform you're using
chrome is pretty much installed there if
you already got a chrome browser
installed all you need to do is like you
need to get a browser uh exe
path over there so that you can
configure that into your
specific uh source code here so as a
chrome driver in the configurations for
that you can put okay so this so and so
location we have the exe file present
there and the source code can actually
use it to launch the
chrome browser and do whatever the
activities you want to perform on there
as such
right so let's see like how we can set
up the chrome browser uh and the chrome
driver over here so that we can run some
couple of selenium test cases now for
the chrome driver uh demonstration over
here we require four things one the cdc
installation the jre which can be
installed from the oracle we already got
the jdk installed into our system and
eclipse also installed into our system
so these two prerequisites already being
done now chrome browser is something
which is also available over here we
already got the chrome browser embedded
inside this machine so the only thing
which is left out is the selenium here
because pretty much though the uh jdk
uh eclipse and chrome browser you will
already be having it there onto your
development machines or into your
personal machines if you're already
dealing with the uh disk with the java
programming source code so you already
have these things available there but
even if you don't have these things we
can easily download those things and
configure into our machine so that we
can start using that one right so we
have the respective links over here
eclipse is pretty easy to download just
download the zip file or exe file
eclipse will be installed and you can
start using it and in order to make the
eclipse work first you have to do the
installation of the
jdk or uh you know the java which you
want to install so that that's what you
require here
right so let's open the selenium uh
browser here so i'm going to click on
this button here so this will help me to
open the selenium
website selenium.dev is the website
which is available there which can help
us to see like how we can go ahead with
this
particular selenium download here so we
are going to download the selenium here
and then we are going to utilize that uh
selenium over here in this one to
process it so this is the selenium which
we got this is the website now here if
you go to the downloads like first of
all you got web driver ide selenium gate
these are the different components which
is there now if you go to the downloads
button
so here you will be able to see like all
the downloads which is available there
like the browser or if you want to see
like the web driver if you want to
install so these are the different uh
programming languages integrations which
is available there
right so you can see like how the
executions uh even if for the c sharp
you have this one here so you also got
the selenium id which is available there
so all these different components are
available which you can see which is
easy for you to integrate for the
selenium here
right now since we are going to uh use
it for the java so we have got like uh
the specific version over here
3.1.4 of
141.59 here so this is something which
we can use and uh you can also go for
the beta version also but i want to
download the uh stable version over here
you can go for the vital download also
right whatever version you feel so let's
go for the download option over here so
this will basically help me to download
a specific file as a file over here now
this zip file is something which is uh
going to have all the required values
and attributes which is available there
so let's see like what exactly is
available in this file so this is kind
of a selenium which we are downloading
and this is what we are going to use in
the eclipse also so in the eclipse we
will be using this stuff so that we can
utilize it
so let's open this one here
okay now you got this uh specific
library files these are the different
library files which is a required over
here you can say like as in dependencies
and these are the ones which is
available there these are the uh
executables like you can say like these
will help you to run any kind of
selenium test cases so all you require
to do is like you can just indicate
these ones into your class path while
running your uh eclipse project you can
add these ones to the build path there
and this will surely work for you these
are the requirements like these are the
predictors which is required in the
eclipse so that you can proceed further
with this one if these are not there
then it's going to show you the
compilations error so first we'll try to
put up the code base there and see that
what kind of error comes in and then
later on we'll see like how we can
resolve those errors as such here so
let's go to the eclipse right now what
we really need to do is like we need to
create a new java project and uh create
a new class so that's what we need to do
and in that case uh we have to configure
the build path but i'm not
going to uh add the external charge as
of now put that uh class bar there so
what i'm going to do is like i'm going
to first
see there that how i can do that
installation so i i'm going to copy this
code here because this is what i'm going
to put up into my a specific class so
whatever the name of the class you can
give so here we are using in the code
base as in the get started here so the
same class name we can use so that we
don't get any kind of issues
so let me copy this content
also uh provided like uh the driver the
chrome is already installed here so we
don't require so you can see here that
we are giving the path of the chrome
driver in case of linux platform when
you're trying to deploy it like when
you're trying to put it up right there
so in that case probably you have to do
the installation like you have to
download the chrome driver for the linux
platform but here it's pretty much like
you can simply use it or you can get it
uh uh done because already the windows
platform we are using it so we are
launching the eclipse here so uh in this
one we will be creating a quickly a
class over here in this one or kind of a
project so that we will be able to
proceed further with that
so uh we're going to create an empty
project here in this case
so we got the uh specific eclipse open
so we can go for a new java project here
so i can say it like selenium so we can
give any project name here
and we can say it like finish so there
will be some basic structure which is
available there so i'm going to quickly
create a specific
file like a class file here
now these are the java files which is
available like white from the jdk but uh
we can easily go to the build path and
we can add the external jars but we are
not going to do that now we are going to
first see like whatever we are going to
get so i'm going to create a class here
like a simple class so getting uh
started is a class which i'm going to
create here because that's the one which
is available into my content of the
class file so you can uh you know if you
feel like you don't want to use the same
name like this one so you want to use
some different names so you can easily
do a rename so that can be easily done
there now here the since like the
imports is something which is coming up
like this is not uh something which is
coming up over here like it's not
getting resolved because of the fact
that uh we are pretty much using uh the
uh specific open uh the selenium
literally jar files the jr files but
it's not getting that it's not showing
that output here so let's see like uh
let's open the uh specific downloads
window here so from where we can access
these jar files and we can refer it so
we got this one so let's extract this
completely
uh you can put these uh for jar files in
any other locations if you feel like you
want to refer that so
you can keep put up into the default
location of the eclipse also if you feel
like this is getting referenced
pretty much frequently and there are a
lot of projects which are working so in
that case you can have it into a small
folder or directly import it into the
eclipse itself so uh here i'm just doing
a one-time activity so let's um use this
downloads folder itself from where we
can simply import these jar files here
so these are the jar files which is
available there in the libraries we also
got like an additional jar file which is
available right so uh we can go ahead
with that part here so these are the
different libraries which is available
and these are again the libraries so
let's uh you know change the build path
here so we'll go for the build path here
and uh we'll say like uh we can add the
libraries here now libraries is
something which we want to sorry we want
to edit the build path here
so here we're going to uh talk about the
external libraries like you know the
libraries which is available there which
we want to put up into this one so we
can say like add external jars so now we
can go for the downloads button here and
here we can put up this jar file here
now we also got a sources one a sources
jar file which is also available there
but what we have done is like we have
added only the executable ones because
sources ones and executable ones is this
is just the same the only thing is that
the sources one will have the source
code also we don't require that as such
then lastly we comes up with the junit
one then of course like uh junit uh you
know is also being referenced here so
for that we don't have to download the
j381 because most of the eclipse
browsers are already having the
libraries integrated so all you need to
do is like you need to click on the add
library here and we already got the
junit in this one so we don't have to
really go anywhere there because it's a
part of the plugin of the eclipse that
it's already integrated there in case of
selenium you went for the add external
jar files and you added the jar file
there but not in this case in junit it
will be automatically referenced because
of the fact that we are using it on over
here in this case
right so these are the two references
like junit also we reference it because
we are running some unit test cases here
so which is like already a part of the
uh plugins here in the eclipse yes uh if
you put the plug-in of the selenium and
you integrate in the same way then also
you don't have to go for this
third-party references but it's okay
like you can reference it there and um
you know any project of selenium can
work now because you got the basic
executables required for that so that
that's how it works on there
right now we also have got like a
certain uh other jar files which is uh
which needs to be added up over there
now those were not uh something which we
added because right now we just resolve
the issues related to the
selenium but uh these selenium
executables may also have some other
dependencies so for that what you need
to do is like you need to add and
another uh folder like uh you know
another folder over here which is like
lib here so these jar files will also
coming up over here because your core
bases may be available or maybe
depending on these ones
so these are the exact uh you know
because your selenium may be dependent
on these jar files there so that's also
we are going to add up over here so not
only the client combined jar file but
other dependent jar files also is going
to be there into the referenced
libraries here
right now let's find out the executable
path of the chrome browser here so i'm
going to open the
c drive here because in that case we
will be having the chrome browser
installed so it's a standard location
where you will be able to see your
particular chrome application exe file
here so uh pretty much this is the
directory structure which is available
there like in this one
it will be installed there so um you can
get the same information from the chrome
shortcut or the from a chrome
icon also that where exactly this exe
file is referenced and if any difference
is there so you can do that now this is
a directory like this is the exe file
which is available there
so i'm going to just put that one over
here in this one
right so this is the way uh we are going
to put up the paths here in this ones
like how the
path should be referenced should be
executed over here and uh ultimately uh
this is required because definitely when
we are going to run the test cases uh
this chrome browser will be sent the
notifications to opening
www.google.com here and it's going to uh
wait over there on that part and uh it's
going to search uh the specific keyword
over here called chrome driver
so this is what it's this program this
basic program is going to perform here
so now let's run the chrome browser here
so uh we're not going to run the chrome
browser but ultimately the junit test
cases so you right click over here and
say run as junit test cases and this
will ultimately help you to launch a
chrome browser now i have not triggered
it manually uh i have got it like
automatically over here and you can see
like the cursor is going to blink
because it's basically waiting for the
selenium to put up the inputs and all
now if you have the test case executed
like you open this website go to this
website click on this and they click on
that so according to that your browser
will start behaving without any
interaction from the human there now
this is a kind of a functionality which
we will get with the selenium and this
makes easy for us like if we want to
validate or if we want to go through any
kind of web application waste testing
this is the ultimate way like how we can
go for that verifications
right so this is what we have in this
demo where we can see like how the
automatically we can do the chrome
browser we can interact with chrome
browser right from the selenium over
here so let's go back to the main
content right so that was the way that
how we can configure the chrome driver
with the selenium here so that we can
invoke chrome browsers and when then we
can according to the statements we can
start sending the request
so that's uh pretty much which is there
now the various activities which we did
in this case was the jdk installation uh
eclipse selenium chrome browser now
chrome browser ide and jdk is pretty
easy to download and you can configure
it and uh that that's the way that how
we can set up the chrome browser the
main important thing is like how to
download the selenium and refer it into
your projects okay so that you can start
using the selenium over here
now we will come to various annotations
this change you will be going to talk
about test engine out today what is
destiny let's talk about that existing
next generation this is the full form of
this ng what is test engine so first of
all preston g is a unit
testing framework or i would say java
unit testing framework they specific to
java
there are two most popular united states
framework one is j unit and one is
distance these are the two in distinct
framework for java and uh if i talk
about jna j in it
it's
used a lot by developers
so developer used this particular
framework a lot for the unit testing
purpose and when i talk about test ng
testing g it is used
a lot by
testers
why there is a discrimination between
these two frameworks then
okay what happens is uh you know
developers are keep on using unit from
quite a long time and they don't want to
switch to the new one
that's only the thing which i feel is
they are using jlit
however if i talk about this change
testing g is
having
more annotations
compared to
junit
having more annotations means more
functionalities
let's let me write it here more
the latest version of junit is junit 4.
for testing g
it is actually
six point that one is the latest version
of testing gm for your junit as it's the
fourth version
for junit there is a new version coming
up that is called s5 and it may be
possible that that will be more advanced
or more not more advanced but that will
be equivalent to testing g
because i have seen as an introduction
that it is having functionality similar
to distance
so now then we won't be able to say that
testing g or sorry j unit is behind test
engine but as of now yes it is
in test ng if i talk about we'll be
going through
some annotations
these annotations helps us to make our
test
more reusable
easily
maintainable okay
if you
get stuck at any point of time you can
go to the documentation of this engine
will find each and everything
clear and very easily defined
so test ng uh documentation is very good
so i would suggest whenever
you get time you can go through with it
but most of the seventy percent of the
test ng functionality is what we are
going to take a look okay because they
are very helpful when we talk about test
ng we always talk about view annotation
question
when we talk about annotation what
annotation is can anyone tell me what
annotation is let me create a package
here
so actually test ng learning testing is
very interesting thing
we are creating a class and we are
seeing
it as
login test cases
we see here
verify
with valid
credentials
verify with invalid credentials
verify
um
suppose if you have any other test cases
well let's let me just think
if you can tell me one test case of
login
one is with valid credential one is with
invalid credentials you can expand it as
much as you want
you but
please verify it with
with no credentials as well correct
or we can say verify with special
characters
sql injection
so there can be multiple methods correct
guys have you observed at any point of
time
whenever you are working on java if you
have written any programs or anything
like that have you observed
there is one annotation comes up there
is one line comes up that is at the rate
override
sometimes at the rate
surprise warnings
anyone of you have have you ever seen
this kind of statement
move on it seems
okay
we also get
deprecated
okay
so
let me come back from that so
whatever you write on top of your method
with enterate sign
and anything post that
that will be considered as an annotation
on top of a method on top of it to pass
anywhere
okay these are called as annotations
and it can be anything i will say at the
right test i so it's not what you will
define
this is
what you will say any name to it
no
these are the annotations which are
being provided by test ng
and every
thing whatever you will be going to
define here
has some functionality attached to it
so it's not that it is just for the name
purpose
it will be going to add up some
functionalities
okay
that's the thing
but okay
let's find
[Music]
so whenever i am talking about
annotation i am talking about
few things which i am going to add on
top of methods or on top of a class
okay
and they actually place an important
role in your particular class or in your
methods
before i tell you about annotations
that what all annotations do we have in
test ng
let me tell you how you are going to
download this test engine
first of all when i said junit jr note
is a pre-installed
java is pre-installed in eclipse but
test ng is not
if you have to download this then just
go to
help
eclipse marketplace
wait for it to
move up
right here
they're changing
and defined okay this will hang
just let it come
okay
here test in g and search for it
so to install it you right you go to
help eclipse marketplace
and inside that you mention
destiny when you get the test change you
will see here testing g for eclipse just
click on install this is how install
button will look like click on that and
install sng and done
testing g will be installed in your
system
okay
now let's talk about few annotations in
testing g we are talking about
annotations from quite a long time now
let's write some annotations
enter it
before
sweet
enter it before test
at the rate before class
and the date before
method
enter it
test
after method
enter it
after
class
hit the right
after
test
enter it
after shoot
enter it before
group
enter it
after group
iterate
data
provider
and and and let's just think if i have
entered it
parameter
okay
so these are the annotations what we
have in test ng
so here what it says score of the driver
automation framework without proper
design your test may look like the image
below
if you don't
think and you know without any design
you may end up by saying login test
product test add to cart test checkout
test checkout test payment checkout test
shipment payment test and pigmentation
etc
it may be possible that the things which
you are using here might
can be used in product test as well it
might be possible that whatever the
things which you are doing here can be
used in add to part as well
so these
are the things which
we are going to use now like this
see this
so with page object you are creating one
object for sign in page product list one
object part one object shipment one
object payment one object order one
object
when you are using the login test when
you are creating select product test it
might be using sign in page objects as
well as product list object so it may be
possible like i have shown you just now
in the uh trivago in that we were using
multiple pages multiple page objects and
we were coming up with the test case and
that's what it is showing us in a form
for diagram if you want you can go
through with that but this is how we
will be going to
write our
automation framework and that's what it
states consideration whenever you create
page object design always consider these
few things
always
create a class for every web page
webpage elements webpage elements are
instance variables off page with a class
of type web element so what it's saying
that whatever the elements you will be
going to write in that are always
instance
or always instance variable we will be
going to do that service page would
include
sign in page active cart
which becomes a method in page object
class
so there will be services pages where
you may see sign in page add to cart
page add to cart query functionality
or methods i will say
and then at the last we have written in
text you create object of page request
and call the methods so let's go
three more slides there are we'll go
through that and we'll see design
pattern test does not have any technical
code to communicate with deal with the
browser
so test will not have any technical code
okay make sure that whatever you are
writing technically you will be writing
in the
pages test call page objects and verify
the result test is more readable like i
have shown you it was more readable form
test object do not verify page load we
don't verify whether the page is loaded
or not okay but they communicate with
the browser these are the syntaxes what
i have mentioned here if you see here
they are using
weight dot until no that is again also a
method so you can ignore it again
okay let's just take a look at this
because all these syntaxes is what we
are going to see
after the break but let's take a look
these are the best practices one can
follow to make design robust and
maintainable
create one page object class for each
web page
web page okay we'll be doing that
each page object method should either
return the object on that page or should
return the
page object of the next page
so we'll see it is this is what we call
as in the name of language
linking between the classes
linking between the classes each page
object should self query date whether
the page is fully loaded before giving
control to the next step any data used
by the page object should be passed to
test and should not be hard coded so now
will not be hard coding anything
and that's what here it is showing us a
very small example with the page check
bmi calculator and the test and here
again
but
let me just create
an architecture of the framework
and then we will
see
all the things will be going to execute
this is my test
i'll be going to create few packages
inside it and i'll be going to tell you
about each package everyone has a
different way to define it
and this is how
i always define
some people say it as page package but i
call it as core package
the score package in this core package
i'll be going to initialize all my
elements
in this
this is the heart of the package
if something goes wrong in this package
in this whatever i will define in this
package if something goes wrong in that
nothing will get executed nothing will
be executed
second package
this is the package i am going to call
it as pages
pages is here we will be going to create
all our pages
means all
are classes for web pages
so all the pages are maintained right
here
another
package we'll call it as
test cases
here i'm keeping all my test cases
another package
util
here i'll be keeping all my utilities
under package
config
here i'll be keeping all my
configuration
pipes another package
logs
here i'll be generating all my logs
related to my project
a new folder
through one thing instead of creating a
folder let's use utilize this resources
and let's put here
one folder by the name of
drivers
so all our firefox chrome ie drivers
will be placed at this location
one more folder
test data
excel sheet or whatever trace data you
are using you'll be putting your test
data right at this location
one more folder
screenshots it's at the
project level so all the screenshots
will be maintained in this folder
and this is the architecture of my
framework which will i'll be going to
create
let's take up uh one more concept that
is first principles and srp let's see
that what it is so first principle
structures the test creation and create
value of the test suits not all the
first principle can be followed in ui
testing use first principle as a long
term guide to maintain a
test suit let's see that what all those
five principles are fast
isolated independent
repeatable
self validating
throw time so your test whatever the
test you are writing it should be fast
enough so
that's why we always discuss that void
use of thread
pick up one more concept that is first
principles nsrb let's see that what it
is so first principle structures the
test castion and create value of the
test suits not all the first principle
can be followed in ui testing use first
principle as a long term guide to
test suit let's see that what all those
five principles are fast
isolated independent
repeatable
self validating
through timely so your test whatever the
test you are writing it should be fast
enough so
that's why we always discuss that avoid
use of thread.ly
what explicit weight put implicit weight
else you may be spending a lot of extra
time
so better avoid this
isolated independent
minimize dependency between tests as far
as possible
so there shouldn't be dependent uh your
test cases should not be dependent on
each other because if one fails it may
be possible the other one will not run
in that case
okay don't make your test case dependent
on each other as much as possible and
also in your test case
insert at least verification of course
you will be having that verification
because that's a
requirement repeatable
configured test so that re-running the
test always give consistent result we
have to keep now our test
cases separately
in different different methods so that
if even if we rerun it won't impact
the results and of course it will not
impact and it actually does not affect
you if this is here validating while
writing the test you should automate
education
as automation
suits run without human intervention
don't assume any human intervention so
always whenever you are creating
your framework your test scripts don't
think that you will be providing some
input to it
never ever give any input to your test
cases to your automation pack make it in
such a way that it can be freely or it
can be run
in your absence as well so what you will
do you will schedule it at 3am in the
night and it will run and it will give
you the results you'll have to make your
test in such a way
not that that it requires your input
like verification here we are saying you
should automate verification you know so
when you are opening up a website you
should verify whether it has actually
opened or not
that is actually opening that particular
url or going to that url or it is going
to some other different url need to
verify all these things probably uh
borrow timely this is applicable to your
test this list should be true in terms
of coverage so when i say in the terms
of coverage you know guys
what happens in unit test cases
in unit testing
we
write code okay of course in selenium
also we write code and in code we write
some variables we create some methods
some extra methods some extra line of
code as well but if we write some extra
line of code that means
if your graph will then sponsor program
will get executed
execution time will be moved correct if
you are adding some more things if you
are using objects which are not being
used anywhere if you are creating
objects which are not changing here if
you are creating variables which are not
being used any version of cool java
while executing java will take care of
them and we'll see them
correct we'll go through through those
steps
which is of no use actually in your
scripts
so here in terms of coverage what it
means is you should get the code
coverage that you have written hundred
percent of your you know you have
written your complete code but actually
how much percent is being used
fifty percent sixty percent seventy
percent so there are some code coverage
tools
which you can use and can see that
actually
how much code is being used
so when you write your script it may be
possible that
50 percent of the script is only useful
50 is you know it's completely not is of
no use
so when you get the coverage code
coverage report you can see that which
one is of no use and you can remove
those extra lines
that's the benefit of code operation and
it is applicable of unit test it is
applicable in selenium as well
running or executing softwares or
applications with the aim of finding out
errors or bugs in the developed
application is called software testing
selenium and qtp are two software
testing tools used widely in the current
software industry
let's do a comparison between these two
testing tools in this video
in this session we will be going through
what is selenium what is qtp then we'll
have a comparison between selenium and
qtp
we'll then try to understand why one
should shift to selenium
and finally how to migrate from qtp to
selenium
so what do you mean by selenium to put
it in simple terms selenium is an open
source testing program for web-based
applications spread across different
platforms and browsers
selenium is a set of four components
that are usually required at the time of
software testing
they are
selenium integrated development
environment or ide
this is a web browser add-on that
creates tests very quickly through its
record and playback functionality
depreciated selenium remote control rc
this is a test tool that allows you to
write automated web application ui tests
in any programming language against any
http website using any mainstream
javascript enabled browser web driver
this is used for cross browser testing
and selenium grid this is used for cross
platform testing so what is qtp qtp is a
testing tool developed by havelet
packard
it stands for quick test professional
identifying errors problems or gaps with
respect to the expected results of any
software that is being tested are the
functions of the hpqtp
vbscript is used by qtp for automation
purposes and it need not be installed
separately as it comes along with the
windows os
the latest version of qtp is called uft
and it is a combination of hp qtp and hp
service test
hudson's and jenkins are two open source
continuous integration system that is
supported by uft
it also provides support for mobile
testing uft mobile support
allows to create agnostic scripts that
is scripts compliant with for all mobile
platforms this script developed in ios
can also be run on android let us now
have a comparison between hpqtp and
selenium
hpqtp is a famous tool in the market of
web-based testing but with the dawn of
selenium's popularity and its ability to
do more than qtp ever could has made it
a worthy competitor
these are quite a few straightforward
differences between qtp and selenium
that might help people choose between
the two
qtp is used commercially and hence it
requires license while selenium is an
open source tool and is free for
everyone to use
qtp can be used to test both web paste
and desktop application
while selenium can only come in handy
while testing web-based applications
only qtp ide can be used while doing qtp
test
while in case of selenium tests multiple
ides can be used like netbeans visual
studio eclipse
qtp can only support vb scripts while
selenium supports multiple programming
languages like dotnet ruby perl php java
javascript etc qtp supports multiple
types of dialog box while selenium can
only support dialog box partially
developing time is high in selenium than
qtp
authentication windows can be automated
in uft whereas in selenium we have to
use auto id or use robot class in java
qtp has a very good official technical
support while selenium has community
technical support
qtp is comparatively more user friendly
and the scripts can be developed in a
short time on the other hand selenium
has less functionality as it is low
level and the scripts take up more time
to come and to be maintained
hp uft is a tool used to integrate qtp
on the other hand selenium does not have
any tool used for integration
speaking of execution qtp can test one
application per machine whereas selenium
can execute multiple tests on a machine
at the same time moreover selenium takes
lesser cpu and ram power in the time of
execution as compared to qtp
so why should one then shift to selenium
a slight modification in the code has to
be tested to make sure that the code is
running fine and fulfilling the target
now
repeating the tests again and again can
get costly the high portability of
selenium allows the automation engineers
to write codes without worrying about
the os
the testing is ideally kept
self-contained within the program and
they can be modified as desired this
approach makes sure that any change in
quotes does not increase the development
and improves maintainability
the flexibility offered by selenium
allows coders to manage tests better
since selenium is open source users can
extend share and modify codes thus
saving a great deal of time and effort
for the programmers
so how to migrate from qtp to selenium
choose the script language keeping the
team's experience and the relevant kind
of automation framework in mind
put off building frameworks and write
simple selenium scripts in the beginning
keep tracks of the issue that come up
with time and make use of the solutions
to build larger test suites in future
once comfortable with selenium start
discovering tools that can be used with
selenium for example maven test ng etc
selenium jobs and salary a very
interesting topic so the market trends
for test automation are continuously
changing and selenium has seen an
exponential growth in a very short time
period this selenium makes it convenient
for clients to receive an roi much
faster and how does that happen by
reducing the number of test cycles
involved in testing their product in
present scenario selenium is a perfect
automation for any of your web web
application testing and automated web
application testing and it is the first
choice of your automation tester as well
as the companies also so as the
softwares are becoming more and more
complex so is the test automation and
selenium is a key skill set for any test
automation engineer to have but of
course it's not the only skill set one
needs to have so if you look at a
typical job description here so gone are
the days when the engineers were hired
as a manual tester every company today
wants to hire engineers who knows how to
do automation and since selenium is the
most popular web application automation
tool companies look specifically for
selenium automation engineers and this
is the typical job description of any
automation engineer to develop test
cases to detect bugs and errors
automation framework designing it's not
just about automating your test cases
one should have the ability to design
the complete framework related to the
project to improve and automate test
practices to participate in
communicating best practices defining
test strategy test manuals for tracking
and fixing your software issues let's
look at the compensation part of it so
compensation varies from company to
company and it also depends on your
experience level so according to the
stacks if you look at the us market it
can vary anywhere from twenty one
thousand dollars to one fifty thousand
dollars
average could be of course somewhere
around ninety thousand dollars and if
you look at the indian market range it
ranges anywhere from two to ten lakhs
per annum for a startup with an average
of five lakhs so the more and more
you're going to get experience the
better is going to be a compensation
package and the market has always been
very lucrative for automation engineers
so since selenium is so powerful web
automation tools there are some of the
top end companies who use selenium in
their various project they want to
provide their customers the best quality
software and help them reduce the time
to market and hence they going for
selling it so a lot of these companies
have selenium deployments in this video
we will look at most commonly asked
questions in the interview and some
guidelines on how to answer them
nowadays automation tool and especially
the selenium skills is a very key
requirement for an qa engineer or even
an automation engineer jobs so if you're
on an outlook of automation engineer or
a qa engineer positions i'm sure this
question bank will definitely help you
prepare for your interview so this video
consists of three parts basically three
different levels of set of questions one
is the beginner level second is the
intermediate level and then the advanced
level questions and each level has a set
of 10 most probable questions which you
might be asked in the interview so let's
begin with the beginner level questions
question one what are selenium suite
components so selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
on web applications you already know
this it is not a single tool so what are
those components which are comprised in
the selenium so selenium comes with four
major components the first one is the id
id happens to be the most simplest tool
in the whole suite of selenium it is
nothing but an integrated development
environment which has a record and
playback functionality this was earlier
available as only firefox plugin however
you need to know that the new version of
selenium ide is available as a chrome
extension as well as a firefox plugin so
that means you can either use any of the
browsers that is firefox or the chrome
for recording your test scripts also you
should also know that the new id comes
with many new features and
now this new ide is become more powerful
than what was available earlier so some
of these new features are like
reusability of your test cases it comes
with a better debugger now and most
importantly it supports parallel test
execution and how does it do that it has
a utility called selenium side runner
that's about selenium id the next
component is the selenium remote control
so selenium remote control or popularly
called as selenium rc is used to write
web application test in different
programming languages it supports
multiple programming languages like java
c
perl python rupee and php it is nothing
but it's a server which interacts with
your browser using a simple http get and
post request for communication selenium
rc is also called as selenium 1.0
version or selenium core third component
selenium webdriver it is a programming
interface to run your test cases and
webdriver was introduced by simon
stewart in 2006 and this was introduced
to overcome some of the limitations of
selenium rc so rs architecture was very
complex because it required an
additional server in its setup and why
was that additional server for
communicating with the browser and what
webdriver did was it removed this
dependency completely webdriver
interacts directly with the browser and
also makes your test cases run much
faster than your rc the last component
the selenium grid a very important tool
this is used to run multiple test
scripts on multiple machines at the same
time now with the selenium webdriver you
can only do sequential execution but in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment so this grid
allows parallel execution of tests on
different browsers as well as different
operating system so the design is in
such a way that commands are distributed
on multiple machines where you want to
run the test and they are executed
simultaneously this uses a simple
hubbard node concept where hub controls
the all execution of your test cases on
the nodes and this is how we achieve
parallel execution and what is the major
advantage of having this grid it is to
reduce your overall test execution time
question two what are the limitations of
selenium now like any other tool
selenium also has certain limitations so
when you are answering this question you
will also be expected to talk about what
is the workaround available for all
these limitations so let's look at them
one by one no reliable tech support of
course selenium is an open source so if
you look at it you do not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
available there are forums available
which you can refer to selenium hq dot
org is the website is your bible if
you're working with the selenium and
then there are there are a lot of
selenium google groups and the forums
which are available for any kind of
support so selenium has been there for
quite some time so it's it's one of the
most mature tool available today so even
though we do not have a technical
support available there is enough
documentation available on the internet
the second limitation selenium can test
only web application selenium is the
open source tool that is designed to
automate web-based applications on
different browsers but it cannot handle
windows gui or non-html pop-ups in the
application now what is the workaround
available for that selenium provides a
support for integrating other tools like
autoit so autoeta is a tool for handling
your windows based activity selenium
also cannot automate mobile applications
but then what is available with that it
can integrate a tool called apm tool
which is a mobile automation tool the
third limitation limited support for
image testing selenium is a de facto
tool for functional web web application
tests so standard api allows interacting
only with the browser and it's hard to
test the images based applications using
selenium what is the other tool
available securely is a very good tool
to use for image testing and this again
you can integrate securely with selenium
that's how you can achieve your image
testing through selenium but using the
secular tool no built-in reporting
facility so selenium does not have any
reporting capability as such of course
it does provide a very limited reporting
capability where some basic reports are
created but definitely when you are
working in a framework you need a better
support for a good reporting tools so
that way selenium supports some of the
tools like test ng report ng and extent
reports using which you can integrate
these tools with selenium and generate
beautiful reports limited test
management selenium does not provide any
test tool integration with test
management tools may require knowledge
of programming languages so since
selenium supports multiple programming
languages the developer of the test
automation will require to have some
basic knowledge of any of the supported
programming language why one in order to
write your effective automation scripts
and of course because selenium tool you
want to use it at its full potential
question three what are the testing
types supported by selenium so selenium
supports regression testing and
functional testing these can be called
as a very high level categories so what
is regression testing regression testing
is a full or partial selection of
already executed test cases which are
re-executed to ensure your existing
functionality does not break so let's
look at what are these attributes of
regression testing and why we say that
selenium helps us in doing regression
testing so regression tests are run
every time a new fix has been received
or a new feature has been deployed so
that is called as retesting you can
always select a full suite or select a
test to test a fix or a complete product
so your selection can be based on
recently added features a test area
where most defects are there or
integration areas or even end-to-end
kind of tests you can also prioritize
your test cases based on critical
functionalities and business impact of
this test cases according to the
priority set so all this can be done
using selenium now what is the second
category of the testing which it
supports functional testing so
functional testing includes what your
smoke does sanity test say install it as
database test basically any kind of
functionality which you are going to
test and if you look at the kind of
steps which are involved in that it
involves identification of your test
inputs expected outputs or the results
the test case logic itself and the
assertions so a typical flow will be
you identify your test inputs first then
you derive your test outcomes or the
expected outputs you design and execute
your test cases and then assert on the
expected versus action outcomes question
4 what are selenium 2.0 and 3.0 versions
so selenium was introduced by a
gentleman called jason huggins way back
in 2004 and that was selenium version
since then this tool has gone through
multiple changes to make it better and
better so if selenium two dot version
had a major change it took a leap
forward in terms of browser automation
the selenium rc the remote control had a
disadvantage of having the need of an
additional server to talk to the web
browsers and because of this the text
execution was much slower and the com
architecture itself became very complex
so if you look at this selenium 2 it had
two components a successor to rc and the
rc itself which is called as your core
so this successor was nothing but your
web driver api so web driver apis made
it easier to write your automation
scripts for any browser by simply using
a suitable driver for any browser which
you want to run the tests on apart from
these two components the selenium 2.0
version also had the ide and the grid
components so in summary if you look at
it selenium 2.4 version has an ide it
has selenium rc which was on its way of
deprecation web driver api which was
just introduced in there a very very
earlier version of web driver api and
the grid so what is selenium 3.0
consists so selenium 3.0 rc was
completely eliminated now because in 2.0
it was already on its path of
deprecation and web driver replaced rc
completely so if you look at the
components of 3.0 we have ide we have a
web driver and grid as the major
components so now with this introduction
of web driver a full-fledged web driver
selenium became the most powerful tool
for web application automation question
5 a very important question what is same
origin policy and how was it handled now
same origin policy is a security id
feature so it is a very important
concept in web application security
model and what is this according to this
policy a web browser allows scripts from
one web page to access the contents of
another web page provided both these
pages are on the same origin now what
does origin mean origin is nothing but a
combination of your url schema the host
number and the port number it's
basically your domain now if a such
question is asked how are you going to
explain it so let's say you have a
javascript program which runs in a
certain domain say google.com okay so
this program can access all the programs
which are from the same origin now
origin here is what google.com so for
example you can access other pages like
your google drive your google email or
your google calendar however now if you
use the same javascript right so if you
use the same script from the google.com
to access another page or an element in
a different domain say yahoo.com then
the security model of the web
application itself prohibits you to do
so so what happens because of that is
you are limited with access only to
those elements and pages which are in
the same domain but now look at the case
that you want to run your test on
multiple servers and you might also want
to access multiple domain so due to the
same origin policy you will not be able
to do so and this became a major
limitation with a very early selenium
tool so how was this handled so this got
handled by paul hammon who created the
selenium remote control so he created
the selenium remote control server to
trick the browser in believing that the
selenium core and the web application
under test actually came from the same
domain and this is how the same origin
policy was handled and this selenium rc
which is selenium remote control became
the version one of selenium question 6
what is celine is and how is it
classified selenium commands for
selenium id are often called as salinis
they are a set of commands that run your
test and sequence of this command is
called as a test script now these
commands are categorized into three
major categories one is the action
command now action commands are the
commands that generally manipulate the
state of your application for example
they can do things like click on this
link or select a particular option open
a url type certain text into an input
box click or double click on any web
element and so on so these are called as
action commands the second set of
commands is the accessors now accessors
examine the state of the application and
store the results in a variable so it
basically allows the user to store
certain values to a user defined
variable for example if i want to store
the page title of a web page i can do
that by defining a user defined variable
and then these stored values can be
later used to create your assertions or
verifications in your test now few
examples of such commands are you can
just use a store story or a store text
store title or a store value so these
are some of the accessor commands the
third category is the assertions
assertions are like your accesses but
they verify the state of your
application and conforms to what is
expected so basically it is a comparison
of your actual versus expected results
there are two types of assertions
available one is the softer sessions and
the harder sessions an example of a soft
assertion can be verify title wherein
you verify the title check whether the
expected and the actual outcomes are the
same and continue with your test case
now whereas in hard assertion is you do
an assert title using the command assert
title and if at all the assertion fails
the test case stops from executing
question 7 mention the types of web
locator what is web locator a locator is
a command that tells the selenium which
ui element you want to operate on
selenium uses locators to find and match
the elements of your web page which it
needs to interact with and there are
around eight locating techniques in
selenium the first one is by id now this
is the most common way of locating
elements why since the ids are supposed
to be unique for each element the ids
can also be dynamic in nature so you can
identify them by inspecting the
attributes of the web element so let's
look at an example so if we go to a
facebook right so if you go to the
facebook and say if i want to identify
this element email so if you look at
this highlighted text here it has a
unique id which is email so if i'm going
to operate on this particular element
email i can directly use the id locating
technique link text and the partial link
text so this type of locator applies
only to the hyperlink text so we access
the link by using this locator which
needs the hyperlink text to be provided
so for link text you can give a complete
text in the link text or let's let's
look at an example of that so let's if
you go to say one of the e-commerce site
which is say amazon dot in and say you
want to click on this today's deal link
so if you look here in
amazon.com there are a lot of hyperlinks
available here and if an example if you
have to take an example say we want to
click on the today's tale now if you
inspect this element you will see that
it has an anchor tag a it has an
associated href link here and also it
has a text which says today's deal right
which is what is displayed on your web
page now similarly there is also a link
available here called customer service
so if you inspect that customer service
it also has something similar what the
today's deal steelhead it has an anchor
tab it has an href link and it has a
long text which says customer service
which is what is displayed now if you
have to use your web locator which is a
linked text you need to provide the
complete text which is displayed on your
web page and there is another way of
using the link text by saying partial
link text where you can just give a
partial text which can be matched
against the complete text of your link
and this is how you can use your partial
link text or the link text the next id
is by name so locating elements by name
is very similar to locating by id just
that your attribute instead of using an
id you're going to use name in this case
now if you look at the same example of
say facebook we identified this email
element using its id you can also locate
the same element by using the name
attribute which is also unique in this
case which has a value called email tag
name that's the next identifier so
locate element using tag name of the
element now say if you want to identify
all the elements on your web page which
are of type button so that you can do by
using the tag name as button there for
example again on your facebook page i
know that there is a single button here
which is of type button and which has a
tag as button and this is the only
button which is available on this page
so if i want to access this particular
element i can simply use a locator
technique called tag which is button in
this case next locator class name so
locate an element using its class name
attribute so you can use this identifier
only if you find that a class name is
unique for a web element which you want
to work with class names are sometimes
unique a web element can also have
multiple class name or even you will
find some elements which has no class
name so depending on what is available
in the attributes you can use this class
name for identification so example the
shown on your screen here where it says
find element by class name input text
basically this is going to list out all
elements on your web page which has a
class name called input text the next
identifier is by xpath now xpath is a
language used when locating xml nodes
what is xml extendable markup language
it can access almost any element even
those without any class names or names
or even id attributes so whenever you do
not find a unique attribute for id name
or class name you can construct an expat
to create an unique identifier for that
particular element now for example on
this facebook page if you observe here
there is a label here called create an
account so if you inspect this
particular label it has no attributes
other than a tag called span so if you
want to identify this particular element
and say display it this is one of the
ways to do it is through xpath css
selector so css selector are string
patterns used to identify an element
based on the combination of either the
html tag id class or any other
attributes locating by css selector is
little more complicated than any of the
previous method however the advantage is
css selectors work much faster than the
xpath the performance of your test
scripts is much better when you use css
selector than any other locating
technique now again as an example if you
see the facebook again you can identify
the same email here right i used an id
here or a name attribute here to
identify it so assume that if you did
not have any of those things or if you
want to use a css selector here you can
still do that by using this syntax this
is how you use the css selector to
identify an element question 8 what are
the types of weights supported by
webdriver now before even you answer
this question you should know why do we
need weights in selenium weights play a
very important role in executing test
cases most of the web applications are
developed using using ajax and
javascripts so when a page is loaded by
the browser the elements which you want
to interact may load at a different time
intervals not only this makes it
difficult to identify the elements but
also if the element is not located it
will start throwing element not visible
exception and how do we resolve this by
using the weights so there are three
different kind of weights available in
selenium first one is the implicit
weight the implicit weight tells the
browser or your web driver to wait for a
certain amount of time before it can
throw no such element exception now the
default setting is zero for this once we
set a time what web web driver does it
it will wait for that time so if you
have mentioned 10 seconds it will wait
for 10 seconds until it finds the
element and even in the 10 seconds it is
unable to find that element only after
that it throws an exception now what is
the syntax of this implicit weight is
this is the syntax of this where you use
dot manage timeouts implicit weight and
there is a timeout value say 10 seconds
and the unit whether it's in minutes
seconds or milliseconds is what you can
mention implicit weight is applied
globally to all the elements which means
it is available for all the web elements
throughout the driver instance implicit
weight is defined only once and it will
remain same throughout the driver object
instance now let's see what explicit
weight is so explicit weight is used to
tell the web driver to wait for certain
conditions before throwing an element
not visible exception it is defined to
wait for certain expected conditions
only now these expected conditions can
check whether the element is displayed
on the web page or not or can be clicked
or not so any kind of conditions you can
mention there so these are called as
conditional weights and they are applied
on a web element on a single web element
unlike the implicit weight which was
kind of applied globally to all elements
it is definitely recommended to use this
explicit weights when your elements are
taking longer time to load and also for
verifying the property of the elements
like say visibility of the element
located element to be click clickable or
element to be selected then we have
fluent width now fluid weight is used to
tell the web driver to wait for a
condition that is very similar to the
explicit weight as well as a frequency
with which we want to keep checking the
condition before throwing the not
visible exception so fluent weight is
used to define the maximum amount of
time you want the web driver to wait for
a condition then if you look in the
syntax then there is polling every
second so polling every and you give a
timeout this could be like five seconds
so start pulling to see whether the web
element is available or not say once in
three seconds once in four seconds
depending on your use case and then dot
ignoring so you can also try to ignore
specific type of exceptions while
waiting now for example such as no such
element exception which is sometimes
thrown when searching for an element on
page so you can mention even that here
so fluid weight takes two parameters one
is the timeout value and the polling
frequency so when we have web elements
which sometimes are visible after few
seconds or sometimes it takes more time
than usual like we have ajax
applications as an example we can set a
default polling period based on our
requirement and then as i said you can
also ignore some of the exceptions by
pulling this element question nine
mention the types of navigation commands
available in selenium so webdriver
provides a basic uh browser navigation
commands that allows the browser to move
forward backward refresh and using the
browser history and this is done using
some of the driver.navigate methods
right so these are some of the commonly
used navigation methods first one is
navigate to so this method loads a new
web page in the existing browser window
and it accepts string as a parameter and
returns nothing so it's a void so the
url you mentioned here needs to be a
fully formed url driver.navigate.refresh
so this method refreshes or reloads the
current web page in the existing browser
window it neither accepts anything so
there is no value path or it returns
nothing forward so this method enables
the web browser to click on the forward
button in the existing browser window
again this has this has no arguments to
be passed or it returns nothing
driver.navigate.back so this method
enables the web browser to click on the
back button in the existing browser
window again this returns nothing nor it
needs any argument question 10 what is
the major difference between
driver.close and driver.quitter so this
is again a very important question and
pretty confusing also sometimes so
selenium webdriver provides two methods
for closing the browser window one is
browser.close and the other one is the
browser.quit so you might think to use
them interchangeably and that's that's
what everybody thinks that both anyway
does the same function so it can be used
however it is not so both are two
different methods now driver.close
command is used to close the current
browser window which is having the focus
and in case if there is a only single
browser window open then calling this
driver.close actually quits the complete
browser session now it is used when
you're working with say multiple browser
tabs or windows and you want to just
close one of them which is in focus in
the test right whereas the driver.quit
is used to quit the complete browser
session along with all its associated
windows tabs pop-ups and everything so
when do you use browser.quit it is best
to use use browser.quit or sorry
driver.quit when you no longer want to
interact with the driver object along
with all its associated windows tabs and
pop-ups generally it is one of the last
statements of your automation scripts so
in case you are like working with
selenium with test ng or gij unit we
usually call this driver.quit in the
after switch that is at after suite
method of our test suite thus by by
doing that we close the complete browser
session at the end of the test suite
execution now let's look at some
intermediate level questions question 11
how to type in an input box using
selenium so selenium provides a method
or a command you can say to insert value
into any of the input box and this
command is called as a send keys command
so send keys is a method available in a
web element now this is how you use the
send keys so here is an example so first
you need to find the element using any
of the eight locating techniques and
once you find the element in this case
which is an email field you need to call
a method called send keys send keys
takes an argument which is of type
string so you can pass the value which
you want to pass to the web element so
in this case you will be passing a gmail
id or any id which will be your email id
here and then similarly you do it for
your password fit so first you find the
element password and then you send the
password using send case this is a very
simple method to use question 12 how to
click on a hyperlink in selenium so
whenever you're testing an e-commerce
application you are going to find lot of
hyperlinks on your web pages which you
will obviously need to test now selenium
provides two locating techniques using
which you can identify this hyperlinks
and using these is what you need to
operate on the hyperlinks on your web
pages so one is using link text and
other one is using partially text so
using link text you give a complete text
in the link text that is if you look at
in your e-commerce site let's say
amazon.com let's let's go to that
website and see what it means so in the
amazon dot in if you look at uh some of
these hyperlink text called today's
deals or amazon pay or sell or customer
service if you inspect this element you
will see that this is associated with a
link text which is called as today's
steel along with this href and of course
an anchor tag so one way of identifying
this link is to use this complete text
which is today's t also there is another
way by using partial link text for say
example you have a link text which is
pretty long and you do not want to use
this complete text instead you can use
the locating technique called partial
link text and give a partial text from
that in this example instead of giving
the complete customer service here you
can just say use a customer or you can
just use service as your text only thing
whatever will be required here is this
has to be unique on this page there
shouldn't be two elements which would
have this text which you are going to
use so let's quickly see this in action
how do we use this link text and partial
link text now we will be using the same
example of amazon.com so my use cases
first i will click on this today's deal
and after a sleep of two or three
seconds i will also click on customer
service and i am going to achieve this
one by using link text so if you see in
this program so i have this method
written which is going to click on
today's deal and this is using a
locating technique link text and then i
also have another method here by using
partial link text i'm going to be
clicking on the customer service link
right so let's see how this works so
i'll just go ahead and execute this so
this launches the amazon dot in and the
first thing what we are doing is it is
going to click on today's deal all right
that is done and then it will click on
the customer service link right so this
is how you can achieve clicking on the
hyperlinks in your web applications
question 13 how to scroll down a page
using javascript this is a very
important question and usually this gets
asked quite often in the interview you
should know that you can run java
scripts through selenium and selenium
provides a way to do this selenium
provides an interface called javascript
executor javascript executor and this
helps in executing any kind of
javascripts through the selenium
webdriver so this javascript executor it
has basically two methods one is execute
script and the other one is execute its
async script to run the javascript on
the selected window or on your current
page but why do you need this right so
if if you are answering this question
you should also have a background that
why at all this is required because
sometimes you need to perform certain
functions which cannot be done using the
locators what has been provided like say
scrolling down the web page itself also
sometimes you will see that you are
unable to even identify some web
elements using all the locating
techniques which is made available by
selenium so in such situations what you
can do is you can directly write a
javascript and execute it using this
javascript executor and if you look at
it the syntax is something like this so
it says javascript executor js is equal
to javascript executor and driver now if
you look at this javascript executor is
an interface that means you cannot
create an object of it and hence you
type cast it to your driver object now
how do you do this now first thing what
you do is you launch your web
application on whatever web application
is under test and then on that current
window you call this particular execute
script method using the javascript
executor and then you can perform any
functions here in this example we are
seeing a function which is crawling down
vertically so this function takes an
attributes or arguments like x
coordinate and the y coordinate now in
this example our x coordinate is zero
and y coordinate is one thousand that
means when this command gets executed
the page is going to get scrolled down
vertically by thousand pixels so why
don't we just see this in action so
let's go to
another program here called the
scrolling tester java so basically what
i'm doing here is i'm going to be
logging into amazon.com and then i will
show you how to scroll down by 600
pixels so it's a very very simple code
to write you launch your application
then you create your object of
javascript executor right actually you
type cast it to the driver and then you
just use an execute script command or a
method this you see is your actual
script which gets executed which says
windows dot scroll by 0 comma 600 which
is x coordinate and y coordinate let's
go ahead and execute this so when
amazon.in is launched and you should see
the screen scrolling down yes there we
go so just scroll down by few pixels and
that is 600 pixels what we mentioned see
i could scroll back again and that is
how you can achieve scrolling functions
and when do you usually use this say if
you have a very long web page and you
want to go and identify or do some
operations on the web element which is
probably available to you towards the
end of the page and that is when you can
use some of the scrolling functions
question 14 how to assert the title of a
web page selenium web driver provides
web driver methods and one such method
is called get title so what get title
does is it fetches the title of the
current page how to use this command get
titles returns a string which is nothing
but your title of your page that means
you need a string variable in which you
can store this value so what you do is
you define a string variable like it is
defined in this example to store your
title and then you execute this command
driver.gettitle which is going to fetch
the title and that value gets stored in
your actual title once you get the title
you can do any operations with that in
this case what we are doing is we are
trying to verify the title there are two
ways which you can verify that one is
using an if else statement where you
compare your actual title with the
expected title or alternately you can
also use assert statements here right so
selenium provides a search statement so
using assert you can validate whether
your title of the web page is as
expected question 15 how to mouse over
over an element
in automation many times it is required
to perform some action on the element
which gets visible only on the mouse
hovering on those elements now in
selenium action is a class which we can
use to achieve this functionality so
action class is defined in a package
called as selenium.interactions
this has a set of apis to emulate
complex user gestures it helps in
building the patterns of action and then
perform that action on a web element now
this action class provides a rich set of
apis like so for mouse events and even
the keyboard events so say for to
perform any kind of mouse event it
provides a method called move to element
now in this example what you do is you
initiate an object of mouse class and
then use this move to element method and
what it does is the element is scrolled
into the view first even before the move
operations happen so you could have
multiple actions like here in this
example we are just using move to
element but also you can if you want to
do a drag and drop observation you can
still have that so in such case where
you have multiple actions like a drag
and drop then you use a method called
build along with this so you say actions
dot move to element dot build and then
dot perform so dot build method is
called before the perform method and
what it does is it generates that
composite actions which has all those
multiple actions which you want to
perform on a web element then after the
building action is done you call a
perform method which actually performs
that action on your web element and this
is how the move to element method of the
action class is used why don't we just
see that in action let's say let's go to
our eclipse here and i have a mouse
hover test written here so let's say we
go to amazon.website so in the amazon uh
if you go to the shop by category you
see that so the moment i mouse over it
it is going to give me this drop down
list so for me to select any element
from this my first action on this web
page should be to go and just hover my
mouse over this web element called shop
by category and that's exactly i'm going
to achieve through my automation now
here in my methods here what i have
written i have said okay first launch
your website which is amazon.n and then
i am finding that element which is shop
by category using an x path so you could
use any available locating technique to
find the element first and then i
instantiate an object of actions and
then simply i'm doing is i'm using the
method move to element and then i'm just
going to say perform that means my mouse
would actually get moved or hovered onto
that particular element okay so let's
see this in action so i'll just execute
this test case okay so amazon.com is
launched and now we should see yeah the
mouse actually moved to shop by category
and because of that we got this drop
down list so and this is how you can
achieve your mouse over functionality
question 16 how to retrieve the css
properties of an element now css is
nothing but cascading style sheets it's
a style sheet language used for
describing the presentation of a
document written in your markup language
it basically describes your html
elements as how they need to be
displayed on the screen it's basically
the look and feel like your font size
the width height color and so on so it
provides a special and easy way to
specify various properties of the
element now why do we need this we need
to use a special method called get css
value to retrieve such chs properties of
web element why because we already have
a method called get attribute which can
retrieve the value of the attributes
right however the get attribute method
can only retrieve those properties where
the attribute and its value are
mentioned in your dom and hence all this
font size color cannot be retrieved
through the get attribute method and
that is why we use the get css value so
basically it works like your get method
and you need to provide the attribute
which you want to fetch using the get
css value so in this example what we are
trying to do is we have a web element
called the email id and of that we are
trying to fetch the font size so let's
again check this in action so if i go to
my web page here let's close this so if
i go to my facebook and if i inspect
this particular element which is the
email id and on the right if you see
there are multiple other attributes of
that element you see right so you see
the background color you see the color
here then you see something called as
font size and say for example we want to
retrieve the font size of this
particular web element and you will also
see on the left where you are seeing the
dom here you do not see that font size
anywhere as an attribute and its value
here and that is why i cannot use the
get attribute method to retrieve it now
instead of that what i'm going to do is
i'm going to use the get css value and
use this font size for that so let's go
to my eclipse i have a method written
here where i log into the facebook and
then i'm going to first find that
element which is by id and i'm going to
retrieve the css value and i'm just
simply printing it on the console so if
i execute this so it's going to launch
the facebook and since i'm not going to
do anything on the facebook webpage as
such let's go to my console here because
this is where i'm expecting the output
so here it has given me that an output
in the console saying 12 px which is
nothing but your actual font says what
you see here in your html page right and
this is how you can extract your css
properties of any web element on your
web page question 17 what is page object
model popularly known as pom page object
model is a design pattern that helps
create object repositories for web
elements so writing selenium test cases
without say using any patterns may lead
to code duplicacy and also the code
becomes unmaintainable after some time
and say if you have web element locators
which changes over time then you will
have to go through the entire code base
to make all the required changes so
under this model for each web page in
the application there should be a
corresponding page class and this page
class will have all the web elements of
the web page and also it contains the
page methods which perform operations on
the web elements and the verification
steps required in your test cases are
the separate test cases they are not
combined in the same class now the tests
that use the methods of this page object
class whenever they need to interact
with the ui of that page the benefit
here is if the page ui changes that the
tests need not be changed only the code
within this page object class needs to
be taken that is you go and just change
the web elements or the locators of the
web elements only in one place which is
your page class and not in any of your
test classes or not test classes so how
does this form help so it makes the code
more readable maintainable and reusable
so there are two ways you can implement
a bomb or a page object model one is
done using the page factory which is
offered by selenium and then you can
also achieve a page object model without
using the page factory right using
directly the objects and the classes
question 18 can capture be automated
this is again a very favorite question
of the interview captcha is a security
feature that prevents bots and automated
programs from accessing sensitive
information yes and captcha cannot be
automated you will see that there are
many applications today who have captcha
why because it's a security feature it
is a concept to differentiate between
human and computers the idea of capture
itself is to prevent any automated
process or a robotic process to do any
kind of actions and say if you're going
to automate it then the entire idea of
having the captcha is lost so you should
never attempt to automate it but then
what do you how can you handle this then
one either you can ask your developers
to disable it in the test environment so
that you can test the whole application
without having to hit on this captcha
other way of doing is you can use static
data for your captcha so that you can
hard code that value in your test for
the time being and then since your
application has capture as one of its
functionality if you really need to test
that you can just test that separately
as a manual testing itself but not
automated question 19 how does selenium
handle windows based pop-up selenium is
an automation tool for automating web
applications it cannot handle windows
based application however we can use
tools like auto it and robot class along
with selenium to handle such pop-ups so
what are these tools robot class is a
java class which along with selenium can
simulate your keyboard and mouse events
it also helps in upload and download of
files and also to manage the popups so
wherever you have a requirement of doing
a file upload operation in which if your
native dialog box opens up then one of
the way to handle it is using robot
class other tool which is available for
us is the auto it tool it is a freeware
and what it does is it uses a
combination of your mouse movement
keystrokes and window control
manipulation to automate any such task
which is not possible by selenium
webdriver and again this auto it tool
can be integrated with selenium and thus
you can achieve the automation of native
window based pop-ups question 20 how to
take screenshots in web driver take
screenshot interface can be used to take
screenshots in webdriver so selenium
provides us this interface for managing
our screenshot operations now
screenshots are desirable for bug
analysis so selenium can automatically
take the screenshots during your
execution you know that it is very
important to take screenshots when we
execute the test scripts say if we have
a huge number of test scripts running
and if some of the test case fail we
need to check why this test case failed
so using the screenshot functionality it
helps us debug and identify the problem
by looking at the screenshots so
webdriver has this built-in
functionality to take the screenshot
across the page and it's pretty easy to
use take screenshot interface is used to
capture the screenshot during the
execution now this interface has a
method called grid get screenshot as
which captures a screenshot and it also
stores in a location specified by us so
let us take an example of our facebook
page and say we fail a particular test
case on the facebook application and
then let's see how we take a screenshot
at that particular moment when the test
case fails so let's go to the facebook
page first and let's understand the use
case so in this facebook page say if i'm
signing up on this page i need to enter
all this field now as a part of demo
what i will do is i'll just enter the
first name and the surname and i will
click on the sign up button with this
test case it should basically not sign
me up rather it should give me some
error saying that you need to enter all
the fees and at that minute we are going
to take a screenshot okay so that's our
use case so let's see how do we achieve
that so if i go to my eclipse and let's
say we go to my screenshot test.java i
have a method written here so and these
are the operations which i just
described which i'm doing it here so i'm
going to just send keys my first name to
the first name field second name into
the third name field and then i'm just
going to click on the sign up button now
there are few things required for us to
do before we use the take screenshot
interface along with its method which is
the get screen shot as so i said that
this method stores the screenshot taken
in a file so that means i need to
provide it a file name and also a
location where it needs to be placed so
in our demo here in this test class what
i have done is i have created a folder
called screenshot in the same project
directory and then i am giving it a file
name called fblogin.png so that means
after the screenshot is taken it is
saved in a file called
fblogin.png and then it is stored in the
location screenshot folder and these are
the simple file operations of java which
i use to achieve this so let's execute
this and see how this happens so right
now i have this screenshot folder and
it's an empty folder so after the
execution i am expecting that this
particular file would get created so
let's see that in action so i'll go
ahead and execute this java program okay
so we have launched the facebook.com and
then i entered the my first name second
name and it has also clicked on signup
after which it has given all this red
marks here and now this is what i'm
expecting in the screenshot so let's go
back to our eclipse i will refresh this
folder so i'll say right click and
refresh okay i have this file created so
let's open this file and see right so do
you see this this whole image has been
captured so now as a tester if at all
this test case fails for me i can always
open this png file and see what actually
happened and i can debug my test case so
this is how you use screenshot
functionality in selenium level
questions question 21 can you type in a
text box without using send keys so you
need an alternative way to use instead
of using the send keys function and one
such alternative is using javascript
executor so selenium provides an
interface called javascript executor and
this helps in executing any javascripts
through your selenium webdriver so you
can do any kind of function using this
javascript and one of the functions
which we can do is the send keys kind of
a function now how to replicate a send
keys function using javascript so let's
see an example here now since this
javascript executed is an interface you
cannot create an object of this
interface so what you do you type casted
to your driver object the way it is done
here in this example and then you use
document dot get element id to get the
actual element on which you're going to
perform the operations of sending the
keys now what is this document so it is
an object right so this document it's an
object that represents your html
document which is displayed in that
window and this document object has
various properties that refer to other
object which allows you the access to
modify any of your document content so
the argument which you're passing to the
java execute script is nothing but your
javascript now this javascript uses the
document object to identify your element
and then send the value which you need
to send to that element so let's see
this in action as how it works so let me
show you a small program here all right
so i have a method here wherein i'm
trying to identify the email field of
your facebook page so if this is your
facebook application this is my email
field and instead of using send keys
here i'm going to pass a email value to
this and how am i doing that using a
javascript executor right so if i
execute this particular java program it
is exactly going to do the same function
what i would do otherwise using the same
case so let's execute this and see if i
can see my user's id email in the
facebook application so the facebook
application is launched and there we go
so we this is the value which i have
sent using my javascript okay so this is
how you can use a javascript executor to
replicate a send keys method question 22
how to select a value from your drop
down list in the selenium webdriver so
select class is a selenium webdriver it
is used for selecting and deselecting
options in your drop down list the
objects of select type can be
initialized by passing the drop down web
element as a parameter to its
constructor like in this example i am
saying select drop down equal to new
select of test drop so test drop is
nothing but the web element which i have
identified using any locating techniques
after you create the select object then
you have three different methods
available for actually selecting your
methods and what are these methods one
is select by index now the index starts
with zero in the list so you can select
any element from your list using the
index side and then the second one is
select by values so this is used to
select an option based on its value
attribute select by visible text so this
is an option wherein you can select a
particular list item or an option based
on the text displayed in the option so
that means whatever text you can see on
your drop down list is what you will use
it to identify that particular element
so let's see the demo for this so i have
again a same facebook application which
i have considered here for demo so if
you go to our facebook application first
you know that there is a drop down menu
here now this drop down is for selecting
your birth date this has a day values
which you can select the month values
right and the year now what i have done
in my code is first thing is i've
identified all these drop-down boxes
using one of i'm using mostly the id
locating technique here so you can use
any of your choice so once i identify
the element i created the select object
class for each of this and i pass that
web element to the constructor of the
select class so now my select element or
the object is ready to use so my next
step what i need to do is i need to go
and select the actual dates now in this
use case what i want is i want to select
a date which is 10th june 2005 that
means on my select drop down of the day
i should be able to select the day 10
now this i am achieving by using select
by value and then i am selecting the bun
month based on the index which is the
index in this case is 6 which will
select the june for me and then the
third one i am trying to select it by
visible text wherein i am selecting the
year 2000 y so when i execute this
program let's see how the date selection
happens
okay there we go so it selected the 10
the day 10 the june month and the 2005
so this is how you use select objects in
selenium question 23 what does the
switch to command do so switch to
command is used to switch between
windows frames or even the alert pop-ups
within your application right so there
are multiple things which you can do
with switch to now sometimes in your web
application say when you click on a
button it opens up a completely new
browser window or you will also see it
opens up another tab in your browser say
for example let's look at one of this
application which i have let me go to my
browser
and say i
launch hdfcbank.com
all right so this is my application say
which you want to test now when you
launch this first thing is i see this
advertisement pop-up which comes up
which is right now an unwanted pop-up so
right now i'll just close this and now
if i want to enter this hdfc bank
application first i need to do a login
so if i click on this login button see
there is a new window which opens up and
i need to go and operate into this
window so for any further operations i
want to do it on this web page i need to
switch to this window and then say i
want to click on continue to netbanking
and then continue with my use case so
now in this application there are two
windows open one is your base window
from where we actually logged in and
after i clicked on the logging there is
a new window opened up right so this is
where your switch to command will help
us to switching to this particular
window to do any of the operations on
this web elements present on this window
okay now let's see how do we actually do
this so in order to do this first you
need to get the handle of the window by
using a command called driver dot get
window handle all right so now when you
use driver.get window handle what you
get is a unique alphanumeric value which
is an identifier for that window and
once you get this you use a command
called driver.switch2
dot window and you pass that handle
which you have fetched previously and
this command will actually switch to the
current window which is in your focus
now you will also come across a case
where there are multiple windows open
right now the example what we saw we
just had a single window but say if you
whenever you launch an application say
there are multiple windows which are
open so in such case you can use
something called as get windows handles
right now get windows handles what it
does it it picks up all the active
windows at that point of a time and
using a for loop you can read into every
handle and then you do your operations
specific to your window handles also
there is another way wherein you can
switch back to your parent window so if
ever you want to switch back to your
parent window you have to use the same
command driver.switch2 and the handle
what you need to provide here is your
parent handle all right so this is about
windows then i also said switch 2 can be
used for your frames so what are frames
frames are usually used to divide your
web application or your web page or the
on the same domain into various
different windows or sections right so
for us to operate on elements which are
in different frames we need to first
switch to a particular frame and then
use the web elements on that so the same
command will be using now instead of
window here i would say driver dot
switch to dot free similarly even the
alert popups can be handled using the
same command so in the case of alert
what you need to do is you have to say
driver dot switch to dot question 20 how
to upload a file in selenium webdriver
right a very important concept in
selenium webdriver we know that selenium
webdriver is designed for automating web
application right and file upload is a
very common scenario which we get with
every web application which we are
working with now there are two ways to
do a file window file upload operation
one is using the send keys which is the
simplest method and the other way is
using robot class now there are certain
prereqs required for you to work with
the send keys option now if you are
using the send keys option what you
basically need to do is you need to type
in the complete path of the file along
with the file name right in the file
select input field now this element
where you're going to enter your file
name should have certain attributes one
of the attribute is it should have the
tag as input right and also it should
have an attribute called type which
should have a value of file only then it
is possible for you to enter a file name
and upload the file okay that is by
using the send keys method then the
other way is using robot now when when
is that we need to use robot where
whenever you have an application and in
your application usually for your file
upload you have a button which says
upload a file and when you click on that
it opens a new window and this window is
your windows explorer window or a finder
window depending on what operating
system you're working and these are the
native windows and we know that selenium
webdriver directly cannot handle the
native applications so in such case the
robot class helps us in managing these
native windows so what happens in the
robot classes it helps you manage your
file upload dialog box by simulating all
the actions required for selecting a
particular file from your dialog box and
then you go and upload them all right so
this is the example of using the send
keys question 25 how to set browser
window size in webdriver so you can
either maximize the window or set it to
a certain value now to do this you use a
simple functions provided by
driver.manage one of the functions using
driver.manage is
driver.manage.window.maximize
now this command maximizes the current
window and say you want to set a
particular window size rather than
maximizing it and then for that you have
a command called
driver.manage.window.setsize
now this set size takes an argument of
the type dimension class so this is
basically when you create a dimension
class you are passing the size of the
window which you want to create here
right so we use the dimension class
define the new dimensions of the window
and then pass the object of this
dimensions to the set size method this
is one way of doing it we also saw that
using javascript executor we can do any
kind of functionality so if you want to
minimize or maximize or set a different
size to your browser windows this can
also be done using a javascript okay
let's see a quick demo on how do we use
this driver.manage
dot set size or the maximize command so
let's go to my eclipse here so i have
this method written here so i have two
methods one method where i'm saying i'm
going to maximize the window this
particular command is where i'm saying
driver.manage.window.maximus and i'm
launching a facebook application so
first let's run this particular method
and see how our browser window behaves
so i'll just say execute this
so now you will see the whole window
your browser window is in maximized mode
so now from here i'm going to execute
the other set of
lines here using which i'm going to set
a certain size now i'll just comment out
these two lines
and then
these are the two commands which i'm
going to use right so here what i've
done is i've defined an object of the
class dimension and i've used 600 600
which is the size of the window which i
wanted to be and then using the set size
i'm passing this dimension object to the
set size method now let's see how do we
look at this browser window now
did you see that so it was at a certain
size and it just shrunk it shrunk
because i have used a smaller size
window question 26 when do we use find
element and find elements now find
element you can use this command to
access any single element on your page
and what does it return it returns an
object of the first matching element of
the specified locator and this is the
most common command what we use for
working with every web element on the
web page what is find elements find
elements is used to return a list of web
elements right so each element which it
identifies is indexed with the number
starting from 0. it's just like an array
i'll show you an example of that so that
you can understand it better so let's go
to my eclipse here right so if you look
at this locators.java i have different
elements which i have identified using
different locating techniques right so
for that i use a simple command called
find element now say i have a use case
right wherein i want to fetch all the
web elements who have a class name
starting with the text input let's see
what that is so if i go to my facebook
application if i try to inspect this say
first name right so i'll say inspect
element now here if you see this
particular web element has a class name
starting with text called as input text
likewise there are many elements here
like even the surname if you look at it
it has a class name starting with input
text okay so if i have a use case like
that where i want all the web elements
on the facebook page who have the class
name starting with mint now input if i
have to do that that is when i say i'm
going to use the driver.find elements so
i say driver.find elements i give an x
path which is going to pick up all those
elements which has the class name
starting with input this is my xpath
expression once i get all the elements
what am i doing i'm going to store it in
a list array once i have all these
elements created it's in an array i'm
just going to traverse through the array
using an enhanced for loop so in this
program in this test case i'm just
picking each and every element and
printing the attribute id of each
element so if i execute this now we
should see all the elements on the
facebook page which has the class name
starting with input and we should see
all the ids of that so this is what we
are getting so you are around getting
nine to ten elements it has picked up
and all of them have the class name
starting with input and these are the
different ids
question 27 what is pause on exception
in selenium id so pause on exception is
a new feature of selenium ide it is one
of the brilliant debugger function which
this new selenium id provides us what it
does is it enables us or when this
particular option is enabled the
execution of your test pauses if at all
there is any exception which occurs in
your test scripts and because of this
what you can do is you can go and handle
that error by say changing your command
in the script and then continue your
test execution so this helps in
debugging your code pretty well so
whenever there is an exception say for
example and web element which you are
trying to identify has a wrong
identifier or it changes on your web
page then you can correct that command
which caused the exception and then
resume the test execution from that
point onwards so let's look at a simple
use case and see how exactly this works
so for example let's go to my browser
here
okay so i have a simple use case here
where i want to login into facebook
using my email id and password and what
i have done is i have created a script
or recorded a script using my selenium
id so these are all the steps which it
has wherein it logs into the facebook
account then it clicks on the email
field enters the email this is my value
which i'm passing clicks on the password
field enters the password and then
clicks on the login button now this is a
clean test script and all my web
elements are correct here so whenever
i'm running this test with this test
script is going to pass now say as an
example say this particular element
which is my password element say this id
changes so now deliberately what i'm
going to do i'm just going to give a
wrong id here so if i give a wrong id
and if i execute this test script now it
is going to throw an exception at this
point so let's do that so it's going to
throw an exception but now since i want
to use that pause and exception feature
what i do is it's available here it says
pause an exception by default it is
switched off so when you select this
that means this has been switched on and
now if i execute the script this is
going to come into a debug mode at this
point where my exception is going to be
through so let's see that so now i have
this i have changed this id to a wrong
id so i'll just say go and run this
current test so let's see how it
operates so let me just bring this side
by side so you can see here it has
entered the email and if you look here
in the console it is saying trying to
find the id for which i've given pa and
4s which is a wrong id so it will look
for some time whether it can find an
element with this particular id so let's
wait for it to throw the exception
there we go so now it tried enough and
actually that step has failed and there
is an exception saying that that
particular web element is not found
however my test case or the test script
did not exit it has come and paused and
it has entered into a debug mode here
paused and debug now as a tester or an
automation script writer what i can do
here is i can simply go and correct this
now i know this is my correct id once i
correct this i can execute the rest of
the script right from this point so now
i have this option here if you go here
it says resume test execution so i'm
just going to click on that so it is
going to go ahead and enter everything
yes if you see here i entered email
password and in this test script what
i'm doing is i'm entering my first name
and my surname instead of clicking on
the login button so it went ahead and if
you look here it says fb test completed
successfully this is how the pause and
exception feature helps us question 28
how to login into any website if it is
showing an authentication pop-up for
username and password which will be
something like this so this is a typical
authentication pop-up which you normally
see when you are dealing with some web
application right and to handle them we
use something called as an alert class
and alert class comes with a method
called authenticate using basically by
using this method what we are trying to
do is it helps us skip the basic http
authentication box so how do we handle
it it is handled exactly the way we
handle any kind of alert box and
selenium now in this example first what
we need to do is we need to create a
weight object using an explicit weight
now this weight is for what it is for
the alert to pop up so we basically wait
until that authentication alert pops up
and set the conditions in this explicit
way for as alert is present so that
means you're going to wait until your
authentication pop-up is c on your
screen and then once you have that
authentication pop-up which is on your
screen that is when you need to go and
handle it now to handle it for your
alert class you're going to call a
method as i said using authenticate
using and to this you pass a parameter
now this parameter has to be your
username and password however the way
the parameters are passed here is using
a class object called user and password
now this user and password class it is a
part of selenium security package all
right and this is implemented from an
interface called credentials so you
create this object of class user and
password using the authentication
information which you have and then pass
this as parameter to your method called
authenticate using and this way you can
handle your authentication pop-up
question 29 what is the difference
between single and double slash in
x-path a very important question and
it's a very important thing for each of
you to understand single slash is used
to create an x path with absolute path
that is the x path would be created
right from the starting node and the
starting node is slash html and the
double slash is created or it's a x path
with relative path now relative path
this x path would be created
using any starting location or anywhere
within the document for example i could
start with a div tag wherein if i
mention double slash and div so this is
going to be treated as a relative path
and whatever conditions i am going to
give it is going to try and match those
attributes with the stack right this is
called as a relative path so why don't
we just go and take a look at how do we
identify an element using a relative as
well as an absolute path so if i go back
to the same application of the facebook
this is my facebook application now i
have this crow path installed which
helps me in identifying x parts of an
element now say i want to try and see
what is the x path of my element first
name so in the inspector tool i can see
that it has a tag input and it has a
long class name and it has multiple
attributes which i can use to identify
this element so if i go to my crow path
and again try to match this element so
if i just hover my mouse here now here
you can see this crow path gives me both
the path one is the relative x path and
one is the absolute expert now look at
the big difference between these two now
relative path was as simple as using a
slash slash input which is the tag and
an attribute called id we are able to
identify this particular element same
thing if you want to use an absolute
path and you if you see here it will
start right from the slash html which is
your starting node of your html page and
then it travels down looking into each
of the parent and child under this until
it found this element input right so
this is absolute path so you can use
either of these paths to identify your
elements question 30 how do you find
broken links in selenium webdriver now
http is designed for what to enable
communications between your clients and
servers and if you know there are few
commands like get put post now get is
used to request data from a specified
resource put command is used to send
data over your server and post is used
to send data to the server right now
while using these links and trying to
figure out if the link is valid or not
what you can do is you can use something
called as head requests now what are
head request head requests are nothing
but they are something like a get
request but they do not have a response
body and usually this is used for
checking that what a get request can
return before actually making a get
request like say before downloading a
large file you would send a head request
before sending the complete get just to
know whether the link which is provided
for downloading a large file is a
genuine link or not and then looking at
the response code is what you decide
that so how do we do this
programmatically now selenium provides
something called as http url connection
class which has some methods to send
http request and to capture the http
response codes like the ones which you
see it on the screen so if we have to
see how do we do that now first thing
the logic behind how do we get this
broken links is you get all the urls on
your website first after getting all the
urls now how do you get the urls by
using the tag a like it is done here so
once you get the complete list of all
urls you also check for a non val non
null or a blank ones that is one kind of
a check which you can put after that you
create an http connection object with
each of the url and you open the
connection of the url and you send the
request now this request whatever you're
going to send you are going to send the
header request to just to get the head
and not the complete get request now
only thing what you're interested in
getting a response code so once you get
the response code what you have to do is
you have to check the response code
against all your response code now
typically when you're checking for your
response code any response code above
400 is treated as a client error rest
all the links below 400 are all the
valid links so here if you see four zero
four you have a response called as link
not found 400 is a bad request 401 is
unauthorized so you can do a simple
check there where it says if your
response code is above 500 then that
particular link has an error and that is
probably going to be an invalid link so
let's see that in action as how exactly
the code is going to look and how do we
achieve that now i have a test case
written here called broken links.java
now here what i'm doing is i'm logging
into facebook.com and then i'm fetching
all the elements with the tag a now when
i say i'm fetching all the elements with
the tag that means i'm going to get all
the href element from the page and once
i get that using a for loop i'm going to
inspect each and every url what i'm
going to fetch as i said my first check
would be to see if it is a null or is it
an empty if i find an empty or a null
value in the url i'm just going to
ignore that and continue the loop and
this is where i actually do the
connection with my url so i create an
http url connection with the url which i
have picked it up from my website then i
do this i send a request here the head
request to get a response code so once i
get this response code is what i put a
if-else statement and check if my
response code is greater than or equal
to 400. so if i find that if my response
code is more than 400 that means this
particular url link is broken and that
is how i identify so once you identify a
particular url which is broken you can
make use of that information share it
with your developers and get it fixed so
let's go ahead and execute this so in
this test case basically what i'm going
to do is i'm just printing out all the
urls and i'm printing the ones which are
valid and ones which are broken uh since
it's a
facebook.com website i do not have any
broken url but this is just a logic of
how do we find a broken url so if you
look here a lot of websites which is
getting listed which says is a valid
link so that means it is getting a
response code which is more than 500. so
this is what we saw in the demo as how
do i i trade after i select all the
links on the page and then how do i
determine whether it's a valid link or
it's a broken link in this session we
will learn about j meter in this j meter
complete tutorial we will be learning
everything related to jmeter starting
from its installation but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn now without
further ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's session
so as discussed we will start with j
meter installation then we will get into
the performance testing followed by that
we will learn the j meter load testing
advancing ahead we will dive deep into j
meter api testing and finally we will
wind up the j meter tutorial for
beginners with the last topic that is
the j meter strip recording i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda now
over to our training experts let's get
started with what is j meter
j meter or apache j meter is an open
source software which is a 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance performance testing means
testing a web application against heavy
load multiple and concurrent user
traffic
it was originally designed for testing
web applications but has since expanded
to other test functions
to simplify let's assume that someday
your team lead tells you to perform
performance testing of some website like
google.com or facebook.com for around
100 users
what would be the first thing that comes
to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with computers and
access to the internet and accessing the
same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when a need for software like
jmeter rises
so what jmeter actually does is that it
simulates
it will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load tests on a server group of
servers network or object
moving further let's have a look at the
prerequisites to install jmeter
the only prerequisite of installing
jmeter is that java must be installed in
your system since jmeter is an entirely
based application that's why having java
installed in your system is a must
other than that jmeter can be used in
many operating systems such as linux
windows mac us or even ubuntu
now that we know the basics of jmeter
let's go on to installing jmeter onto
our system first let's check if you have
java installed in your system
for checking that we shall go to the
command prompt and type java hyphen
version
we can see that java is present in our
system
here it will show the version of java
present in our system
the next step is to download jmeter
go to google chrome and type jmeter
download
now go to the official apache jmeter
website and go to the binary sections
in the binary sections we shall download
the zip folder
once the zip folder is downloaded open
the folder location then extract the zip
folder
once the folder is again extracted go
inside the folder and go inside the bin
folder here
the bin folder contains the jmeter
script file for starting j meter
now it's time for us to launch a meter
but before we launch jmeter we need to
know that there are typically two types
of modes in which jmeter can be launched
the gui mode and the non-gui mode the
non-gui mode may refer to two types the
first being running j meter in the
server mode and the second refers to
running j meter in the command line
and if we talk about the gui mode then
the gui mode has a limitation which
slows down the cpu utilization while
running the recorded script
but
gui mode of j meter is perfect for
adding and editing new configuration
elements thread groups and samplers as a
result of which you can view a number of
different listeners helping for
debugging
here today we shall be using the gui
mode
so to open the gui mode inside this bin
folder select the jmeter.bat file
double click on this file this may take
a while and then the j meter window will
open up on the screen the home window is
divided into two sections on the left
side all the elements of the test plan
are added and on the right side all the
configuration of that element are added
as we see on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward let's rename this test
plan let's name the test plan to be
first j meter
now when you click outside this window
section you can see the element name
will change otherwise you can just save
this and also the name will change
now when this is done the next step is
to add thread groups
right click on first jmeter here and
select the add option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group the thread
group refers to the users that are used
or created or needed to run this test so
let's name this thread group to be j
meter
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it in the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's hits
third there is also a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
choose the test to run infinite number
of times
there is also scheduler here that will
help you schedule the start time and the
tests end time
for now let's leave everything to be one
only next step is to go to first jmeter
and again to go to add in the box that
appears select samplers you can see all
types of requests that jmeter can work
on
for now we will choose the simplest of
them all let's choose the http request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
so let's make it a little easy let's
rename it to be home pages
here in the server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip
let's pick a website let's go to the
simply learn website copy the url from
here
come back to the j meter window and
paste it in the server name box keep in
mind we don't need to give http or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the http request
case
then in the path dialog box since we
have to access the route page we will
leave a forward slash there
now when our http test is ready we will
perform the test on it
to determine what the result of the test
will be we need to add some more test
elements we shall again right click on
first j meter go to the listener options
then in the box we can check the
different type of reports that jmeter
provides us
for now we shall select two of these
let's choose view results in table
and the view results tree
now save the test and run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
the green button here to run second you
can go to this run option and choose run
the test and the third way is you can
right click on first j meter and choose
to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the results of the test
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be 1 there's just one entry
in both the results now let's try one
more thing we shall go to j meter and
change the number of threads and the
loop count
let's make the number of threads to be
around 10 and also the loop count to be
and now run the test
after running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and the same happens in
the case of view results entry
since we have increased the number of
users and the loop count we can see the
test being performed accordingly
since the loop count now was 10 so for
each user the test will run 10 times
and here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed and the status of each hit
onto our website link
let's get started with what is
performance testing
so performance testing is one of the
most important phases of any product
launch as it verifies and validates the
overall product performance this testing
can be done in different forms depending
upon the resource availability and the
type and volume of the user base
the main agenda behind conducting
performance testing on any product is to
make sure that the product's performance
is as expected before it gets launched
into the market so performance testing
is the process of testing a software
application under a specific workload
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability reliability
scalability and resource usage of a
software application under a particular
workload
the main purpose of performance testing
is to identify and eliminate performance
bottlenecks in the software application
performance testing mainly focuses on
three factors of a software program
first one is the speed
here it identifies whether the response
of the application is fast or not then
comes scalability where the maximum user
load is determined and the third one is
stability where the stability of the
application is checked under various
workloads
now we know what is performance testing
let us understand why if we need
performance testing
the only concern of a software system is
not features and functionality the
response time reliability resource and
scalability are also important factors
so the goal of performance testing is
not to find bugs but to eliminate
performance glitches
performance testing is performed to help
the stakeholders with information about
the application concerning the
application speed stability and
scalability furthermore performance
testing reveals what needs to be
improved before the product goes into
the market if there is no performance
testing the software might suffer from
issues such as running slow while
several users use it simultaneously
inconsistencies across different
operating systems and poor usability
performance testing determines if the
software or application meets speed
scalability and stability requirements
under expected workloads applications
sent to market with poor performance
metrics due to non-consistent or poor
performance testing are likely to bring
a bad reputation and fail to meet the
expected sales goals
now we know the relevance and need for
performance testing let's look at the
types of performance testing
so there are six types of performance
testing namely load testing stress
testing volume testing capacity testing
reliability testing and scalability
testing let's have a look at all the six
types of testing one after the other
so the first type is load testing load
testing is a type of performance testing
where the application is tested for its
performance on normal and peak usage
an application's performance is checked
concerning its response to the user
request and its availability to respond
consistently with an accepted endurance
on different user loads
here the main consideration is the
maximum load the application can hold
before the application starts behaving
abruptly
then another consideration is regarding
how much data the database can handle
before the system crashes the second
type of performance testing is stress
testing
stress testing is a type in which
different ways to break the system are
found that is how much load a system can
sustain
stress testing has an incremental
approach where the load is increased
gradually the test is started with the
load for which the application has
already been tested then more load is
added slowly to stress the system
the point at which we start seeing
servers not responding to the request is
considered the breaking point
here the major considerations are the
maximum load to a system can sustain
before it breaks down then how is the
system broken down and how will the
system be able to recover once it has
crashed
we also see in how many ways a system
can break and which are the weak nodes
that are to be kept in mind while
handling the unexpected load moving
forward the next type is volume testing
volume testing is the type where the
performance of the system is checked
with respect to the volume of the data
to execute a volume test a huge volume
of data is entered into the database
this test can be incremental or steady
test in the incremental test the volume
of the data is increased gradually
generally with the application usage the
database size grows and it is necessary
to test the application against a heavy
database if we consider an example let's
say there is a website of college having
small amounts of data to store initially
but after 5-10 years the data stored in
the database of the website is much more
and has become huge
now comes the fourth type of performance
testing the capacity testing
so capacity testing is a type of testing
where the application is checked for its
capability to meet the business volumes
capacity testing is generally done for
future prospects
here the main concerns are if the
application would be able to support the
future load
if the environment is capable of
standing the upcoming increase the load
and what are the additional resources
required to make the environment capable
enough
capacity testing helps in determining
how many uses or transactions of a given
web application is capable of supporting
and will perform well during this
testing resources such as processor
capacity
network bandwidth memory usage disk
capacity etc are considered and altered
to meet the goal
to consider an excellent example of
capacity testing we can see the case of
online banking moving forward the next
type of testing is the reliability
testing
reliability testing is a type in which
the application is verified if the
application would be normal again after
an abnormal state
it estimates the time that the system
would take to return to its normal state
to understand the concept let's say
there is an online trading site that
experiences some failure and because of
which the users are not able to buy or
sell shares at a certain point of the
day but after a couple of hours they
were able to operate their shares and
the application became normal this is
when it can be said that the application
is reliable and can recover from its
abnormal state the last type of testing
is scalability testing scalability
testing is a type where the application
is determined if it would be able to
scale up whenever needed
the need for scaling up comes when there
is an increase in user load now when we
have learned the types of performance
testing we must learn the process of
performance testing
so the process of performance testing is
divided into eight parts that is
requirement gathering selection of tools
performance test plan performance test
development performance test modeling
execution of test test result analysis
report now let's have a look at all of
these processes one after the other the
first step in the process is requirement
gathering the requirements are
identified and gathered from the clients
by the performance team this includes
getting information on the applications
architecture technologies database used
intended users functionality application
usage test requirement hardware and
software requirements etc the second
step in the process is selection of
tools
after the previous step poc or proof of
concept is done with the available tools
the proof of concept is a sort of
demonstration of real-time activity but
in a limited sense
the list of available tools depends on
the tool's cause the protocol that the
application is using the technologies
used to build the application the number
of users we were simulating for the test
etc now the third step
the third step is the performance test
plan in reference to the above two steps
test planning and designing are
conducted the process of test planning
involves information on how the
performance test is going to take place
like the test environment workload
hardware etc moving forward the fourth
step is performance test development in
this step the use cases for the
identified functionalities are created
these use cases are shared with the
client for their approval
once the clients approve the use case
the script development begins these
scripts are validated against several
different users and parallel to script
creation the performance team sets up
the test environment the performance
team also takes care of metadata through
scripts if the client does not take up
that activity so the next step is
performance test modeling
performance load model is created for
the test execution this step aims to
validate whether the given performance
metrics are achieved during the test or
not then the sixth step is execution of
tests the scenario is designed according
to the load model in controller or
performance center initially the tests
are not executed with maximum users that
are in the load model the test execution
is done in incremental order let's say
there are thousand users then the
scenario will begin testing from 100
then go to 250 then 350 and so on it
will gradually increase and go up to
1000 users
the next step is the seventh step in our
process
that is the test result analysis
the test results are the most important
deliverable for the performance tester
this is where we can prove the return on
investment and productivity that a
performance testing effort can provide
what makes the result analysis process
more effective is that we must have a
unique and meaningful name for every
test result which will help us
understand the test purpose in the test
summary certain things must be included
like the reason for failure how the
performance of the application changes
regarding the previous runs it is also a
good practice to make a result summary
after each test run so that the analysis
results are not compiled every single
time the results are referred then the
final and the last step in performance
testing process is the report the test
results should be simplified so that
conclusion is clearer and should not
create any derivation
the development team needs more
information on analysis comparison of
results and details of how the results
were obtained the test report is
considered to be good if it's brief
descriptive and to the point
now that we know the performance testing
the next important topic to discuss is
the understanding of performance testing
metrics
the first is processor usage which
refers to the amount of time the
processor spends executing the non-idle
threads second metric is memory usage
memory use is the amount of physical
memory available to the processor on a
computer system the third metric is test
time which is the amount of time the
disk is busy in executing read or write
request the fourth metric is the
bandwidth that shows the bits per second
used by a network interface moving
forward the next metric is the private
bytes it is the number of bytes a
process has allocated that can be shared
amongst the other processes
these are used to measure memory leaks
and usage then comes the committed
memory this is the amount of virtual
memory used
then the next metric we have is the
response time it is the time between
when the user enters a request to time
to the first character of the response
is received
next metric is the throughput it is the
rate at which a computer or a network
receives request per second moving
forward the next metric is the hit
ratios the hit ratios are concerned with
the number of sql statements that are
handled by caged data instead of
expensive input output operations
and the last metric in our list is the
top weights these are monitored to
determine what wait times can be cut
down to make the data retrieval faster
from memory apart from this some metrics
like the rollback segment garbage
collection thread counts heads per
second cpu interruption per second disk
q length etc now when we know almost
everything that is needed regarding
performance testing it is very important
to know the tools that make performance
testing possible here are the top five
performance testing tools in the market
today the first tool we have is the load
runner or hp load runner as the name
suggests the load runner is great when
it comes to handling a large amount of
users for testing
the second tool in our list is web load
web load is one of the best testing
tools for stress and load testing the
next tool in our list is load ui load ui
is a great testing tool to map the
scalability and speed of the target
product the fourth tool in our list is
new load it is one of the fastest
testing tools with a speed of around 10
times the traditional testing tools that
are integrated seamlessly into our
existing software with a wide array of
tests the last tool in our list is the
apache j meter apache j meter is one of
the best and most used testing tools in
the market right now it is highly
capable of creating a large number of
virtual users working on web server
moving forward we shall talk about
jmeter and understand why jmeter is
preferred over all the other performance
testing tools in the market so moving
forward let's see what jmeter is
j meter or apache j meter is an open
source software that is 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance
jmeter is originally designed for
testing web applications but has since
expanded to other test functions to
understand the concept of jmeter let us
assume that someday your team leads tell
you to perform performance testing on
some website like facebook or google.com
for 100 users
what would be the first thing comes to
your mind do you think it's practically
possible to arrange 100 people with
computers and access to internet and
accessing the same website now just
imagine the infrastructure requirement
when this testing has to be done for 10
000 users this is when a need for
software like jmeter arises so what
jmeter does is it actually simulates
it will simulate the real user's
behavior and perform load tests on
server group of servers network or
object
now let's have a look at some reasons
why gmeter is used for load testing we
have divided these reasons into six
parts
the first one is it's free of cost
second one is performance testing of
applications next one platform
independent the fourth one is
customizable fifth is recording and
playback and finally sixth is the
community support let's see all of these
one after the other the first reason we
have is free of cost one of the main
deciding factors in any software is its
cost normally a software can range from
high as six to seven figures per license
here jmeter is free of cost very
intuitive and has all the possibilities
you need to automate your work then the
second reason is performance testing of
applications the application is used to
perform performance testing on different
types of applications like web
applications web services ldap database
and shell scripts jmeter can conduct
load and performance tests for many
different servers and server types web
http and https database via jdbc ldap
and jms the third reason is
platform independence
jmeter is written and developed using
java to run on any environment or
workstation that accepts java virtual
machine for example windows linux mac
etc the next reason we have is that the
jmeter is customizable since jmeter is
an open source application it enables
developers to customize
whenever needed jmeter has a
comprehensive and user-friendly
graphical user interface
parameters are easy to define and
understand scripting is simpler and
clearer and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive also one screen shows
everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis
the samplers are highly customizable
when determining which request to be
sent to the host however samplers don't
enable full control of test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and playback
the application provides record and
playback options enabled with the drag
and drop feature making the application
faster and easier the next and the last
reason on our list is incredible
community support jmeter is an open
source tool with a brilliant community
that keeps adding features and supports
users who run into issues and problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on j meter also having an open
source tool ensures that it keeps
getting better and is always in line
with users needs and requirements
finally let's have a look into the demo
that shows the working of j meter
so the first step is we shall go to the
apache j meter folder
in that folder go inside the bin folder
and select the
jmeter.pat file
double click on this file
this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the test
plan elements are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
i have renamed this test plan as
performance testing
now the first step is to add thread
group
right click on the performance testing
go to add
then go to thread or users
and select thread group
let's name this as perform
here the thread group refers to the used
or created users or needed to run this
test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after
there is an error you can choose it the
way you want then there is this number
of threads where you can choose the
number of users you want then there is a
ramp up period in seconds option that
states the time gap between the users
hits third there is a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
also choose the test to run in finite
times there is also a scheduler here to
help you schedule the start time and the
test end time let's make the number of
threads to b2 and let's make the loop
count to be 100
the next step is to add an http request
for that right click on the thread group
go to add option and go to the sampler
option in the menu that appears select
the http request option here on the
screen there is a server name or ipbox
we have to give the server name or the
ip in that let's pick up a website and
place the link in the box we shall use
the simply learns website here go to
simplylearn's website and copy the url
from here then come back to the jmeter
window and paste it onto the server name
box keep in mind we don't need to give
the http or https since these are
protocols which will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case
then in the path dialog box we will
leave the forward slash there since we
have to access the root page
and let's rename this http request as
simple now
to get results we shall add listeners
listeners are something that are used to
provide the outputs of a load test there
are different types of listeners present
in j meter and many may be added using
plugins we will use three different
listeners here to have an idea about the
representation that the jmeter provides
for that right click on the thread group
then go to the add select listener
option and go to the view results entry
option then again right click on the
listener option and choose graph results
and for the third listener again right
click and select the view results in the
table option
now it's time to run the test
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
on the green button here to run second
is you can go to the run option and
choose the run the test and the third
way you can right click on the first
jmeter and choose to run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
first we will have to save this j meter
test and then we shall go on to check
the results of the test
here in the view results tree we can see
the test being run
the same in the case of graph results we
can see the throughput option then we
can also see the time the test has been
executing since we had put the threads
to 2 and the loop count 200 so the test
will run for a while
we can check the view results in the
table we can see different performance
testing metrics on the screen you can
see the thread name label sample time
per second bytes sort bytes and the
latency
and in the tree option when we click on
the test we can see a lot of information
appearing on the screen these are again
several performance testing metrics and
in the graph results we can see the
graph coming up on the screen now which
represents the test taking place with
respect to the ip address thread and
loop counts so what jmeter exactly does
is creates a request and sends it to the
server once it receives the service
response it collects them and visualizes
those details in a chart or graph after
that it processes the service response
and finally it generates the test
results in several formats such as text
xml json so that the tester can analyze
the data let's get started with what is
load testing
load testing is a type of performance
testing that determines an application's
behavior when a large number of users
access the application together here
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability and reliability
of the software application under a
particular workload the testing
determines a system's performance
according to real life conditions to
give you a better idea let's say you
have a printer so you want to test a
printer by transferring large number of
documents for printing or
test a mail server with thousands of
concurrent users or to test a word
processor by making a change in a large
volume of data this helps to know
whether the existing infrastructure is
capable of running the application or
not
load testing checks how much load can a
system handle the testing identifies the
limitations due to hardware like cpu
maximization network bottleneck memory
limitation etc and it also identifies
the issues in software configuration
such as web server application server
database server etc
it helps to identify the maximum
operating capability of an
application and checks the performance
of the application under different load
conditions of system components and
database components load testing is
conducted to determine the number of
concurrent users that an application can
support without performance
deterioration the response time of each
transaction of an application and the
network delay between the client request
and server response are also checked
load testing proves itself very
significant when it comes to determining
user demands and satisfaction several
tools make load testing possible such as
apache geometer web load load ui load
runner neo load load ninja etc
here in this session
we shall be using jmeter for load
testing
so jmeter or apache geometer is open
source software that is 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance
performance testing means testing a web
application against heavy load multiple
and concurrent user traffic
it was originally designed for testing
web applications but has since expanded
to other test functions to simplify
let's assume that someday your team
leads tell you to perform performance
testing for some websites like yahoo.com
or google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing that comes
to your mind do you think it's
practically possible to arrange 100
people with 100 computers and access the
internet and accessing the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for 1000 or 10 000 users
this is when we need a software like
jmeter
so what jmeter does is it simulates it
will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load testing on a server group
of servers network or object next
let's have a look at some reasons why
jmeter is used for load testing
we have divided these reasons into six
parts
it is free of cost performance testing
of applications
platform independent customizable
recording and playback and community
support
now let's see all of these one after the
other the first one free of cost
one of the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost normally a software
can range from high as six to seven
figures per license here jmeter is free
of cost very intuitive and has all the
possibilities you need to automate your
work
the next one is performance testing of
applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different
applications like web applications web
servers ldap database and shell scripts
jmeter can conduct load and performance
test for many different server types
like web http and https database via
jdbc ldap and gms
the third important reason is it's
platform independent in nature
jmeter is written and developed using
java programming language to run on any
environment or workstation that accepts
a java virtual machine for example
windows linux mac etc
the next reason we have is j meter is
highly customizable since jmeter is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize it whenever
needed jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to define and
understand scripting is simpler and
cleaner and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive
also one screen shows you everything you
need the script the scenario and the
analysis the samplers are highly
customizable when determining which
request is to be sent to a host however
samplers don't enable full control of
test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and playback the application
provides record and playback options
enabled with the drag and drop features
making the application faster and easier
the next and the last reason in our list
is incredible community support jmeter
is an open source tool with a brilliant
community that keeps adding features and
supports users who run into issues and
problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on jmeter
also having an open source tool ensures
it keeps getting better and always in
line with users needs and requirements
now after we know about j meter and the
reasons to use sheameter let's
understand the process to perform load
testing with a hands-on demo the only
thing that is kept in mind before this
demo is we must have a fully functional
jmeter on our system and by now we know
that jmeter can be used in any operating
system like linux windows mac os and
ubuntu in this demo we shall look into
both the graphical user and
non-graphical user interface mode of
load testing
so the first step is we shall go to the
apache geometer folder
in that folder go inside the bin folder
and select the jmeter.pad file double
click on this file this might take a
while and then the jmeter window will
open on the screen the home window is
divided into two sections on the left
side the elements of the test plan are
added and on the right side all the
configurations of the element that are
added as we are on the test plan element
we can see the configurations of the
scene here the test plan is like a place
or a container where all the elements we
will use to perform this test will be
stored all the requests the listeners
and everything will be stored here so
the first step is to add listeners for
that go to test plan right click on the
test plan go to add then go to threads
users and select a thread group
the test group refers to the users that
are used or created or needed to run
this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
in seconds option that states the time
gap between the users hits then the
third one there is a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
also choose the test to run infinite
times there is also a scheduler here to
help you schedule the start time and the
test and time for now let's leave
everything to be only one
the next step is to add the http request
for that right click on the thread group
and go to the option and go to the
sampler option
and go to the http request option here
on the screen there is a server name or
ipbox we have to give the server name or
the ip in that let's pick a website and
place the link in that box we shall use
the simply learns website here go to
simply learn's website and copy the url
from there
now we have copied the simply learns url
now let's come back to the jmeter window
and paste it in the server name box keep
in mind that we don't need to give up
the http or https since these are
protocols which will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case
so this is what i was talking about
now let's rename this name as simply
moving forward let's create one more
http request
for that again right click on the thread
group select samplers and select http
request and go to simply learns website
again and there we have the resource
link go to that link and copy the url
then place that url in the server or ip
address box
we shall remove the http from that link
and add from the end cut the resource
part and paste it in the path box there
here we will rename the http request as
resources
moving forward to increase a load a
little bit more we shall use one more
http
so this time we shall add one more http
request again right click on the threads
group go to the samples option and
select the http request option again to
add one more link to the server and ip
address go to simplylands website go to
the corporate training link now copy the
url and go back to the jmeter window and
paste that url in the ip box
now cut the corporate training part from
the link and paste it to the other path
box
we shall again rename this http request
box as corporate now let's save this
file
in the save dialog box let's name it as
load testing dot jmx
now to get the results we shall add
listeners listeners are something that
is used to provide the outputs of the
load test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins the listener
we will use here is the tree as it is
comparatively easy to interpret for that
right click on the thread group then go
to add select listener option and we go
for the view results in three option now
it's time to run the test and check the
load for running the test there are
three simple ways first you can simply
click on the green button here to run
second is you can go to the run option
and choose the run test and the third is
the way you can right click on first
geometer and then choose run let's
simply choose the green button and run
the test after we run the test we shall
go to the check the results of the test
in the view results entry section
we can see the green symbol that states
the test has successfully completed
since we had left all the values to be
one in the beginning that's why there is
just one test for each http request now
let's increase the load and let's change
some numbers let's make the number of
threads to be 10 ramp up the pds to be 2
and the loop count to be 10.
now let's run the test again with the
green button after running the test we
shall see the results in the tree and
see the testing being performed since we
have increased the number of users and
ramp up the periods and the loop count
we can see the test being performed
accordingly since the loop count now was
10 for each user the test will run 10
times so here on the screen we can see
the time taken and the number of tests
being performed on the status of each
hit onto the website this is how you
perform load testing in graphical user
mode now perform the same test in
non-graphical user mode we shall remove
the listener so let's remove the view
results in tree
after this we will go to the command
prompt then in the command prompt we
shall put the pin folder path in the
apache geometer folder let's go to the
bin folder and copy the location from
here now paste the path in the command
prompt and execute it
once that is done the next step is to
put the command prompt for jmeter load
testing this command has got three parts
the first part is the hyphen n hyphen t
and hyphen l here the hyphen n
represents the non graphical user
interface mode hyphen t is used to
specify the location of the
test script hyphen l is used to specify
the location of our output result now go
to the location where our jmx file is
stored let's search for the load
testing.jmx file
copy the path and paste it in the
command prompt hyphen t
in the link
that we paste towards the end make sure
that you add the name of the filebit.gmx
now go back to the folder and make a dot
csv file make an excel spreadsheet and
rename it with dot csv extension
now copy this path and go back to the
command prompt and paste it after the
hyphen l in the path don't forget to add
the name of the csv file towards the end
then execute the command and wait for
the command to end
after the command is successfully run
you can see that the tree is
successfully created and towards the end
of that execution you can see that the
message is the end of the run
now you can go back to the folder and
open the loadtesting.csv file in that
file you can see the entire test result
has been generated
this shows that the command has been
successfully executed and the
load testing is successful in the non
graphical mode without any errors this
is what we had in this demo we saw the
load testing in graphical user interface
and non-graphical user interface mode
to have a better picture we use
dashboards dashboards include several
graphs that explain the working of the
website link we use in the http request
the dashboard generator is a modular
extension of jmeter its default behavior
is to read and process samples from a
csv file to generate html files it
generates the report and at the end of
the load test are on demand the
dashboard reports provide metrics like
the apd-ex or application performance
index the dashboard also provides a
statistics table response time over time
response times percentiles over time
active threads over time and response
times and percentiles we shall learn
about dashboards and more in the
forthcoming videos in this video we
learned how critical is load testing in
the software testing process and how it
ensures high user satisfaction a
successful load testing will help to
release high quality software if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
let's get started with what an api is
we often come across this term while
reading any technical blog or magazine
an api or application programming
interface is a programming code that
enables data transmission between one
software product and another it is an
intermediary software allowing two
applications to communicate with each
other
to understand api even better let's take
an example
for example you're booking a flight
for that you will begin with searching
flights online concerning your
destination departure return dates and
many more filters
to make all these choices you interact
with the airline's website and access
their database and see if there are any
seats available on those states and what
the cost might be
while you're doing all this from the
time to begin to the time you finish
booking your tickets you're doing that
with the help of an api
to simplify it even more it can be said
that whenever we use an application on
our mobile phone the application
connects to the internet and sends data
to the server the server then retrieves
the data interprets it performs
necessary actions and sends it back to
our phone
the application then interprets the data
and presents the information we wanted
in a readable way
this is what an api is so that means
each time we use an application like
facebook send an instant image
check weather on our phone or make some
specific choices while online shopping
we use an api now when we have a good
idea about what an api is let's look at
another major thing before going on to
the hands-on demo that is why we use
jmeter for api testing
apache g-meter is an open source
software and it is used to simulate
loads of various scenarios and output
performance data in several ways
including csv and xml files and graphs
we know that the apache g meter is 100
pure java application so it is available
on every os that supports java 6 or
later
some of these specific reasons what
makes jmeter a perfect fit for api
testing are
jmeter enables fast api testing it
performs quick scope tests and enables
load and stress testing
then as we know it is an open source
tool and supports load testing and
stress testing
it has a lot of plugins and extensions
jmeter can be used across several
platforms and can use various
programming languages
now we know about api basics and why we
use jmeter for its testing
it is the right time to see the process
of api testing in jmeter
to download jmeter you can go to the
apache jmeter website and download the
file
to know the entire downloading process
and installing jmeter you can check our
jmeter download and installation video
in our jmeter playlist
moving on i have my jmeter installed i
will go to the apache j meter folder go
into the bin folder and open the batch
file
this might take a while and then the
gmeter window will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections
on the left side all the elements of the
test plan are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the scene
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward right click on the
first jmeter here and select the add
option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error or you can choose it the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
in seconds option that states the time
gap between the user hits
third there is a loop count where you
can choose how many times the test will
run for the number of users
you can also choose the test to run in
finite times
there is also a scheduler here to help
you schedule the time for starting the
test and the time for ending the test
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
now for some sample apis go to your
browser and search for some sample rest
api for testing
in this we will go to the first link
that is
req res dot n or request response dot n
we will create and run get
post
put and delete rest api request in
jmeter in the demo
here in this link we have all get post
put delete apis
so we shall choose the first link here
list users
here we have the link request open this
link in the new tab
then we have got the url for this api
copy this url and go to the jmeter
window
then in the jmeter window right click
thread group and go to add
in the box that appears select samplers
you can see all types of requests that
jmeter can work on we shall choose the
http request here you will have to give
the address to some home pages or
websites
here in the server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip so
here we shall paste the get api request
url
in the protocol box we shall put the
https
if in the url the protocol would have
been http then we would have left this
box empty
in the url we shall put the url link
remember that we do not put any slashes
here and that anything after the url
would be put in the path
so we shall remove the path from the url
and put it in the path box
then we shall take part from the
question mark and use it to give
parameters
since it is the get api we will have to
give parameters we will add the name in
the parameters and give the name as page
and value as 2.
in this http request drop down we can
see all the different types of http
requests that jmeter accepts for now we
shall leave it to be get since we are
using the get api and also let's name
this http request as get api now when
our http request is ready we shall
perform the test on it
to determine what the results of the
test will be we need to add some more
test elements we shall again right click
on the thread group go to the listener
options then in the box we can check the
different types of reports that jmeter
provides us for now we shall select two
of these let's choose view results tree
and the view results in the table
now save the test
i will save the test with the name api
testing
and finally let's run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways
first you can simply click the green
button on the run
second you can go to this run option and
choose to run the test
and the third way is you can right click
on the first j meter and choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the result of the test
let's go to the view results stream here
we can see the green status that shows
the test was successful
and the view results in a table we can
see again the status is green
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be one there is just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing
we shall go to the thread group and
change the number of threads to be 10
and run the test again
after running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed
and same happens in the case of view
results in table
now in the view results tree we can
click on a request and see different
information here we can see the sample
start load time latency error etc
same in the view results in table
you can see all such information in a
tabular format
you can also see the response data here
this is the same data as it was there
when we copied the url from the browser
you can furthermore check the response
headers and the request that was placed
now we are done with the get api request
let's add the second request that is the
post request
again add a http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group then come
back to the browser window and click on
the post api option
then
open the request url in the new window
then go to this window copy the url and
come back to the jmeter window
first let's rename this http request as
post api
then let's paste the url in the server
name or ipbox again let's put http in
the protocol box
address in the server or ip address box
and path in the path box
and in this http request drop down
select the post option this time
then let's go to the parameter part here
select the body data option
and we shall have to add body now
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
[Music]
come back to the jmeter window and paste
the body here
here you can check some advanced
settings also in case you need them
for now
since this is just a demo we shall keep
it really simple
so let's run this
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
then we shall save the test and run it
now you can see the two tests are here
since the thread count is one let's make
the thread count to be 10 again let's
see what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running a required number of times
that is 20 times again i can see
information about different requests
that include different parameters like
latency errors etc
now let's move on to our third api
request that is the put request
go back to the browser and click on put
request
open the request in the new tab
copy the url and come back to the jmeter
window make a new http request by going
to the sampler in the thread group
first
let's rename this http request as put
api
then let's paste the url in the server
name
or ipbox
again let's put http in the protocol box
address the server or ip address box and
path in the path box
and in the http request drop down select
the put option this time here also we
shall have to add body data
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
coming back to jmeter window select the
body data option and we shall have to
add body now and paste the body here we
shall go to our two listeners and clear
the previous output make the thread
count to be one and then we shall save
the test and run it
now you can see the three tests here
since the thread count is one here by
clicking on the api request we can check
a lot of data like the response body and
response headers and same in the case of
view results in the table you can see
the data in a tabular format
let's make the thread count to be 10 and
again see what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running a required number of times
and here i can see information about
different requests
now let us add our last api request that
is the delete request
go back to the browser and click on the
delete request
open the request in the new tab copy the
url and come back to the jmeter window
make a new http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this http request as
delete api
then let's paste the url in the server
name or ipbox again
let's put http in the protocol box
address in the server or ip address box
and path in the path box
and in this http request drop down
select the delete option this time
here there is nothing to be added in the
parameters section so let's go to the
two listeners and clear what all is
there
then save this test and run it
since we did not make the number of
threads one this time we can see the
test running n number of times
we can see the information of any api
request by just clicking on it
let's get started with what is script
recording record testing in j meter
helps testers to record and run their
activity against test targets it is a
type of automated testing but for
multiple users the test script is
designed to record such scenarios the
proxy server allows jmeter to watch and
record user activity while browsing web
applications with a normal web browser
when we talk about proxy it is a
component that is present between you
and the remote server let us say that
you want to record web browser
interactions when james data starts
acting like a proxy this is when jmeter
script recording is used script
recording is one of the advanced and
impressive ways to figure out and
eliminate the complexity of browser
interactions and software testing now
when we know what script recording is
and how it is relevant let's look into
how to do it in jmeter but before that
let's check the prerequisites of script
recording in jmeter there are three
major prerequisites first is having j
meter installed in your system the
second requirement is having java
installed in your system the third and
final requirement is having mozilla
firefox in your system now let us have a
look at the hands-on demo of how to
perform script recording in jmeter so
the first step is we shall go to the
apache jmeter folder in that folder we
will go into bin folder and then select
the jmeter.bat folder let us double
click on that this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen the home window is divided
into two sections on the left side all
the test plan elements are added and on
the right side all the configurations of
the elements are added as we are on the
test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here you can
think of the test plan like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored all the requests all the
listeners and everything will be stored
here now the first step is to add thread
group so for that right click on the
thread group select add and from add go
to threads or users and in that select
thread group here the thread group
refers to the users it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period and second
option that states the time gap between
the user hits third there is a loop
count where you can choose how many
number of times the test will run for a
number of users you can also choose the
test to run for infinite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the tests
end time the next step is to add an http
request for that right click on the
thread group go to the add option and
now go to the sampler option select the
http request option here there is a
server name or ipbox we have to give the
server name or ip in that let us pick a
website and place the link in the box we
shall use the simply learns website here
go to simply learn's website and copy
the url from here then come back to the
jmeter window and paste it in the server
name box keep in mind that we don't need
to give http or https since these are
protocols that will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case then in the
path dialog box we will leave a forward
slash there since we have to access the
root page now the next step is to add
the http test script recorder for that
right click on the test plan then go to
non-test elements and select the http
test script recorder option the window
on the screen shows several options here
we can see the start option to begin the
test then there is a box that has the
port number you can make this number
whatever you like i'll put this number
as one two three four for now then let's
go back to the simply learns website and
go to the resources page then come back
to the jmeters window and rename the
recording controller as resources now
let us add another recording controller
so that jmeter works like a proxy with
the help of https test script recorder
then again go back to the resources page
that we just opened and scroll down a
little bit here we can see several
technologies and several other links in
those links you can select any one of
the links i will select digital
marketing here then go back to the
jmeter window and rename the recording
controller as digital marketing then
finally let's add a recording controller
for the home page and rename it as
simply learn's home page so now we can
see that we have a thread group here
then there is a http request where we
have simply learn website in the server
name then there are three recording
controllers one for the resources the
second for digital marketing and a third
one for home page and last we have a
http test script recorder here i will
rearrange the recording controllers in
sequence putting the simply learns home
page controller on the top and then
placing the resources finally digital
marketing recording controller now let
us open mozilla firefox in our system go
to the general option here and scroll
down to the network settings in the
network settings option select settings
in the window that appears select the
manual proxy configuration here we shall
put the port number for now i will put
the port number as 1234 in this box
here in the http proxy we have localhost
and we have selected to use this proxy
for ftp and https and then click on ok
now go back to the apache jmeter folder
and now we shall use this apache jmeter
temporary root ca file which is a
security certificate file so coming back
to the mozilla firefox window go to the
options tab and in this tab i will type
certificates and here we shall select
view certificates in the window that
opens let us import the security
certificate from jmeter folder here we
shall select these two boxes so that the
proxy server can access the website that
we shall enter here in the browser and
then select ok coming back to the jmeter
window let us add some listeners to get
the results listeners are something that
are used to provide the outputs of a
test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins for adding
listeners right click on http test
script recorder for adding listeners
right click on the http test script
recorder then go to add option and then
go to listeners option and then add view
results tree now let us add one more
listener in the same way we shall add
view results entry now in the http test
script recorder in the target controller
option save the target controller here
in the drop down select the simply learn
home page option as we will begin the
script recording for the home page
finally let's start the test by clicking
here click on ok now go back to the
mozilla browser and here let us open the
simply learns home page now come back to
the jmeter window go to the home page
recording controller you can see the
homepage controller has started as you
can see the homepage controller has
started recording the scripts that are
being performed these are the tasks that
are performed on the client side to the
server side now we can check both the
listeners that we have put to see what
all functions are working fine and what
all are not all the tasks from the time
that we have entered to simplylearn.com
in our browser are recorded in this home
page controller to take the test further
go to the test script recorder and stop
the test now here in the target
controller select the second controller
that is the resources controller now
start the test again select ok go to
simply learns website select resources
after opening the resources link go back
to the jmeter window and now in the
resources controller you can see what
all events are recorded from the client
side to the server side once we click on
the resources link now again in the two
listeners you can check all the scripts
and tests are successful or have failed
now for our last recording controller go
back to the test script recorder and
stop the test now here in the target
controller select the third option that
is the digital marketing now here in the
target controller select the third
option that is digital marketing start
the test and select ok now get back to
the mozilla firefox window go to
resources go to digital marketing after
digital marketing link has opened go
back to the jmeter window and now in the
digital marketing controller you can see
what all events are recorded from the
client side to the server side once we
click on that link i guess this is
taking a while you can see all steps
coming under the recording controller
and then you can also see the two
listeners some of the tests are being
successful and some are not we can sum
this entire process as a way of
communicating between the server and the
client with a proxy server help in this
case the proxy server is rj meter that
is why it was able to record all the
steps that are happening while we were
performing any task this is how we can
perform the jmeter script testing in few
simple steps now when you are done with
the proxy server do not forget to go
back to your browser and change your
network settings back to normal that is
go to the settings select use system
proxy settings and that's how it is done
in this complete course we will learn
everything that we need to know to excel
in jenkins devops we have matthews chida
nad and anuj to guide us through this
journey we shall begin with having a
basic understanding of devops with a
short animated video after that we shall
dive deeper and understand what devops
is and its relevance in the present
scenario in this process we shall also
learn about the ci cd pipeline and how
it is important in the process of
automation
finally we shall learn what jenkins is
its relevance and how we can install it
in this process we will also see several
hands-on demos helping us understand the
entire process more effectively
after we have a fair amount of knowledge
regarding jenkins we will look at some
of the jenkins interview questions that
will increase your chances to crack any
jenkins interview
so before we begin make sure that you
have subscribed to our youtube channel
and don't forget to click on the bell
icon so you never miss an update from
simply learn
now without any further ado let's begin
with our animated introduction
meet tim
tim builds a robot in his lab
a climate controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner mia's house mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises
the change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction
mia is now really annoyed and she has a
lot to correct and it seems to her as
though tim didn't really do much
this wall between them leaves a poor
robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall tim and
miana work together in a common space
tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as and when a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product they
develop a common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective tim would be the developer
while mia the operations their union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these tim first puts down a
plan
in terms of software this could mean
deciding on the modules and the
algorithms to use
once he has the plan he now codes the
plan with tools such as git tim has a
repository for storing all the codes and
their different versions this is called
version control next this code is
fetched and made executable this is the
build stage tools such as gradle and
maven will sort this out now before
deployment the product is tested to
catch any bugs the most popular tool
automating testing is selenium once the
products are tested mia must deploy it
the deployed product is then
continuously configured to the desired
state
ansible puppet and docker are some of
the most common tools used that automate
these stages
now
every product is consciously monitored
in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this space and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage
and finally we have the core of the
devops lifecycle the integration stage
tools such as jenkins is responsible for
sending the code for build and test if
the code passes the tests it's further
sent for deployment this is called
continuous integration
giants such as amazon netflix target xc
and walmart have all adopted devops and
seen a considerable increase in delivery
and quality
in 2014 an hour of downtime for netflix
would cost it two hundred thousand
dollars
it became absolutely crucial that
netflix prepared themselves for any sort
of failure and so they took to the
devops approach and implemented it in
the most unique way they developed a
tool called simeon army this tool
created failures and automatically
deployed them in an environment that did
not affect the users
the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its divergence from the
traditional methods would devops be the
future hello this is matthew with simply
learn and today we're going to go
through and introduce you to devops
we're going to go through a number of
key elements today the first two will be
reviewing models that you're already
probably using for delivering solutions
into your company and the most popular
one is waterfall followed by agile then
we'll look at devops and how devops
differs from the two models and how it
also borrows and leverages the best of
those models we'll go through each of
the phases that are used in typical
devops delivery and then the tools used
within those phases to really improve
the efficiencies within devops finally
we'll summarize the advantages that
devops brings to you and your teams so
let's go through waterfall so waterfall
is a traditional delivery model that's
been used for many decades for
delivering solutions not just i.t
solutions and digital solutions but even
way before that it has its history that
goes back to world war ii so waterfall
is a model that is used to capture
requirements and then cascade each key
deliverable through a series of
different stage gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution they build out
their applications to build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the actual code you'll
do manual testing you do ui testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and if the project has
been running for six months and they've
gone hey we need to change something
that means that we have to almost
restart the whole project it's very
expensive and it's very time consuming
also if you spend weeks and months away
from your clients and you deliver a
solution that they are only just going
to see after you spend a lot of time
working on it they could be pointing out
things that are in the actual final
application that they don't want or are
not implemented correctly or lead to
just general unhappiness the challenge
you then have is if you want to add back
in the client's feedback to restart the
whole waterfall cycle again so the
client will come back to you with a list
of changes and then you go back and you
have to start your programming and you
have to then start your testing process
again and just you're really adding in
lots of additional time into the project
so using the watford model companies
have soon come to realize that you know
the clients just aren't able to get
their feedback in quickly effectively
it's very expensive to make changes once
the teams have started working and the
requirement in today's digital world is
that solutions simply must be delivered
faster and this has led for a specific
change in agile and we start
implementing the agile model so the
agile model allows programmers to create
prototypes and get those prototypes to
the client with the requirements faster
and the client is able to then send the
requirements back to the programmer with
feedback this allows us to create what
we call a feedback loop we're able to
get information to the client and the
client can get back to the development
team much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the client the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
sprint and that typically a sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of sprint two and the client
says hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and they may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple sprints but when you go through
the sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually implement successfully into
their sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day to with the actual sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production environment it's only
been tested on the developer computers
and it's really hard when you're
actually running agile for the sprint
team to actually build out a solution
easily and effectively on their
computers to mimic the production
environment and the developers and the
operations team are running in separate
silos so you have your development team
running their sprint and actually
working to build out the features but
then when they're done at the end of
their sprint and they want to do a
release they kind of fling it over the
wall at the operations team and then
it's the operations team job to actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production service but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developer's test environment that
doesn't match the production environment
there may be a dependency that isn't
there there may be a link to an api that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these challenges that the
operations team are constantly faced
with and their challenge is that they
don't know how the code works so this is
where devops really comes in and let's
dig into how devops which is developers
and operators working together is the
key for successful continuous delivery
so devops is as an evolution of the
agile model the agile model really is
great for gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the ops team and the
dev team and so with devops what we're
doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production-like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that it's based on data so let's
step through the different phases of a
devops team so typically you'll see that
the devops team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
agile and what i'd like to point out at
time is that again agile and devops are
very closely related that agile devops
are closely related delivery models that
you can use with devops it's really just
extending that model with the key phases
that we have here so let's step through
each of these key phases so the first
phase is planning and this is where we
actually sit down with a business team
and we go through and understand what
their goals are the second stage is as
you can imagine and this is where it's
all very similar to agile is that the
coders actually start coding but they
typically they'll start using tools such
as git which is a distributed version
control software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as maven
and gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another pointer
here is that the tools that we're
listing here these are all open source
tools these are tools that any team can
start using we want to have tools that
control and manage the deployment of
code into the production environments
and then finally tools such as ansible
and chef will actually operate and
manage those production environments so
that when code comes to them that that
code is compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things i want to point out is
that these tools are open source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
but it's quite likely that you're
already using some of these tools today
you may already be using jenkins you may
already be using git but some of the
other tools really help you create a
fully scriptable environment so that you
can actually start scripting out your
entire devops tool set this really helps
when it comes to speeding up your
delivery because the more you can
actually script out of the work that
you're doing the more effective you can
be at running automation against those
scripts and the more effective you can
be at having a consistent experience so
let's step through this devops process
so we go through and we have a
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to make a release
well the first thing you want to do is
send out your files to the build
environment and you want to be able to
test the code that you've been created
because we're scripting everything in
our code from the actual unit testing
being done to the all the way through to
the production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the the scripting test it
can then be deployed and once it's out
to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases to agile
which is two weeks or four weeks
depending on your sprint cadence to
where you are today with devops where
you can actually be doing multiple
releases every single day so there are
some significant advantages and there
are companies out there that are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take any one of these companies such as
google google any given day will
actually process 50 to 100 new releases
on their website through their devops
teams in fact they have some great
videos on youtube that you can find out
on how their devops teams work netflix
is also a similar environment now what's
interesting with netflix is that netflix
have really fully embraced devops within
their development team and so they have
a devops team and netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on smart tvs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the devops team for netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all internet traffic on
any given day is from netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
devops can be when you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that devops has it's the actual time to
create and deliver software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to waterfall complexity and
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment you're improving the
communication between all your teams so
teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together and that
there is continuous integration and
continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer is constantly
being delighted welcome everyone to this
topic on continuous integration delivery
and deployment so this topic by
simplylearn is going to explain you that
what exactly is all about the continuous
integration process continuous
deployment and continuous delivery so
let's talk about these concepts one by
one so continuous integration isn't kind
of a process which is which comes up in
the first part right so first the
continuous integrations comes into the
picture then the continuous delivery and
the deployment comes into the part
so the main important component or the
main task which we primarily perform in
the continuous integration is all about
the build automations test executions
and merging in various branches so it's
nothing but the integration of the
source code from the each and individual
developers machines to a shared location
which we often call it as an kind of a
version control system so continuous
integration is integrating the source
code into the shared repositories and
then depending on the order triggers
once the changes are checked into the
version control system the automated
build test cases all these executions
can really happen now in the build
process and the test cases automation
it's going to validate that how the
source code is really working uh how the
compilation is going on how the test
cases are getting executed
so all these things are getting
validated during the execution of these
things now once the continuous
integration is successful we can not
assure give a hundred percent surety
that the code base is working fine
because it's just taking care of the
compilation and the test cases there
could be a possibility that some kind of
errors may also come up into the
production environment because those
test cases or those scenarios are not
being covered in the test cases so test
cases are very important aspect over
here because it's giving us the
authority whether we need to proceed
further or we need to halt there itself
so after the continuous integration the
next process which comes into the
picture is the automatic release to the
repository over here right so it's just
a kind of a mechanism where we will be
releasing the source code to the
artifacts we are uploading the artifacts
to the
particular component so that kind of
automation is available but that is also
happening when we are saying that yes
the test cases execution is successful
and we have to proceed further and at
the end it's nothing but the automated
deployment to the production environment
which we call it as an kind of
continuous deployment over here so these
are the overall process which we are
looking forward so that we will be able
to have an end to end automations going
on over here with the help of ci cd
automations
now continuous indications again the
build test merge these are the different
options which we do
so continuous integration is a kind of a
process a kind of a development process
which is being used by most of the
development teams nowadays that
eventually enables the developers to
merge their source code uh whatever the
changes or whatever the modifications
they are doing they can uh particular uh
you know like merge their source code
from their local systems to the central
repository so that after that with the
help of ci tools we can actually have
the build automations and the test cases
automation there so this is the reason
why we prefer the continuous integration
process because it depends on the basis
of our modifications that how the whole
build and test cases automations can
really happen here
now continuous integration is considered
as a very important process because of
the various reasons let's talk about
those reasons one by one the very first
one is that it avoids the merge
conflicts because if we frequently uh
sync back our source code from our
systems to the shared repository and the
same thing can be done by other
developers also so eventually it
definitely helps the different
developers to collaborate their source
code into a single shared repository and
that can really help you to avoid the
merge conflict situations because you
are always going to work on the latest
source code so the scope of merge
conflicts is not going to be there
it also helps us to decrease the need of
the code review because we are just
doing the uh collaboration frequently so
we don't require any person to be
sitting there and you know have
to perform a kind of a heavy duty code
review because uh that is something
which we can easily manage and we can
work with that so code review uh is
something which we can easily decrease
with the help of this continuous
integration process
uh it also speeds up the development
process yes definitely because
the developers can easily collaborate
with each other so from collaboration
perspective also it's beneficial for us
to do and that can really help us to see
that how easily we can integrate our
source code and that differs or that
basically helps us to go for the overall
mechanism and you know going for an
perfect automation process over here
so it also increases the overall
development process which needs to be
implemented during the ci process
next it also reduce the product backlog
because we are doing our changes
frequently into the repositories so uh
any kind of product backlog which is
there which is pending from long that is
also can be managed easily because it's
keep on you know reduce there so we keep
we keep on implementing our changes we
keep on implementing merging us
particular changes to the share
repository so that reduces the amount of
backlog which is available
now next thing is the continuous
delivery which is an automatic release
to the repositories here so what exactly
is in continuous delivery all about
so continuous delivery is a kind of a
practice that refers to the particular
uh building testing delivering
improvements to the software code so the
important part of continuous delivery is
that the code is always in the
deployable state so we are saying that
we are done with the delivery we are
ready with the delivery and whichever
environment whichever
particular server you want us to deploy
we are ready to do that so that is where
we call it as in continuous delivery so
we have our artifacts ready and whenever
is desired whenever we feel that we want
to do the deployments we want to proceed
further we will be able to do that with
the help of this process
so it's in kind of an end-to-end process
you do the belts you do the test cases
executions once the test case execution
is done once the testing is done then
you create an artifacts you create a
particular war files jar files er files
whatever the artifacts we have we
prepare that artifacts and then we
deliver it to a specific environment we
say that yes let's go with the delivery
let's make it into a particular state
where we will be able to deploy to
pretty much any environment which we
feel as such over here so that's a real
beauty about the continuous delivery
where we can actually deliver it to
whatever environment we feel we want to
deliver
now continuous delivery is uh also
something which is a very important
concept for most of the organizations
so uh each and every organizations are
actually looking forward to invest in
this one for a variety of reasons
because uh it's something where we can
invest some of our particular efforts
budget money lot of things are there but
the kind of benefits which we get in the
return that's what we are going to talk
about over here as such so let's go with
that so it provides the higher quality
of products yes the efforts are there
yes the investment is also there but in
the return the prime the very important
concept or very important thing which we
get is the high quality of products here
so the kind of quality which we are
getting with this one is quite high and
that's the biggest benefit which we get
when we talk about any kind of
continuous integration continuous
delivery or continuous deployment here
so the quality is always top notch when
we work of these particular processes
it also helps us to go for a quicker and
less risky releases so that's another
benefit which we get this process
customers are also satisfied because
they feel that yes we are going with
this particular automated process
within you know few days we are getting
the deliveries uh we don't have to wait
for months for getting our delivery so
that's the biggest benefit which a
customer usually gets when he talks
about the continuous delivery
and it's more efficiency is there and
the cost of fitness of the team also so
from the cost and from the uh particular
up efficiency all those parameters are
fully fulfilled when we talk about the
continence delivery so this process
delivers a lot of benefits which can
eventually help us to go for an perfect
high quality product which we can
develop as such over here
now the next thing is the continuous
deployment which is an automatic
deployment to the production environment
so let's see that what exactly is in
continuous deployment all about here so
continuous deployment uh refers to the
final stage in the pipeline so which
means that we are not only preparing our
artifacts we are not only doing the
particular compilations or test cases
executions we are actually going one
step ahead and this one step ahead is
nothing but the deployment to the
production environment so this is what
we are typically doing when we talk
about the continuous deployment over
here that we are going to one step ahead
and that's where we are going for the
deployment of our particular artifact so
we are deploying to the production
environment so that our changes whatever
the changes we are trying to do we are
trying to make that should be deployed
to the production environment
right now
so continuous deployment again is can be
deployed to uh hire whatever the
organizations want to feel or want to
deploy they can actually go with that
and there are a lot of benefits actually
which we get when we talk about the
continuous deployment so let's see about
all these particular deployments one by
one so first of all the faster
development of the products is there so
we are looking forward that when we are
going for the automations when we are
going for this deployment so it we get a
kind of a faster uh you know development
process which is there so the products
are getting developed very quickly very
fast that's the biggest benefit which
you are getting when we talk about this
continuous deployment here
and it's less risky releases also there
and it's easy to fix problems whatever
the automations we are feeling we are
trying to perform that can definitely
help us to go that how we can automate
and how we can go for these uh
particular releases over here so these
are releases are very less risky because
we are doing all the things automated
there is not much of a scope which is
there for the manual errors so usually
manual errors is something which is the
biggest uh problem or which is the
biggest risk when we go for any release
but that is something which is totally
removed with this automation here now it
also helps in continuous improvement in
the quality so continuously improve
quality is also getting improved as such
here
now let's talk about that why exactly as
and we talk about at the industry level
in the market level also that the ci cd
is one of the best practices now what is
the reason behind that why those are
known as the best development and devops
practices as such
now continuous integration and
continuous delivery are the best
practices as they create an effective
process the kind of integration and
delivering the source code these are the
prime things which we need to take care
when we talk about the development uh
teams over here so they want an
automated process first of all and they
also want to streamline process which
can you know take up the things
which should not fail it should be a
fail-safe process mechanism
through which they can release various
kind of changes to the production
environment because ultimately they are
looking forward for the deployment of
the changes to the production
environment so how they are going to do
that that is where the ci cd or the
continuous integration and continuous
delivery helps on that part and that's
the reason why they can help the teams
the development teams to go for an
effective
process implementations when we go for
these implementations of these two
practices
small call changes can be easily made in
the software course so you don't require
much of the efforts if you are going for
even small changes in the source code
that can also be effectively deployed to
a production environment in a simple
straightforward and easy mechanism the
changes can go from the developer
machines to the production environment
that's the biggest benefit which we get
due to which we feel that yes these two
processes should be implemented into a
devops platform
right so ca and cd provides continuous
feedback from the customers and also
from their development teams the devops
teams so the increase of transparency is
also something which is important which
is implemented with these processes here
so the process enables faster release of
the product so we don't have to wait for
months to release the source code there
within a couple of hours within couple
of days we can actually release it to
the production environment provided we
do all these steps like build
compilations testing development uh
validation all these things will be done
in that duration of time so the failures
can be easily detected faster and we can
easily find out that what is the problem
with the code base what is the problem
that changes and we can even do the hot
fixes now hot fixes these kind of
ad hoc changes are also can be easily
deployed to a production environment
within just a couple of hours there
so that was a complete summary on what
exactly is the acd and the prime
important concept which we have got a
proper understanding is that why these
two processes are really important for
our development process and the only
benefit which we are getting the prime
benefit which we are getting from these
processes implementation
is that we get a effective build process
effective test cases automation or
process and automated deployment process
and these processes when we combine that
is something which we can use to deliver
our source code our features to the
production environment and eventually to
the end user so that's how the ci cd
automations really works into a devops
environment hey guys welcome to jenkins
pipeline tutorial by simplylearn my name
is chidanan and let me quickly walk you
through the topics that i plan to cover
as a part of this tutorial at a very
high level i'll be introducing you
jenkins and then get into more details
of the continuous integration process as
most of you are aware most of the
software's in recent times are developed
using some or the other kind of agile
practices and continuous integration is
an important or key factor in all such
agile software development life cycle
next i'll be looking at the software
delivery pipeline from a perspective of
if someone were to visualize
all the steps that is required from the
time someone gives out a requirement a
software requirement it gets translated
into some sort of a code and gets tested
may be moved into one of the testing
platforms and then migrated across or
moved across or propagated across
various environments and then finally
put out in production if one were to put
a value stream mapping for all these
steps that is involved each of these
steps could translate into a simple job
within jenkins i will first look at what
existed in jenkins or rather pre-jenkins
2.0 where we had a way of upstream
downstream mapping of jobs there were
some plugins that allowed us to
visualize all the jobs at one shot
starting from the first job that
triggered and then i will get into the
most powerful groovy scripting that are
there in jenkins 2.0 outpost jenkins 2.0
these groovy scripting uses much more
powerful ways of defining our pipelines
there are two different ways in which
you can write your scripts one is the
scripted one the other one is
declarative one there's very subtle
change or difference between each one of
them but these gives you a much more
flexible and much more powerful feature
to write complicated pipelines for your
software delivery having said that most
of these topics that i'm going to
discuss will be followed up with a demo
and the source code for most of these
would be on our github repository all
right now as a prerequisite probably it
may be a good idea in case if you
haven't already watched please watch our
previous video wherein i mentioned how
to install jenkins and how to put up
some sample jobs on our jenkins server
so what exactly is jenkins jenkins is
nothing but a powerful automation server
that is written in java and it is a web
application which can also be run on any
web server but what makes jenkins an
ideal choice for a continuous
integration server jenkins has got
wonderful plugins that allows it to
connect to all kinds of tools software
development deployment coding build
source code kind of tools that is what
makes jenkins very very powerful from a
continuous integration perspective
jenkins can connect to various source
code servers and it has also got plugins
that allows it to build deploy test all
kinds of software artifacts so this is
what makes jenkins an ideal choice for a
continuous integration server but mind
you for me jenkins is nothing but a very
very powerful automated server at the
heart of it there's a lot of automation
in it but the powerfulness of jenkins is
more so because of the tools that it
integrates with and the kind of plugins
that it has got what is continuous
integration from a software development
uh life cycle assuming that the software
delivery is happening in very small
sprints maybe three to four weeks is
your delivery life cycle and there are a
bunch of developers who are located in
different locations who are working on
the same code base on the same branch if
the code check-ins do not happen quickly
as in every day if at all developers
stagger their code check-ins into the
repository finding problems at a later
stage would be very costly for the whole
project early detection of any such
issues would be you know quick to
resolve and would not affect your
delivery schedules so as a part of
continuous integration what is requested
or what is demanded is that every
developer checks in code pretty much you
know every day as long as it doesn't
break the code he checks in code pretty
much regularly and at the end of a day
you have an automated server which kind
of wakes up pulls the latest code so
this code has got the integrations of
all the code bases that has been checked
in by various developers so it pulls out
the code it builds on a completely
different server there is a ci server
which pulls this code it builds it it's
got all the tools that is required to
compile it build it and test it and
assuming that you got some good
percentage of test case automation
you're also having a most of your
regression test suites automated if at
all there is a way by which in a couple
of hours time when the team is out or
other team is sleeping you have
verification that happens at a very
crucial level and then any breakages
even before the team arrives for the
next day if these are notified to the
whole team members saying an email going
out saying that something got broken
most of the code would be pretty okay
from the perspective of compilation
errors or build errors it is the
functionality and the regression that
the team is worried about so if these
can be automated test it very very
quickly and very very fast and then any
breakages are detected early during the
day all right by the time the next day
people come in they know what is broken
and possibly they know what code
check-in broke that particular thing and
they can have a quick stand-up meeting
and then they discuss what broke the
code and able to fix it so this way any
problem that could possibly arise at a
later point of time if at all they kind
of move to the initial phase of the
project any detection that is early
doesn't really hurt the team so this is
all continuous integration that is about
and jenkins plays an important role in
being the continuous integration server
because it's got connections to anything
and everything all kinds of tools i mean
and then it is also got various ways on
which triggering the job which is a part
of its automation strategy now that we
know what is continuous integration and
where does jenkins coming to picture
let's look at the rest of the tasks of
our software development lifecycle so if
at all i were to visualize the kind of
steps that is involved in delivering my
software possibly the continuous
integration phase would be somewhere
here where multiple developers are
developing on that and then we have a
little bit of a stable code that is
there that can be kind of moved across
because i want to go ahead with the
particular build that i have and then i
want to migrate that i want to propagate
that across various environments so if
you consider the standard software
delivery approach in the first cycle you
just do some minimal testing and then
you kind of move that to one of the
environments and from there you kick off
more and more tests there could be
integration test they could be
acceptance tests they could be
functionality check they could be a
stress test there could be a load test
it could be a system integration test
all kinds of tests that you can think
about and all the way may be propagating
the build across various environments if
all this can be considered as various
steps the workflow is such that as and
when the build moves across various
phases if there's any failure of course
the build propagation kind of stops
everyone gets notified but if at all
everything goes well so your workflow is
progressing well and at the end of the
workflow you eventually have a code
which is pretty much good to release now
mind you i make an assumption here that
most of your test cases are automated
and you have a good percentage of
coverage of your test cases but if that
is not the scenario then possibly there
are some automated tests or checks that
may be required in between but if the
workflow can kind of accommodate all
that as well you know you can visualize
this as the steps that is required for
your software development or software
delivery life cycle now in jenkins the
way this kind of translates is that each
of these tasks can be put out as a job
so now let me quickly let you know or
let me quickly demo what existed in
pre-jenkins 2.0 where i could put up a
couple of jobs and i can connect them
using the upstream downstream linking
mechanism so if this job one if at all
it is a build and even test cases if at
all that passes successfully job 2 gets
triggered if the job 2 is more about
running some more automated tests or
possibly deploying it to environment and
then kicking off some more test cases
that would be job too but if the
deployment fails or if some of the other
test cases fail it would not propagate
to the third job all right so let me
quickly bring up my jenkins instance and
put up some sample jobs and tell you how
to connect that or rather how could one
connect that using jenkins 2.0 or pre
jenkins 2.0 release i have now brought
up my jenkins instance and in case some
of you don't know how to install jenkins
or you don't know how to bring up your
jenkins instance i would strongly
recommend that you watch our previous
videos on simply learn youtube channel
where i've detailed out the steps that
is required for you to install jenkins
and bring it up so alright so i've
brought up my jenkins instance let me
put up few of those jobs now mind you
i'm gonna cover the pre jenkins 2.0
feature here all right so let me put up
my first job all right i hope i don't
have that job i say it's a freestyle
project
i don't want to change anything i'm
going to put up a very very simple job
here it's in batch command let's say
echo
first job triggered
at right that's my first job
now let me put up my second job
it's a freestyle project
all right that's my second job
all right that's my third job i've got
us very very simple uh echo statements
in this
so it just prints out the system date
and the time in it
all right
so i could run these jobs individually
if i want so let me just check running
my third job so this is what i get
the console output third job triggered
at date and time oops
let me fix that
right that should fix it
let me check my second job
all right that's my second job
all right so i've got three jobs now if
i were to link them together or if at
all i want a scenario where after the
first job is successfully run i would
like to trigger my second job so i would
do a small configuration change in here
i would say after this first job is run
i want to trigger the second job so i
have something called as a post build
action so i can say that trigger some
other jobs from here so if you see this
publish
record deploy
all right trigger
trigger trigger trigger let me check the
other one build other projects this is
what i would want to do so after the
first job is done i want to trigger my
second job all right i would say save
this now let me go back to my second job
and then trigger the third job after the
second job is done
all right i'll add this post build build
other projects third job again
i'm not really sure if you guys noticed
this there is various configurations as
to when exactly do you want to trigger
the other job and the default one is
trigger only if the build is stable so
typically this is the configuration that
would need we definitely don't want the
third job to be triggered in case the
second job fails all right so this is
the combination that i want or this is
the choice that i want and i save this
now i have three of my jobs if you see
this the second job the upstream job is
the first job so let me check this kind
of a pipeline what i've set here is a
very very simple pipeline so after my
first job gets triggered if i build this
guy right the second job gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
i click on the second job all right so
the first job was to get the second job
and after the second job it is
triggering the third job so this is how
first job second job and third job were
kind of linked but it's pretty hard to
visualize this as to you know if i need
to see one holistic picture where after
the first job after the second job after
the third job what was the flow it's not
possible for me to visualize that that's
where in i install a plugin so let me go
to manage plugins right here i think i
already have it installed for those of
you who don't have it installed you can
go to the available button available tab
and click on that the plugin is called
delivery pipeline plugin i already have
it installed in case you don't have it
installed you just go to the available
you click on this and say install
without restart this is the plugin that
i want you to install all right so now
we have that plugin installed so what i
want to do is after the plugin is
installed you see something like this so
this is where i would create a new
visualization for the pipeline that i've
created so i would say my first pipeline
or i give a name for my visualization i
would say yes this upstream downstream
dependencies this is exactly what i want
and there are a bunch of settings here
i'll not look at any of that now what i
want is i just want to tell this view
that you know the i can give a name for
this i would give it as simply learn
pipeline
and what's important is that i specify
what is the first job that should be
picked up as a part of this pipeline and
the final job is optional because it
knows that if the first job is
triggering those other jobs it knows
where to end this whole uh life cycle so
i define a pipeline and they give a name
for my component and i initialize that
as my i mean i give it the first job so
i say okay and there you go this is much
better this gives you a beautiful
visualization of as to what happened
after the first job second job was run
second job if you click on any of these
that will in fact take me to the job all
right there is also one other option
which is pretty good option in my
opinion which is about edit view yes
this is where it is enable start of a
new pipeline build let me apply and let
me click ok on this what it gives me is
a way in which i can trigger my whole
pipeline from here so if i click on this
there you see the first job getting
triggered the second job is still
running the green means it's all run
properly and nicely second one is
triggered now the third one it's still
running all right so this is the
pipeline that existed prior to jenkins
2.0 this is pretty decent enough and if
you see there's a one-to-one mapping but
if at all you remember we could go and
add multiple dependencies for the
projects that i set in just to give an
example let's say if i go to my first
job i can do a configuration here and
nothing stops me from triggering
multiple jobs after this by giving me a
comma i can trigger multiple jobs here
in case if i have to run few things
parallely this also gives me that option
to do that but having said that this was
the most primitive way in which the jobs
were kind of visualized and run prior to
jenkins 2.0 now this feature became such
an important feature the users wanted
more and more complicated because the
pipelines were a lot complicated it was
not just one job after the other there
were multiple jobs that has to be run
and there was also an introduction of
the jenkins agents where multiple tasks
could be parallelly run on different
agents so they wanted to club all of
that and the pipeline could have all the
such complicated stuff that's where in
post jenkin 2.0 or in jenkins 2.0
jenkins
released a version which has got the
feature of pipeline which can be written
in groovy scripts now groovy is
wonderful scripting language it's very
very powerful anybody can visualize your
pipeline or write your pipeline using
programming language and the point of
everything is code where this whole
groovy script gets into your source code
repository so instead of putting jobs
here and in case my jenkins kind of
fails you know there's a crash on my
jenkins i don't get back these jobs how
do i bring back all these jobs back so
everything has code that's the devops
principle so the pipelines will be
written as scripts that is what i'm
going to do in my next exercise in my
previous example i showed you the crude
way in my opinion of putting up a
jenkins pipeline but this is what
existed prior to jenkins 2.0 and now i
have post jenkins 2.0 in terms of my
version jenkins version is 2.107. so
this supports something called as a
scripted pipeline wherein you can write
your pipeline in terms of groovy scripts
no need to put up any jobs here and
remember how exactly you put up these
individual jobs you can write a pipeline
script in terms of groovy language let
me quickly show you a very very simple
and elementary pipeline that i have this
is what a groovy script would look like
pipeline any agent can run this stages
there are individual stages that is
defined as a subset of these stages so
the first stage is the compile stage and
stage has got some steps in it you can
have multiple steps in it and once only
after all these steps successfully
complete that's where in the stage gets
through perfectly with the pass so
there's a compile a stage there's a j
unit stage there's a quality gate stage
there's a deploy stage and i'm really
not doing anything much within this
other than echoing you know some text
within each of these stages and what's
interesting is at the end there's
something called as a post which is
similar to or you can kind of equate
that to what would be there in a try
catch kind of a block supposed always
meaning this would run all the time
success only if at all all the steps
that were above in terms of the stages
they were completed successfully without
any failures so typically you would have
your email that is going out here saying
that the build is successful and stuff
like that failure if something went bad
if any of the step resulted in a failure
this particular block will get executed
unstable whenever any build is marked
unstable if at all only few things that
failed within your test run and you
would want to mark the build as unstable
are changed this is an interesting
option so this compares the present run
with the previous run and if there's any
change meaning if the previous run was a
failure and the present run is a success
or vice versa this would get triggered
so this is what a simple pipeline script
would look like so let me copy this
pipeline and let me put up a simple job
for running this pipeline so let me open
up my jenkins say a new i would say
scripted pipeline yeah this is what i
want i don't want to choose a freestyle
project this is going to be a pipeline
project so i would say pipeline and say
okay all right this has got far less
options than the other jobs that we put
up so general i don't want anything here
i don't want any build trigger right so
this is where i kind of i can paste in
whatever i had copied there's also
something called as a pipeline syntax or
a syntax generator this is like a lookup
where you can choose what you want to do
and choose the option that is specific
to those steps and you will get a
pipeline generator or a script generated
for you jenkins knows that you're not
very good at understanding these
pipelines so this gives you the sandbox
kind of an environment where you can
check out whatever you want to do as a
part of your pipeline and then get the
equivalent groovy script from here let
me look at this in a bit later so for
now i have my pipeline syntax already
copied so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to paste what i copied all right
so this looks good okay i'm not
connecting to any github repository of
any of that i'm just running a very very
simple pipeline which has got some steps
in it and it just compiles or rather it
just puts out some messages saying that
this stage completed successfully and
stuff like that so let me save this and
let me try to run this scripted pipeline
all right if you see this you'll see
each of those steps going through and if
at all i look at the console output
compile successfully unit passed all the
stages passed there was a pass the
failures doesn't show up you will see
the messages from our post or the try
catch block that i was mentioning
earlier so this is how one would put up
a pipeline and you also get to see the
visualized view of your pipeline that
says which stage run after which phase
how much time did it take and you can
click on any of these and get into
looking at the logs from that particular
pipeline front that was pretty easy
wasn't it now let me give you another
scenario for a pipeline wherein the
source code of my pipeline would be in a
github repository and i'll write scripts
to grab this particular code and run
some part of the code which is there as
a part of the repository so let me look
at the repository that i have i have a
repository out here on the simply learn
github account which is called the
pipeline script and if you see in there
there are a bunch of batch files that
are there so the first batch file would
be a build.batch so there's nothing in
it except that it is just trying to
build a particular project you can
visualize this as individual batch files
which actually contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your particular
project so i have a couple of batch
files that is here and this is on the
github repository so i would need to
write jenkins job which will log into my
github account and then check out this
particular repository from my account
and then run these batch files as a part
of those individual steps within within
the scripted pipeline so let me check as
to how i could do that
let me put up a new project for this let
me call this scripted pipeline scripted
pipeline from github all right so let
this be a pipeline project that's good
enough for me let me see my scripts all
right now this is where i need to put in
the scripts for pulling out the code
repository from my github server and
running those batch files that are there
as a part of the repository so what i
want to do is i already have the
skeleton of my pipeline that is written
which is very similar to whatever was
the pipeline syntax that i showed you in
the previous step so i just copy this
out here and then paste it here so what
i have here is i've written on the high
level skeleton without really putting in
the actual steps required for checking
out rather or rather running those build
scripts so i've got four steps one is
the git checkout step the builds tab
unit test quality gate and possibly the
deploy all right so i need to put in the
actual scripts that is required for
first checking out the repository from
my github server so this is where i will
make use of this pipeline syntax so as i
mentioned earlier you have a bunch of
help that is available for you to figure
out the actual scripts that is required
for you to write within your pipeline so
what i wanted to do is check out
something from git so it's get related
so search on git and you'll find this
option so i got to specify my git
repository url and my credentials so let
me look at the repository url this would
be my repository url so let me copy this
i'm going to copy the https url of my
repository and branch is good and one
thing that you gotta notice is for now
the repository is anyway a public
repository on github so even though if
you don't specify any credentials that
would work for me still but in case you
have a repository which needs strictly a
username and password to be specified
you can kind of add it out here using
add jenkins and you can give your
username and password out here but for
now i don't need any of these things so
i'm going to just say get checkout or
rather the url of my repository and what
we want is the master branch for now i
have only one branch on my github server
so this is good for me so this is what
exactly i want to do as a part of the
script so if i click this this is the
script that i need to put in my build
script so i come over here and this is
what will check out the code from my
repository all right so now once i get
my code onto my repository from my
repository rather it will grab those
code all these patch files and get it
onto my jenkins workspace now i'll have
to run these batch files as a part of
each of my step so let me look at what
would be the syntax so the first one
that i want to run would be my
build.bat all right so i want to run a
batch file all right and what is the
name of the batch file that i want to
run i want to run this build.back so
generate pipeline script this is all
that i got to specify as a part of my
build step and then unit test i'm going
to just
change this to unit i think that's what
i have in my repository okay that is
unit and then deploy and quality queue
capital
quality and this one would be deploy
all right so this piece of code will
actually get into my repository and
check out my source code and grab it and
take it to the jenkins workspace so from
this workspace since all the files are
there in the root directory of this
workspace it will run these batch files
one after the other all right let me
save this and let me try to run my
pipeline
all right so it runs a lot of things in
the background trying to get the source
code from my repository whoa whoa whoa
that was fast all right so it pulled out
all the source code from my repository
the last commit message from where the
source code was pulled out it was this
create deploy dot bad that looks good
i'm saying building checked out project
building the checked out project this is
what i've had in my build.bat if i'm not
mistaken
okay building the project that's what is
there with the timestamp running unit
test cases unit.bat it is running the
unit.bat and then giving me the date and
timestamp okay so all these kind of pass
and if i go back to the project i will
also see this beautiful view of how
exactly what is the time that was taken
for checking out the repository running
the build on bat running the unit test
cases quality gates and all this isn't
that pretty simple now let me modify my
previous job or rather let me put up a
new job for making use of an agent
wherein i could delegate a job to an
engine typically agents can be brought
up on any other remote machines other
than where your primary enkin server is
running in case you don't know or you
don't know how to start up these agents
i would strongly recommend that you
refer to our previous uh jenkins video
on the simply learn youtube channel all
right so let me just check the status of
my agent for now yes he's offline so let
me start this agent because agent is not
running so i have the agent uh set up in
my c colon agents so let me copy the
script file that is required for
starting my agent let me go to the
agents folder open up a command prompt
and let me try to bring up my agent all
right so the agent is up and running for
now i don't have the luxury of starting
my agent on a different machine so my
agent is running on my same machine but
the agent's workspace is sequel agent
while my primary jenkins server is
running uh has the workspace out here c
colon program files 86 and this is the
workspace of my jenkins all right i hope
you can kind of differentiate those two
all right so now what i want is i look
at the same job that i put in earlier or
rather modify that let the steps be the
same but i don't want to run that on my
master server let me try to delegate
that using the script so let me put up
an agent scripted job
all right it will be a pipeline rep job
let's say okay and let me copy this was
a step that i had put in for my previous
job so agent any so what i'm gonna do
now is i don't want this to be running
on any other agent i want this to be
running on the agent whose label is let
me check what is the label of my
agent that is running okay
so this is the name of my agent okay
windows note so let me just copy that
there all right so with a very subtle
change instead of saying agent any i'm
going to run or rather i'm going to
specify the agent will be running this
job is the one who has got the label as
windows note so this agent that i
brought on my system has got the name as
windows node and it is configured to
pick up any job that matches the label
to which any job is kind of delegated so
let me come back to my jobs where is my
scripted agent job
i've got too many jobs running all right
so this is my agent scripted job that i
left halfway through so here in the
pipeline what i'm going to do is
this is all i'm going to need so the job
remains the same kit checkout is going
to check out from the same repository
run the batch files accordingly but this
change is just to ensure that this job
is kind of delegated on the agent
all right so this would be my agent job
let me save this
and let me get back to the dashboard and
let me run it from here if you see this
you know the master and agent are both
idle as of now let me try to run this
agent scripted job all right so the
agent kind of kicked in and there's a
job that was delegated to the agent if i
look at what is there in the console
output he's pretty much doing whatever
was there as a part of the job but the
interesting thing to note is that this
is the new workspace or rather this is
delegated to the agent and the agent's
workspace is this particular folder so
this is where it's going to get all this
stuff
run the whole thing and
you know the flow is pretty much the
same the only thing is this whole thing
ran on the agent if i need to check
my agent i would see the workspace out
here agent scripted job if you look at
this all the batch files are here and
this is where the job was kind of
delegated to run so with a very subtle
change in in the scripting i can ensure
that the jobs are kind of delegated onto
the agent the pipeline job specifically
as i mentioned earlier jenkins provides
you two different ways of writing
pipelines called the scripted and the
declarative the first one that was
launched was the scripted pipeline this
is heavily based on groovy scripting
since jenkins ships along with the
groovy engine so this was the first
script or the first support for pipeline
that was provided by jenkins in 2.0 this
needs a little bit of a learning curve
since groovy is a wonderful script
understanding that may be a little
cumbersome but then once you kind of
master it you can write really powerful
scripts based on groovy at a very high
level this is what a typical scripted
pipeline would look like something
called as a node node represents the
agent or the actual box on which your
job would be running and then a bunch of
stages are put out with each of the
stage along with the steps that needs to
be covered as the part of those stages
listed one below the other so all these
stages if they're run peacefully then
the whole task is kind of marked as run
successfully since understanding groovy
or learning ruby was a little tough for
many of the people so this is a new one
from jenkins wherein it provides you a
much simple and friendly syntax for
writing pipelines without really needing
to understand or without nearly reading
to learn some group scripting again
there's a very subtle change between
these and you there are a lot of lookups
for figuring out what is a better
pipeline for you to kind of write but if
you can figure out the difference or if
you can try to find that particular
piece of code which kind of helps you
out with your pipeline either of the
skips there's not really any difference
in writing or kind of delivering your
pipeline using either of these two
methods all right so declare your
pipeline is something like this where
you have an agent you can specify the
agent label or if you can say agent any
it will pick up whatever is an available
agent and run the job and then you have
something called a stages stages is
nothing but a collection of stage and
stage could have multiple steps defined
within this so if any of the steps in
any of the stage fails then that
particular complete stage and the build
is marked as failure so very subtle
difference between both these
two syntax but using either of these you
can write powerful scripts for your
pipeline now let me come up with an
example where i'm going to at least demo
one of the feature where you could run a
master and a slave job in parallel so
let me come up with a demo for that
particular scenario let me put up a new
job for my parallel
agent pipeline let me call this and this
would be a pipeline project
i don't want anything here let me look
at the pipeline script that i have
pipeline agent none stages and there's a
first stage where this would be a kind
of non-parallel stage where there's a
need for you to possibly pull out the
source code from one of the repositories
and possibly unit test it if all the
unit test cases pass then possibly you
want to deploy it to one of the test
environments that would be what would be
there as a part of the non-parallel
stage and then you may have a bunch of
tests that could be run and assuming
that you know you have a windows node
you have a linux node you have some
other kind of an operating system based
node you could run these stages in
parallel so for just for demonstration
i've just put in two parallel stages in
parallel is the keyword that you're
gonna use for running tests parallely so
i would say parallel stage test on
windows and i'm going to run this in my
windows note well i could run a bunch of
steps that i want out here and then in
the other stage or other step what i
want is i will run something else on on
my master as long as this parallel
keyword is encountered jenkins will
ensure that these two stages are run
parallely for now i have both these
things running on my same machine but
assuming that these were running on
different boxes you could kind of
visualize it as these two steps are
going to be started parallely without
really any dependency on each other and
then you could wait for the test results
and then based upon whether both of
these steps passed or failed if one of
them failed then we could kind of mark
the build accordingly so let me copy
this pretty pretty simple script let me
put this out here and now let me save
this out and let me try to build this
all right there you go the stage will be
executed first this is the non-parallel
stage that's gonna happen then the task
one on agent task one one master
followed by as i said since i have only
one node or rather one system one with
both these things are running
simultaneously you will not really see a
benefit of this but assuming that you
have couple of boxes on which you have
multiple agents running you'll possibly
want to run your selenium tests on the
windows box because selenium brings up
some of those ui which needs a browser
you could possibly need some regression
test that could run on linux boxes or
linux agents and then you can kind of
break down your tasks into multiple
things that is running on multiple
systems at the same time and then
collate all the results okay one final
thing all right now i have all my
particular
job or rather the steps required for my
pipeline put down in terms of the
scripts and this is saved in this
particular job that's not a good or a
recommended approach so what i'll do is
i'll copy all of these steps out here
and then what needs to be done is
actually let's say let me go back to
this repository the most preferred
approach is where you create something
called as a jenkins file jenkins file
and you paste all the scripts that is
required for your pipeline now this is
in a true sense the devops approach
where i'm going to save this out so if
at all you have a pipeline defined for
your project
the best place to kind of
put out your configurations for the
pipeline is within your repository so
this may be a different project that i
was referring to but assuming that you
have your project where you know you
have to define your pipeline instead of
putting that as a particular job on
jenkins and fearing that if jenkins
fails or the jobs if there's a crash and
then you lose out your job configuration
the best approach is to use a jenkins
file put all the steps that is required
the tried tested steps that is required
as a part of your jenkins file and then
you can put out a job that can pull the
source code from here as well as use the
steps that is defined in the jetkins
file so let me end up by putting up
another job which is a true jobs kind of
a job so i would say devops
pipeline
and this is a pipeline script
and then i'm not going to say any of
these things i would say the pipeline
script is from the source code
management so my pipeline script is
already defined it is present in scm so
what is my svn i mean what is my source
code repository this is my source code
repository where i already have this so
let me copy this url this is my url i
don't need any credentials because the
repositories anyway in public repository
that is all that is required i would say
and the scripted file it automatically
picks up jenkins file all right so let
me save this let me build this
so that's the beauty of devops wherein i
have a pipeline that is defined and
instead of putting the pipeline as a job
because pipeline is nothing but a
configuration the configuration is also
checked into the source code repository
and any changes to this pipeline instead
of putting that modifications in the job
these are all captured as a part of my
repository so the changes are nicely
configured so that you know we know
who's done what change if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know
today is being implemented by you know
most of the major organizations whether
it's a financial organization whether
it's a kind of a service organization
every organization is somehow looking
forward for the implementation and the
adaptation of devops because it totally
redefines and automate the whole
development process all together and
whatever the manual efforts you were
putting earlier that is simply or gets
automated with the help of these tools
here so this is something which get
really implemented because of some of
the important uh feature like a cicd
pipeline because cacd pipeline is
responsible for delivering your source
code into the production environment in
large duration of time so cicd pipeline
is ultimately the goal which really
helps us to deliver more into the
production environment when we talk
about from this perspective
now let's talk about that what exactly
is a cac pipeline now when we go into
that part when we go into that
understanding so cicd pipeline is a
basically continuous integration and
continuous delivery concept which is
used or which is considered as a
backbone of the overall devops approach
now it's one of the prime approach which
we implement when we are going for a
devops implementation for our project so
if i have to go for a devops
implementation the very first and the
minimum implementation and the
automation which i'm looking forward is
actually from the uh particular ci cd
pipelines here so cacd pipelines is
really a wonderful option when we talk
about the devops here
so what exactly is the pipeline term
all about so pipeline is in series of
events that are connected together with
each other it's kind of a sequence of
the various steps like you know
typically when we talk about any kind of
deployment so we have like you know
build process like we compile the source
code which under the artifacts we do the
testing and then we deploy to a specific
environment all these various steps
which we use to do it like manually that
is something which we can do it into a
pipeline so pipeline is nothing but a
sequence of all these steps
interconnected with each other executed
one by one into a particular sequence
now
the pipelines is responsible for
performing a variety of tasks
like building up the source code running
the test cases uh probably the
deployment can also be added up in when
we go for the continuous integration and
continuous delivery there so all these
steps are being done into a sequence
definitely because sequence is very
important when we talk about the
pipeline so you need to talk about the
sequence the same way in which you are
working on the development
and in a typical world the same thing
you will be putting up into a specific
pipeline so that's a very important
aspect to be considered now let's talk
about what is the continuous integration
here now continuous integration is also
you know known as the ci uh pretty much
you can see that a lot of
tools are actually named as ci but they
are referring to the continuous
integration only so continuous
integration is a practice that
integrates the source code into a share
repository and it used to
automate the verification of the source
code so it involves the build
automations test cases automation so it
also helps us to detect the issues and
the bugs quite easily and quite faster
that's a very early mechanism which we
can do as such if we want to resolve all
these problems now continuous
integrations does not eliminate the bugs
but yes it definitely helps them
you know easily to find out because we
we are talking about the uh automated
process we are talking about the
automatic test cases so definitely that
is something which can help us to uh
find out the bugs and then you know the
development can help on that and they
can you know proceed with those bugs and
they can try to resolve those things one
by one so it's not a kind of automated
process which will eventually remove the
bugs bugs is something which you have to
recode and you have to fix it by
following the development practice but
yes it can really help us to find those
bugs quite easy and help them to remove
now what is the continuous delivery here
so continuous delivery also known as cd
is in kind of a phase in which the
changes are made uh into the code before
the deployment now in this case what
happens that uh it's um something which
we are discussing or we are validating
that what exactly we want to deliver to
the customer so what exactly we are
going ahead or we are moving to the
customer so that's what we typically do
in case of continuous delivery and the
ultimate goal of the pipeline is to make
the deployments that's the end result
because
coding is not the only thing you code
the programs you do the development
after that it's all about the
deployments like how you're going to
that to perform the deployment so that
is a very important aspect you want to
go ahead with the deployments that's
right you can go there and that's a real
beauty about this because it it's in
kind of a way in which we can identify
that how the deployments can be done or
can be executed as such here
right so the ultimate goal for the
pipeline is nothing but to do the
deployments and to proceed further on
that
right so when both these practices are
placed in together in an order so all
these steps could be referred as in
complete automated process and this
process is known as cicd so when we are
talking about like when we are working
on this automation so in that case what
happens that we are looking forward that
how the automation needs to be done and
since it's in kind of a ci cd automation
which we are talking about so it's
nothing but the uh end result would be
like build and deployment automation so
you will be taking care of both the
build and the test case executions and
the deployments as such when we talk
about as such the cicd here
the implementation of chcd also enables
the team to do the build and deploys
quite quickly and uh efficiently because
these are things which is you know
happening automatically so there is no
manual efforts involved and there is no
scope of human error also so we have
frequently seen that while doing the
deployments we may miss some binaries or
some miss can be there so that is
something which is you know completely
removed as such when we talk about this
the process makes the teams more agile
productive and the uh confident here
because um the automations definitely
gives a kind of a boost to the
confidence that yes things are going to
work perfectly fine and there is no
issues as such present
now why exactly jenkins like jenkins is
what we typically understand or we you
know uh here and there that's in ci2
it's a cd tool so what exactly is
jenkins all about so jenkins is also
known as a kind of orchestration tool
it's an automated tool which is there
and the best part is that it's
completely open source yes there are
some particular or paid or the
enterprise tools are there like cloud
b's and all but there is no as such of
offering difference between the
cloudbees and the jenkins here so
jenkins is an kind of open source tool
which a lot of organizations pretty much
implement as it is itself so even if
they don't want to go um we have seen in
a lot of big organizations where you
know they are not going for the
enterprise tool like cloud b's and all
and they are going for the pretty much
you know core jenkins software as such
here
so this tool uh makes it easy for the
developers to integrate the changes to
the project that is something which is
very important because it can really
help the teams to say that how the
things can be done and how it can be
performed over there so the tools is
really easy for the developers to
integrate and that's the biggest uh you
know benefit which you are getting when
we talk about these tools as such so
jenkins is a very important tool to be
considered when we talk about all these
automations now jenkins achieves
continuous integration with the help of
plugins that is also a kind of another
feature or benefit which we get because
there are so many plugins which is
available there as such which is being
used and uh for example you want to have
an integration with kubernetes docker
and all maybe by default those plugins
are not installed but yes you have the
provisioning that you can go for the
installation of those plugins and yes
those features will start embedded up
and integrated within your jenkins so
this is the reason this is the main
benefit which we get when we talk about
the jenkins implementation
so jenkins uh is you know one of the
best fit which is there for building a
ci cd pipeline because of its
flexibility open source nature plug-in
capabilities the support for plugins and
it's quite easy to use and it's very
simple straightforward gui which is
there which can definitely helps us you
can you know easily understand and go
through the jenkins and you can grab the
understanding and as an end result you
will be able to have a very robust tool
which using which pretty much any kind
of source code or any kind of
programming language you can implement
csd whether it's an android it's a not
net it's a java it's a node.js all the
languages are having the support for the
jenkins
so let's talk about the ccd pipeline
with the jenkins here now to automate
the entire development process a ci cd
pipeline is the ultimate you know
solution which we are looking forward to
build such a pipeline jenkins is our
best solution and best fit which is
available here
so there are pretty much six steps which
is involved when we look forward for any
kind of pipeline it's a generic pipeline
which we are looking forward now it may
have like uh any other steps which is
available there probably some additional
steps you're doing like some other
plugins you are installing but these are
the basic steps which is there like a
minimum pipeline if you want to design
these are the steps which is available
there now let's see the first one is
that we have the uh required java jdk
like a jdk to be available on the system
now most of the operating systems are
already available with the gre like a
java gre but the problem with gre is
that it's only for the build process uh
it will not be doing the compilation you
can run the artifacts you can run the
jar files you can you know run the
application run the code base but the
compilation requires the java c or the
java jdk kit to be installed onto the
system and that's the reason why for
this one we also require the jdk and
certain linux commands execution
understanding we need to have because we
are going to run some kind of steps some
installation steps and you know process
so that's pretty much required now let's
talk about how do ca cd pipeline with
jenkins now first of all you have to
download the jdk
and uh that is something which is
installed so after that you can go for
the jenkins download now jenkins dot io
slash download is the website is our
official websites of jenkins now the
best part is that there you have the
support for different operating systems
and platforms from there you can easily
say that if you want to go for a java uh
package like a war file tucker ubuntu
deviant centos fedora red hat windows
open sushi uh freebsd ganto mac
operating system in fact whatever the
different kind of artifacts or different
environment or different uh
application you want to download you
will be able to do that so that's the
very first thing to start upon you
download the generic java package like a
war file then you have to execute it you
have to download that into a specific
folder structure let's say say that you
have you know created a folder called
jenkins now you have to go into that
jenkins folder with the help of cd
command and there you have to run the
command called java hyphen jar and the
jenkins dot bar there so uh these are
the executables uh artifacts so var
files can be easily executable
jar files raw files can be easily
deployed so
just because with the java command you
can run them you don't require any kind
of web container or application
container as such so here also you can
see that we are running the java command
and it runs the applications as such and
once that is done so you can open the
web browser and uh you can open like
localhost colony tdt so jenkins uses atd
port just like a tomcat apache so uh if
you know once the deployment is done
installation is done so you can just
open the localhost colony t now if you
want to get uh
the jenkins up and running in the
browser probably you can you know go
through the uh public ipad address also
there so you can put the public ipad is
calling 880 and that can also help you
to you know start accessing the jenkins
application
now in there you will be having an
option called create new jobs so you
need to click on that now once the uh
particular new job new item new job
that's a different naming conventions
which is available there now all you're
going to do is that you're going to do
like you are proceeding with the
creating the pipeline job so you will be
having an option called pipeline job
over there just select that and provide
your custom name what pipeline name or
job name you want to
refer or you want to process there now
once that is available so what happens
that it will be an easy task for us to
see that how exactly we can go ahead and
we can perform on that part so this can
really help us to see that how a
pipeline job can be created and you know
performed on these modifications as such
now when the pipeline is selected and we
can give a particular name that is this
is the name which is available and then
we can say okay as such over there now
you can scroll down and find the
pipeline section so uh there what
happens that when you go over there and
say that okay this is the way that how
the pipelines are managed and you know
those kind of things so you will scroll
down and find the pipeline section and
go with that pipeline script now when
you select that option there are
different options which is available
like how you want to manage these
pipelines now you are you know have the
direct access also like if you want to
directly create the uh create a pipeline
scape you can do that if you feel that
you want to manage like you want to
retrieve the jenkins files also scored
management tool also can be used there
so you can work on that also so like
this there are so many a variety of
things which is available like which you
can use to work around that how exactly
the pipeline job can be created so
either you can fetch it from the source
code management tool uh like gate
version or something like that or you
can directly put the pipeline code as
such over there right now so next thing
is that we can configure and execute a
pipeline job with the direct script so
uh we can once the pipeline is selected
so you can put the uh particular script
like jenkins file into your uh
particular github link so you you may be
having like already a github link so
that where the jenkins file is there so
you can make use of that now once you
process the github link so what we can
do is that we can proceed with that
and uh once the processing is done so
you can do the same and you know you can
keep the changes and you know uh it will
be picking up the pipelines you know the
pipeline script is added up into the
github and you know you have already
specified that uh let's just go ahead
with this jenkins file pipeline script
from the github repository and proceed
further now once that is done so what
next you can do is that you can go with
the build now process you click on the
bill now and once that is done so what
will happen that you will be able to see
that how the build process will be done
and how the build will be performed over
there so these are pretty much a kind of
a way so you can click on the console
output you will get all the logs that is
happening in the inside that whatever
the pipeline steps are getting executed
all of them you will be able to get or
you will be able to you know get on that
part there so these are the different
steps which is involved as such and uh
the sixth one is that you know uh yes
whatever the uh particular uh
when you run the build now you will be
able to see that source code will be uh
you know will be checked out and will be
downloaded before the build and you can
proceed with that part now later on if
you want to change the url of this
github you can configure the job again
the existing job and you can change that
url github link url whenever you require
you can also clone this uh job whenever
you go ahead and you work on that and
that's also kind of you know the best
part which is available as such right
and uh
then you can have the advanced settings
over there so in there you can put like
your github repository you can say like
okay uh the github repository is there
so i'm just going to put this url and
you know with that what will happen that
the settings will be available there and
the jenkins file will be downloaded as
such and when you run the build now you
will be able to have a lot of steps like
a lot of configurations going on so uh
then the checkout icm so
we can have a declaration like checkout
sem which is there so when the checkout
sm is there so it will check out a
specific source code after that you go
to the log and you will be able to see
that each and every stage which is being
built up and executed as such
okay so now we are going to talk about a
demo here so on the pipeline here so
this is the jenkins portal now you can
see here that there is an option called
create a job you can either click on the
new item or you can click on the new
up create a job here now here i'm going
to say like a pipeline
and uh then you know you can select the
pipeline uh job type here now you have
the freestyle pipeline uh github
organization multiple branch pipeline
these are the different options which is
available there but i am going to
continue with the pipeline here as such
so when i selected the pipeline and say
okay so what will happen that i will be
able to see a configuration page which
is related to the pipeline now here the
very important part is that you have all
the uh general build trigger
you know options which is similar to the
freestyle but the build step and the
post build step is completely removed
because of the pipeline introduction now
here you either have the option to put
the pipeline script all together you can
also have some particular example for
example let's talk about some github
maven uh particular uh tool here so you
can see that
we have you know got some steps as such
over here and you know it's pretty much
running over there now you run it it
will work smoothly it will check out
some source code but how we are going to
integrate like the version the jenkins
file into the version control system
because that's the ideal approach we
should be following when we create a
pipeline of a ci cd now i'm going to
select a particular pipeline from a cm
here then go with the git here now in
there the jenkins file is the name of
the file of the pipeline script and i'm
going to put my
repository over here in this one now
this repository is of my gate which is
like having even built pipeline which is
available there it's having some steps
related to ci with for the build and
deployments and that's what we can
follow as such over here now in this one
the uh if it is a private repository
definitely you can add on your
credentials but this is a public
repository a personal repository so i
don't have to put any kind of
credentials but you can always add the
credentials with the help of add here
and that can help you to you know set up
whatever the credentials private
repositories you want to configure now
once you save the configuration here
now what it's going to do is that your
it's going to give you a particular page
related to build now uh if you want to
run if you want to delete the pipeline
if you want to reconfigure the pipeline
all these different options are
available there so we are going to click
on the build now here and when i do that
immediately the pipeline will be
downloaded and will be processed now you
may not be able to get the complete
stage view as of now because it's still
running so yeah you can see that the
checkout code is done then it's going on
to the build okay that's one of the
steps which is there now once the build
will be done so it will continue with
the next steps with the next further
steps there so you can also go to the
console output log here like you can
click on this or you can click on the
console output to check the complete log
which is happening there or in fact you
can also see the stage wise logs also
because that is also very important when
you go for the complete logs uh it may
you know have a lot of steps involved
and you know a lot of logs will be
available there but if you want to see a
specific log of a specific stage that's
where this comes into the picture and as
you can see that all the different uh
steps like test cases executions the
scenar cube analysis the archive
artifacts deployment and in fact the
notification so all this is a part of a
complete pipeline this whole pipeline is
done here and you know you get a kind of
a stage view it's success over here and
the artifacts is also available to
download so you can download this war
file is a web applications as such over
here so this is what our typical
pipeline looks like that how the
automation the complete automations
really looks like as such over here now
this is a very important aspect because
it really helps us to understand that
how the pipelines can be configured can
be done and pretty much with the same
steps you will be able to automate any
kind of pipelines as such so that was
the demo to build a simple pipeline as
such with the jenkins and pretty much in
this one we understood that how exactly
the cic pipelines can be configured and
we can use them and we can get hold on
that part hello and welcome to
continuous integration tutorial using
jenkins my name is chidanand and i am
with the simply learn team today let's
get started with jenkins jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for sun microsystems
way back in early or mid 2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wider option since it
is released under mit license and is
almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pull from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
built being good or built being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
contents integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
would have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your jenkins so jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what i'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or a linux based services so if at all
you have windows like the way i have and
i'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever i install it as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic warp file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt if it
layer on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server would be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration or the
way in which i'm going to run this demo
it is going to be same across any of
these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there is always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
these environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you'll have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into this environment
variables
all right so i've just set in a java
home variable
if you see this sequel and program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located see program files
c program files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i've been i've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if at all i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i am good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
you also have a docker container wherein
you know you can launch jenkins as a
container but i'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into c colon program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running your war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just i don't want to
make any changes into the jenkins
configuration c colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets
stored out here so i'll have to just
copy this path
if i told you you're running as a war
file you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so
if that is not great it will about
it but this looks good
so it's going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation
so you would need to install some
recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is a whole lot of plugins which
are bare essential plugins that is
required for jenkins in order to run
properly so jenkins as a part of the
installation would get all these plugins
and then install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs uh lots of bandwidth in
terms of network so in case your you
know your network is not so good few of
these plugins would kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly
or mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you'll get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 1995 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so i'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and um an email id is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case i don't so i just
given an admin and i got a password i've
got i remember my password this is my
full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
java guy you know how painful it is to
write ui in java you will kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the ui bottom line you are
a little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as manage jenkins
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's probably show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration
this just lets jenkin know at any point
in time how many jobs or how many
threads can be run you can kind of
visualize it like a thread that can be
run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
proud each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn
email notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails and what i've done here is
i've just configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email ids
that is set up for a jenkins server so
you can specify the smtp server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails
but in case you want to try it out like
me i have configured my personal email
id which is on my gmail for sending out
notifications so the smtp server would
be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configuration that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your uh you
know your gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
kens okay one other thing that i want to
kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case i want
jenkins to you know run a java code i
would need to install jdk on it i need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it git if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system
which is your continuous integration
server you will have to come in here and
configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
managing let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization
you would probably want to have a you
know some sort of an ad or an ldap
server using which you would want to
control access to your jenkins
repository rather jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization but for now since i don't
have any of these things i'm going to
use this own database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you'll see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo let me just put in a very very
simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job all right
i don't want to choose any of these
again there are some helps available
here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it to any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in in a while build
the environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
will let me just echo something echo
uh hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the time stamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
would see some build straight out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a time stamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into
if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home
so all the job related stuff that is
specific to this particular jenkins
installation is all here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running
you know there will be individual
folders specific to the jobs that has
been put up here all right so one job
one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server
all right so what i'm going to do i will
just keep everything else the same i'm
going to put in the build script pretty
much similar to
second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github
triggering or hook or a web hook kind of
a triggering later on but for now what i
want to do i want to ensure that this
job that i'm going to put in would be
automatically triggered on its own let's
say every minute i want this job to be
run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two three
four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and is asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users who might
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed in advance as of now we don't
have the role based plugin so let me go
to available it'll take some time for it
to get refreshed all right now these are
the available plugins these are the
install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role-based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way
understandably you want to restart
jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of
big installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your jenkins instance but for
now i don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the
user control or the access control so
let me go into
yes
global security
and i would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role-based uh plugin
so this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy
plugin and i'm going to enable that
strategy all right i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage and gains
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my roles
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role-based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here the rules are at a very high level
these are global rules and there are
some project rules and there are some
slave rules i'll not get into details of
all of this at a very very high level
which is a global role let me just
create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qr guys would need to provide
some sort of you know limited access to
developers so that's why i'm creating a
role called developer and i'm adding
this role at a global role level so i
would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these uh you know
permissions specific to
so what i want is like you know it
sounds a little
different but i would want to give very
very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
check you know have read-only access to
the job run
um no i don't want him to give him any
any particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want to read yes
definitely
and this is the specific role so what
i'm doing i'm just creating a global
role called developer and i'm giving him
very very limited roles
in the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i
would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay
so i would save
now i created a rule
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here i'll say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah
developer1 sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign rules
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular rule so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer one i would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role i want him to
have because this is the global rule
that it created so developer i would
assign this developer 1 to this
particular global rule and i would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer1
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qr person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who's
tagged as a part of this developer role
would get the same kind of permissions
and these permissions can be you know
fine grain it can be a project specific
permissions as well but for now i just
demonstrated the high level permission
that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect a jenkins build you can
build a job on jenkins and push it to
sonar cube and get sonar cube to run
analysis on that and get back the
results in jenkins all of these works
very well because of the plugins now
with that let me connect our jenkins
instance to github i already have very
very simple java repository up on my
github instance so let me connect
jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello java and this is
what is there in the repositories hello
hello.java application that is here or a
simple class file that is there it's got
just one line of system dot out so this
is already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the
url for this repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
stps url so what i would do is i would
connect my jenkins instance to go to
github provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file
i'm keeping the source code very very
simple it's just a java file how do i
build my java file how do i compile my
java file i just say java c and the name
of my
class file which is hello java and how
do i run my java file i would say java
and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because
what it needs is a git plugin so if you
remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git is already
installed on my system so i don't need
to install it again so let me put up a
new job here it says git job it will be
a freestyle project that's good for me i
would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github
and then what would be there as a part
of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot java that is the way i would
build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
kit on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is
my workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i've integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app it's got it's a maven based uh
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it'll compile it will based
upon the goals that you specify it can
compile it can run some tests and it can
you can build a war file and even deploy
it into some other server for now what
we're going to use maven is just for
building and creating a package out of
this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an html file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
i'm going to connect jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is maven because jenkins will
use maven so in order to use maven
jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
jenkins box and in this case the jenkins
box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple uh web server that you
can freely download i'll let you know
how to quickly uh download and install
the tomcat all right so download maven
first
and the various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven there is zip
files
binary zip files and rkf file so what
i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so
mvn hyphen iphone version if i specify
this after i set in my path my one
should work and if at all i echo m2 home
which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my
onenote it is already set here
so once you unzip maven just set this m2
home variable to the directory where you
unzip your i1 also just set the path to
this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat server 8.5 is
what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
is where you download tomcat server and
um
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080. since we
already have our jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port clash
so what i've done i have configured
tomcat to use a different port so if i
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081. so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to tomcat users.xml file
here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my tomcat
server first so i get into my bin folder
i open a command prompt here and there's
a startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
okay my tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository
is uh this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that are
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see
if it connects well if there's any
problem with my war file or the war file
gets created properly
okay
wonderful
so it built a war file and if you see it
all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server
let me go ahead and
install the plugin for the container
deployment so i will go to manage
plugins
available
type in container
container container
to container okay so let's put this the
plugin that i would need i will install
it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that have
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm going to just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step
so after the war file is built as a part
of this package directive let me use
this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify
what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
this tomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular
server so if you remember i had created
a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is same
in web use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this local host
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like the deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins instance and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on
some other server with some other
different ip address all that you got to
go and change is the url of the
server so this would be the server in
case you you already have that uh you
know if you have a tomcat server which
is running on some other machine that's
all fine with a different ipa that's all
good enough the whole bundle or the war
file that was built as a part of this
jenkins job gets transferred onto the
other server and gets deployed that's
the beauty of jenkins and automatic
deployments or other deployments using
jenkins and maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's where you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what he will do is
based upon trigger that has happened to
the job or whichever job needs to be
built he if at all he can delegate these
jobs onto some other machines or some
other slaves you know that's a wonderful
thing to have okay use case one use case
two assuming that you know if you have a
jenkins server that is running on a
windows box or on a linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
windows you know windows based dot net
kind of a projects where you would need
a windows machine to build this
particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
linux linux based systems you also have
a mac you you support some sort of an
apps or something that is built on mac
os you would need to build you know mac
based system as well so how are you
going to support all these needs so
that's where in a beautiful concept of
master slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some sort of triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control a lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple runner or
a slave there's a simple jar file that
is run as a low priority thread or a
process within these systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the master slave
configuration so what i'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is i'll set up
a simple slave but since i don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what i'll do is i will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so i've got the c drive and d drive my
jenkins is on my c drive so what i do is
i would just use my e drive and set up a
very very simple uh slave out there i'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave
let me go back to my jenkins master and
configure him to you know talk to an
agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp java network launch
protocol so using this i would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that i need to
ensure that i kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jlp agent's
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so i'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but java network launch protocol
and you know i'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jlp so for that i need to enable this
guy so i enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so i make him random i make
him you know enabled and i say save this
configuration
all right so now i've configured or made
a setting for the master
so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and
you know create an agent
so i'll go to managed nodes so if you
see here there's only one master here so
let me provision a new node here so this
is the way you know in which you bring
up a new node you have to configure it
on the server jenkins would put in some
sort of security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that he can
connect to our jenkins master so i would
say new node i would give a name for my
node i would say windows
note because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i just give an
identifier saying that windows note i
would say this is a permanent agent i'll
say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system i'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or
not 86
c colon program files
it is indeed 86.
all right jenkins so this is where my
master is running so i don't want the c
drive what i'll do is i'll use something
called as a drive i have another drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether
so i create a folder here called jenkins
node and this is where i'm going to
place my or i'm going to provision my
slave
and i'm going to run him from here so
this is the directory in which i'm going
to provision my slave node so i'm going
to copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or slave so i just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage
how do you want to use this guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs i will only build jobs
with label expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them they
will have to specify this particular
label so imagine this way if i have a
bunch of windows system i name it as
windows star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines i name all these mac agents as
a mac star or something like that and i
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with mac
this node run the mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory i think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands
along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there i need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
[Music]
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
agent.jar
i would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this uh sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically i need to take
this jar file onto the other system
and then
kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or i
cut this i come back to my folder my
jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and i need to use this whole
command
ctrl a ctrl c and then launch this
particular agent so let me bring up a
command prompt right here
and then launched it so i'm saying in
the same folder where there is agent.jar
i'm going to launch this a particular
agent java hyphen.jar agent.jar jnlp
this is the url of my server in case the
server and client are on different
locations or different ips you have to
specify the ipad address all this any
way would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
have connected very well so let me come
back to my
jenkins instance and see you know if you
told me you see earlier this was not
connected now let me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision are jenkins node and then i
copied all the credentials of the
slave.jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of
ran it from there since i don't have
another system i've just got a separate
directory in another folder another
drive and i'm launching the agent from
here as long as this particular agent is
up and running or this command prompt is
up and running the agent would be
connected so once i close this the
connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
jenkins node or the jenkins slave so any
task that i'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it'll create a workspace right here all
right so good
so let me just come back and let me kind
of put up a new task here
i will say that you know delegate job is
good i say freestyle project i'm going
to create a very very simple job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
echo
relegated to the
slave negative two i don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that
i've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label
right so now i'm going to put in a job
that will only match this particular
label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in a windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this
it runs successfully
and where is the workspace the workspace
is right inside our jenkins node it
created a new workspace delegated job it
put in here so my old or my primary
master
job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of master slave configuration or
distributed building jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of us
colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present but we
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there a
bunch of backup plugins so i would
recommend one of these plugins that i
specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin
so let me come back to my
manage plugins
stop this plugin is there so
hang on backup manager so you will see
this option once you uninstall this
plugin so first time i can you know do a
setup i would say backup this particular
i'll give a folder this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want
jks to backup some data
and i would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my
you know backup this is good i want it
in verbose mode i don't want to shut on
my jenkins or should i shut it down no
okay one thing that you got to remember
is that whenever a backup happens if
there are too many jobs that is running
on the server
it can kind of slow down your jenkins
instance because it's it's in the
process of copying few of those things
and the files are being changed at that
moment it's a little bit problematic for
jenkins so typically you backup your
servers only when there is very less
load or typically try to you know bring
it to a shutdown kind of a state and
then take a backup
all right so i'm going to back up all
these things you know i don't want to
exclude anything else i want the history
i want the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save
and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations
so how do i do that i just come back to
my manager and gains
come back to
backup manager and i will say restore
that's an or
jenkins configuration hi guys welcome to
this video on jenkins interview
questions and answers
jenkins is a popular devops open source
automation server
it is used to automate the non-human
part of software development and
supports continuous integration and
continuous delivery
jenkins is a server based system that
runs in servlet containers such as
apache tomcat
we have compiled the most important
jenkins interview questions that you
might face in a jenkins or devops
interview so without further ado let us
get started with jenkins interview
questions and answers so the first
question you'll be asked about with
jenkins is explain a master slave
architecture of jenkins so the way that
jenkins is set up is that the jenkins
master will pull code from your remote
git repository such as github and will
check that repository every time there
is a code commit it will distribute the
workload of that code and the tests that
need to be applied to that code to all
of the jenkins slaves and then on
request the jenkins master and the
slaves will then carry out all the
builds and tests to be able to produce
test reports the next question you'll be
asked is what is a jenkins file and
simply put a jenkins file is a text file
that has a definition of the jenkins
pipeline and is checked into a source
code repository and this really allows
for three distinct things to happen one
it allows for a code review and
iteration of the pipeline it permits an
audit trail for that pipeline and also
provides a single source of truth for
the pipeline which can be viewed and
edited so which of the following
commands runs jenkins from the command
line is it java jar jenkins dot war java
dash war jenkins.jar
java.jar jenkins.jar java
jenkins.org
and the answer is a java dash jar
jenkins dot war so when working with
jenkins you're gonna be asked what are
the key concepts and aspects of working
with the jenkins pipeline and you want
to really hold out your fingers here and
go through
four key areas and that is pipeline node
step and stay so pipeline refers to the
user-defined model of a cd continuous
delivery pipeline node are the machines
which is which are part of that jenkins
environment within the pipeline step is
a single task that tells jenkins what to
do at that particular point in time and
then finally stage defines a
conceptually distinct subset of tasks
performed through the entire pipeline
and tasks could be build test and deploy
so which of the following file is used
to define dependency in maven and do we
have a build.xml
b
palm.xml c
dependency.xml or d
version.xml and the answer is palm.xml
working with jenkins you're going to be
asked to explain the two types of
pipeline used in jenkins along with the
syntax and so a scripted pipeline is
based on groovyscript as their
domain-specific language for jenkins
there are one or more note blocks that
are used throughout the entire pipeline
on the left hand side you can actually
see what the actual script would look
like and the right hand side shows what
the actual declaration for each section
of that script would be the second type
of jenkins pipeline is a declarative
pipeline and a declarative pipeline
provides a simple and a friendly syntax
to define what the pipeline should look
like and then you can actually at this
point use an example to actually break
out how blocks are used to define the
work completed in a decorative pipeline
so how do you create a copy and backup
of jenkins well to create a backup
periodically back up jenkins to your
jenkins home directory and then create a
copy of that directory it's really as
simple as that a question you'll be
asked as well is how can you copy
jenkins from one server to another well
they're essentially there are three ways
to do that one is you can move a job
from one installation of jenkins to
another by copying the corresponding job
directory the second would be to create
a copy of an existing job directory and
making a clone of that job directory but
with a different name and the third is
to rename an existing job by renaming a
directory so security is fundamental to
all the work that we do within devops
and jenkins provides the center core to
all the work that gets completed within
a devops environment there are three
ways in which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a jenkins has its own internal
database that uses secured user data
from end user credentials b is you can
use a ldamp or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate jenkins users or c you can
actually configure jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plug-in within jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
hpi plugin file into the jenkins home
plugins subdirectory you want to remove
the plugins development directory if
there is one you want to create an empty
file called
plugin.hpi dot
and once you've completed these three
steps restart jenkins and your custom
build plugin should be available how can
you temporarily turn off jenkins
security if the administrative user has
locked themselves out of the admin
console this doesn't happen very often
but when it does it's good to know how
you can actually get into jenkins and be
able to resolve the problems of
authenticating effectively into the
system as an administrator so when you
want to be able to get into a jenkins
environment what you want to be able to
do is locate the config file you should
see that it's set to true which allows
for security to be enabled if you then
change the user security setting to
false security will disabled allow you
to make your administrative changes and
will not be re-enabled until the next
time jenkins is restarted
so what are the ways in which a build
can be scheduled and run in jenkins well
there are four ways in which you can
identify the way a build can be
scheduled on running jenkins the first
is when source code management commits
new code into the repository you can run
jenkins at that point the second can be
the after the completion of other builds
so maybe you have multiple builds in
your project that are dependent to each
other and when so many other builds have
been executed then you can have jenkins
run you can schedule build to run at a
specified time so you may have nightly
builds of your code that illustrates the
changes in the solution you're building
and then finally you also can manually
build a environment on request
occasionally you will want to also
restart jenkins and so it's good that
when a question around how do you
restart jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the jenkins
url that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the url for your jenkins
environment
safe restart so with that we have come
to an end of this session on software
testing
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in the session or if
you require the resources that we used
in this session like the code or ppt
then do let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be more than happy to resolve all
your queries at the earliest until next
time thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you